[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
boxes
[Music]
thank you
it's high stakes matches in the
elimination bracket two players will be
knocked out and as the Chess World talks
about the return of Hans Neiman Magnus
Carlsen continues to let chess speak for
itself he's got a big day in office as
he faces his longtime rival world number
three Fabiano caruana
the Fantastic commentators in the studio
are ready we are looking forward to all
the action welcome to the Julius bear
generation cup
[Music]
anymore he blundered his night
it's full of traps you saw the reactions
like oh crap here we go like what is
this kid got in store he's got to be a
check mate right I mean that King
levonne is freaking out he's got five
seconds it's over check man on the board
reacts he celebrates
he is so stressed out he knows he's so
close in this one
[Laughter]
we are expecting another action back
there as three different Generations
continue to battle it out welcome
everyone and we will make sure to keep
you on top of each and every move in the
studio guiding us through all of it
grandma said David Howell
gym Simon Williams and international
Master yvanka Huska Simon we had such a
fantastic day of Chess on day one what
was the biggest surprise for you I had
biggest surprise was probably young
Dennis um I thought he was going to
struggle against the very experienced
Fabiano but he played there extremely
well and it went all the way to the
Armageddon game and even there he missed
the chance to win the whole thing so uh
great play from the young man
fantastic play by Dan Laz there taking
the lead in his match but he did go down
to the elimination bracket after Fabi
won the Armageddon Ivanka was there a
moment that had you on the edge of your
seat there were many moments but one I
can particularly recall was the game the
first game between Magnus Carlson and
Amin tabatabai and there it was actually
Amin tabbed by who was in a winning
position but unfortunately he didn't
spot the win and Magnus then resumed
business and just exerted his dominance
the favorites did exert their dominance
on day one David we had three matches
that wound up in just three games Who
was the player of the day for you well I
want to give a shout out to Wesley so
for being back to his best just smooth
classy chest there but for me it was
actually alireza ferrugia who stood out
I mean his match against Abdul sotorov
we thought it would be the closest on
paper but it was a blowout in the end
three nil and uh just impressive stuff
he's clearly come here to win the
tournament
Wesley so is he back and forth he has
been struggling the last couple of
tournaments but we've seen consistent
performances from him in the Champions
Chester and while the favorites continue
in the Winner's bracket Dennis lazowick
also put on a thrilling show taking the
world number three into an Armageddon
and alireza made it look easy on day one
the a port is still a faint open I
expect this is why uh naughty Beck
hasn't resigned because uh you know it's
quite close to queening he's going for
that pawn now but the night will come to
F7 and rookie six is a big
one it's over I don't think he saw that
man his expression there
it's getting worse and worse Magnus is
just slowly methodically improving his
pieces look at that the Knight and F5
was glorious but it was in the way of
White's Queen and Rook so he Maneuvers
it takes two Tempe well spent
there we go breakthrough wow did you see
that it's just
accurate right
oh my god oh he's enjoying himself a bit
too much here that's it it's done Magnus
Carlsen takes the victory I'm in
tabatabai resigns he needs to survive
without losing a piece to move 126 here
Dennis lazovic another 20 moves that is
David we're at move hundred and six
right now 10 seconds left though to do
that I mean it's not a lot of time 15
moves away but he's about to get checked
who is coming up he loses the bishop I
think fappy's done it unbelievable
is uh crazy right there we go Fabiano
takes the win he was winning on the
board he also won on the clock and
relief on his face
and Fabiana carwana is one of the four
players who has booked his seat in The
Season's final along with Magnus Carlsen
who's had two Champions chest or
victories this season he is looking for
that hat trick in this one Hikaru
Nakamura who won the chessable Masters
though he had a tough day uh on day one
he has won the chess kit cup and with
that we'll be playing in Toronto four
seats remain two tournaments still to go
the heat is on and there we see a
bracket with Magnus playing against uh
Fabiano in the winner semi-final Wesley
so against firuja
in the losers round one we've got Amanda
by Dana slazovic Elya nov Abdus who have
been knocked down to the elimination
bracket David who are you most surprised
to see in the elimination bracket well I
guess I'm not necessarily surprised but
disappointed that lazovic has ended
there because he deserved he was so
close to so much more but uh lazovic I
think has great chances in his match the
other three in the elimination bracket
they need to up their game it hasn't
been good enough none of them scored any
wins there so uh today yeah it's crunch
time yeah a lot of players seemed off
form didn't they yesterday in in that
bracket in that loses section so uh
it'll be interesting to see if they can
improve and start playing some proper
chess today yeah after all it's still a
best of two so the players will have to
sharpen up I'm especially looking
forward to seeing whether nordeback
Abdul satorov can defeat Pavel elianov
big matches but it's not only in
division one that there's so much on the
line of course the big seat the big aim
is the big seat in the 500 000 final and
four players in division two and three
There Are Tour points as well as the big
ticket to the next division one where
they can fight to get to Toronto and
there are some big names fighting for
that a bunch of players including
Vladimir fantasy of including Levon
aronian and also the world championship
Challenger yeah
division two saw some action as Jan
napomnishi blazed past Grandmaster
Maxime chagayev after picking up a
victory in the first game and a draw in
the second the third game Saw nepo
playing something you don't see very
often nepo went on an incredible King
run marching marching's King from one
side of the board to the other where it
remained relatively safe for the rest of
the game maneuvering his Knights nepo
won a pawn and eventually the game now
is the end of the game in division three
Legends clashed it was gattacamski vs
Vladimir kramnik on move 11 kramnik
sacrificed his Queen although the
outcome was in kamsky's favor after a
few more trades campski proved that it
is far superior to have a queen and a
rook compared to a rook a knight in a
bishop from there kamski pressed and
earned Victory against the former world
champion
famous and fighting it out there against
big blood in division three but look at
that in division two we had some big
results and one that stands out is Alexi
Serrano's win over nehal Serena three
zero resounding Victory but David the
scoreline doesn't tell the full story
that's right it was heartbreak for
Nissan
uh the first two games he simply could
not get his fair play camera working he
lost those first two games by default
and by the time it was working in game
three he actually managed to amass a
winning position before Mouse slipping a
rook so three nil doesn't tell the whole
story knew how sarin will now be
grateful that he has another life in
this tournament a heartbreaker day for
nehal but this is double elimination
bracket so he can still fight that
meanwhile these are the matchups in
division two David what is the big fight
that we're looking forward to in this
one big names all Lacrosse Big names all
around but for me it is that clash
between janapomnishi former World
Championship Challenger of course
against Vladimir fedesev whose very high
now up there on the overall tour
standings this season high stakes and
both players still with the chance if
they do well here to qualify for those
tour finals
winning two events it has opened up
another spot in the tour standings with
these players division to Super critical
matches but not just that Ivanka we've
got big action in division three as well
we have big names big games you have to
remember there are a lot of big players
playing and take a look at some of them
and we can see already there's some
standout ones back row is facing Shakira
mamajarov and if you go right down to
the bottom we see Ming lay online speech
specialist he is taking on a niche Gary
Gary so big big matchups there you don't
want to miss any of that you can follow
division two coverage on chess dojo's
Channel and division 3 coverage on a
Grand Master a Ben feingold's Channel
and speaking of big games the big story
in the Chess World has been chascom
reinstating Hans Neiman and we asked
Magnus his views on the breaking news
I do for my
um opponent today as well that um you
know even though
um
um even though the last two games
weren't so good
um perhaps with the
some some changes you know some new
people
to to work with better influences maybe
you can um
he can play even better
Magnus uh you're saying better
influences are you talking about Hansen
even right now
uh I'm I'm talking about influences in
in general
all right foreign
regarding Hans and we'll see him return
to competition soon uh one year ago
exactly in the Julius bear generation
cup we all were here and we saw what
happened what were your thoughts on this
next chapter in The Saga and especially
if he comes to compete in the Champions
chess store next
no comments
better influences a bit of a cryptic
response there by Magnus followed with a
no comment on the whole situation David
how does Magnus keep this separate from
the chess on the board what is his
mindset coming into this tournament well
I guess throughout chess history Tanya
chess has been littered with all these
rivalries you don't necessarily like
your opponents often some of the top
players they actually hate each other
but they are able to differentiate that
from the chest itself and uh just that
level of focus that they have uh it's uh
almost superhuman so yeah somehow he's
able to kind of focus on the board
despite the fact sometimes uh this
bubbling rivalries there I mean he's
clearly talking about hands isn't he but
it but it's it's good yeah I mean now
we've got like you know the the good and
the bad or should we say the rebel and
they're fighting again and it's going to
be exciting I think the next couple of
months to to see what happens yeah I
completely agree it will be exciting and
uh Magnus has been on record in 2019 for
uh saying actually that he played
exceptionally well even though there was
a lot of drama in his personal life
we will be seeing him on the board later
today in the winners uh semi-finals
where Magnus Carlsen takes on Fabiano
caruana that is an age-old rivalry a
huge clash between uh two greats of the
game World number one taking on world
number three but that's not all a really
exciting matchup between Wesley so and
alireza farouza as well it will be all
eyes on the Magnus a Fabi matchup
uh Simon two players with big big
history including a world championship
match what are you expecting on the
board today well this is going to be a
great match to watch I mean uh like you
said they play for the world
championships in 2018 and they're back
again playing here and they've both been
uh playing great chess over the last
year I mean you have to put Magnus as as
favorite the way he's playing but if uh
Fabiano brings his game then you could
see a surprise it's going to be very
interesting he has been bringing his
game he's had some fantastic
performances including finishing third
in the World Cup he did mention that he
missed playing against Magnus in the
finals in the world cup so he is looking
forward to this one but it's not only a
big day for Magnus and Fabi it is a big
big match for Wesley so as well as well
because this is his part to the
Champions chess store finals getting
that seat into the Toronto season's
final event if he wins today against
alireza faruja he sees the the deal it
is done he gets a ticket to Toronto the
other scenario if Dennis lazovic loses
to Amin tabatabai it doesn't matter what
happens in Wesley's game he's through
already because he will be uncatchable
with the door points uh
Simon what do you make of the situation
is this big pressure on Wesley or he
knows that he can also count on another
board to get that seat into Toronto I
don't think it's too much pressure I
mean he played really well yesterday as
David said and I think he he's really
experienced so he's just gotta do the
same thing he's used to playing he's
probably a bit more pressure pressure on
young Dennis because uh he'd love to get
that place right and he's got to avoid
losing again today so uh Wesley he can
relax plays normal stuff and I think
he'll be all right
playing farouja what a matchup that's
also Cloud Styles Ivanka it is a clash
of styles and also a very scary match
because yeah and yesterday farrugia had
like an accuracy of 96 which is insane
but uh yeah well Wesley can just relax
and just focus on the one thing you need
to do play good chess he has to forget
about qualifying for Toronto what a
fantastic winner semi-finals bracket
we've got there with two very juicy
matchups but that's coming up later we
do start with the losers uh semi-finals
with
was so impressive in his match against
Fabi on day one taking the lead and then
we also have Pavel eliano who will be
playing not a backup to satro of another
Clash of generations there uh David on
paper not a back a favorite but he was
so shaky on day one yeah not a Beck just
didn't seem to be at his best he was
taking a lot of risk but it backfired
and didn't pay off eliano however has
been in uh tough form lately he didn't
do so great at the world rapid Team
Championships he had a very difficult
day against Wesley so it's just about
who starts faster in this best of two
matchup if elianov can start with a
decent opening I think he'll have his
chances but if not then I do fear for
his chances
it's going to be an interesting fight
when the 40 year old eliano takes on the
18 year old not the back of the satro
and we also have a clash between two
very young players Amin tabatabai
playing against the youngest player to
make it to division one this season uh
Dennis last week yo be Dennis was so
impressive yesterday but amen as well
had his chances against Magnus he had
one chance in game one after that Magnus
was relentless but yeah you're right it
was a much more evenly matched a match
rather than the score suggesting uh but
you know I'm expecting fireworks the
pair of players are both young ambitious
and there is a best of two so anything
can happen I suspect we might see
Armageddon oh we'd love it if the matcha
went down to the wire the bidding
armageddon's can be so exciting to watch
I'm intaba to buy a very aggressive
player Dennis last week a very technical
player so a clash of styles there as
well it is a different format in the
elimination bracket with it just being a
best of to the margin for era for the
players here is zero they are on their
last life you lose and you're out of the
Julius bear generation cup it will be a
best of two one and a half points wins
the match they start with 15 minutes a
three second increment if you win your
match you advance through to the losers
quarter finals
if you lose you are out of the Julius
pair generation car in case of a 1 1 tie
we will go down to the bidding
Armageddon the clocks are ticking the
players are getting ready uh there we
have them I'm in and then last on the
screen I haven't started why do you guys
think that I'm in Saw magnus's interview
and how would that affect his mind Zone
well there's no way that I mean didn't
see magnus's interview it was all over
social media and chess players we know
uh keep up to date with everything uh
meanwhile it's actually a repeat of uh
well it's deja vu for Dennis lazovic
because Tabata by is taking a leaf out
of Carolina's book this is what we call
the anti-berlin it's a variation of the
royal Lopez the Spanish opening and uh
here with blacks doubled pawns on the C
file the lack of Bishop power for white
it does take a slower turn this game uh
so I mean here certainly must have done
his homework must have a special idea up
his sleeve because lots of it came out
of those openings with uh well in decent
shape uh what do you think here Simon We
Peg I mean here as a kind of very
aggressive player but he's chosen a
slower approach to this game yeah and uh
yeah like you mentioned we saw lots of
uh clashes in this uh particular
variation and this B6 move again when we
had a Fabiano with the white pieces
trying to break down Dennis in in this
position so I agree Amin must have
something prepared and he's maneuvering
his Knight around now maybe
um he can back it up by playing the
center which he's he's trying to do here
with this C3 move and uh this is a new
move right because remember Carolina
actually tucked the king into the corner
and uh tried to blast open the Santa
with a potential f2f4 now while white is
being a lot more direct and now
threatening D4 directly and I like this
move by Dennis lazovic just developing
the bishop to the edge of the board and
preventing this Pawn break in the center
this one is fire from the very start a
lot of offensive play by both these
players as we can see the queen under
attack but we've got action starting on
the other board as well as the very
experienced Eleanor who's worked with
some of the best players in the world
for World Championship matches including
Boris girlfriend including Magnus
Carlsen and the music sisters he takes
on the youngest ever World rapid
Champion Elena of an opening specialist
how important will it be for nordeback
to get out safely and navigate the
opening safely in this one well that's
the thing uh safety is not in his
vocabulary Tanya Andrew Satora Futures
plays the most aggressive ideas these
days it definitely feels as we mentioned
yesterday like he's feeling out his
boundaries here just scoping out how
much risk he can take against the best
players in the world and okay it is a
Queen's Gambit declined by transposition
here so very solid start and here we see
the semi-tarash variation
um yeah very theoretical maybe he kind
of has learned from yesterday when he
felt defeat against veruga this is known
as a very solid approach for black
um so yeah definitely two opening
Specialists who uh in a two-game match
just have come come armed with specific
kind of Concepts here at the early
stages Black's now going to give a check
we'll see a lot of pieces traded off set
of knights already off the board Bishops
and white has the strong Pawn Center but
black is Rock Solid ahead in development
as well slightly
early days but actually I think this one
shows that both players are a bit cagey
uh maybe feeling slightly nervous
heading into this encounter yeah and uh
there we see the light Square Bishop
develop towards the center both players
moving very very quickly and I can tell
you from experience from playing this
position from the white side it's a
tough not to crack this one I've rarely
gotten an opening advantage
yeah this is known as one of the most uh
Rock Solid defenses for black not
necessarily the most ambitious but
essentially if you look at the pawn
structure white has Pawn extra Pawns in
the center black SX reports on the queen
side so long term black is actually
doing very well those two black pawns on
the A and B file will often start
running very quickly in an end game and
uh White Pawn Center either very strong
or potentially vulnerable uh Simon do
you have much experience in this type of
structure yeah Fair bit and um I I think
there's been some good plan shown in
this structure if you go back and look
at some of the classic games I know uh
Tau has has demonstrated a plan where
white can sacrifice support by pushing
D5 and then pushing the other Pawn
forwards to start King side attack
um you can also use your your H Pawn uh
funnily enough surprising that to try
and uh probe Black's position a bit but
the the starting stage is put your Rooks
in to the middle of the board but the
main thing I think white tries to do is
to play at the right moment this this
Advance where he's got more pawns and
that is the advanced D5 and this can
involve just trying to get a pass Pawn
or as a sacrifice and uh I believe the
sacrificial idea is is supposed to be a
bit more dangerous Magma's actually won
a nice game by using another plan here
in one of the champions tour a couple of
years ago where he used his a pawn and
you can do that as well if you want to
play a bit more positional so the pawn
right on the left hand side you can
throw up the board to try to do
something on the queen side as well so
you can actually use White playing every
side of the board I mean I really like
this position as white but it is
considered to be very solid for black as
well as as you've mentioned here so um
we have to wait and see now what White's
going to do king side Center or queen
side
possible white can play
I neutralize
shayoi in these positions you said
you've got some experience here yeah I
mean usually black just connects the
works and waits and see what kind of
approach that white takes so of course
if you push the pawn in the middle of
the board is going to be all about
blockading that pawn and then just
corralling it when you can and if white
does go for the king side attack look
look look that's a roving Brook it's
headed to the king side as David is
indicating but obviously you're gonna
have to take some stages to defund
against that
yeah and uh I always hate it actually
when I can play on three sides of the
board I just want one plan one logical
consistent plan but uh yeah sometimes
it's hard to pick here Eliana has chosen
and it's clear now he wants to maybe
maybe move this Knight out of the way a
bit later he might jump forward if given
the opportunity and then this Rook will
slide uh across and just Simon you
mentioned this one plan for example
let's say black just makes a move let's
say I push a pawn uh the plan at some
point will be for example a centralizer
rook uh it's going to be stepping
forward and then yeah pushing the other
Pawn as well yeah and the White Knight
has a beautiful Square then in the
center of the board and uh this is kind
of keys as you can show here you don't
have to take that pawn back you can play
this move and I think it's actually the
first person who played this idea was
pogreski and I've probably butchered his
name but uh a brilliant uh theoretician
and uh this is where you can get a very
dangerous attack with a knight coming in
The Rook swinging over and that pawn on
E5
um is is a very dangerous little thing a
little unit you can open up your
opponent's position with so another play
land there that white can try and you
know this is why I really like playing
this position is why I like attacking
and uh you've got many options to do
that but blacks also played quite a
sensible idea David just uh preparing to
to defend against some of those ideas
and attack it apart yeah it does invite
white to actually push forward not the
Deep one but also the e-pawn as well in
order you can't do it now because the
Knight will jump to D5 and attack The
Rook but bear in mind this could be a
possibility because white can set up as
some kind of battery with the bishop
going down back to C2 and the queen
going to D3
so this is a another idea that I've seen
yeah and uh here okay he just backs up
his Pawn Center uh this Pawn is defended
by two Rooks if black takes it would
just be a trade of material but white
would be left with two minor pieces
versus a rook and pawn that tends to be
uh better for the minor pieces there so
uh defending everything sufficiently and
black is a bit stuck I'm expecting to
see moves such as roots E8 just very
standard uh maybe Queen to E7 although
that's lining up against the white Rooks
yeah it's tough finding plans that's the
name again and not easy for either side
right now
um I very much like how Eliana has
approached this despite the fact he kind
of went into the tank for a few minutes
uh he has stumbled across a very nice
plan and uh clearly taken Abdus tour of
out of his homework I think it's kind of
player ilearnoff who would know these
classical games you know he's put of the
older generation and I think they
learned in a slightly different way like
they learned by looking at more whole
games rather than concentrating on
opening ideas so
it strikes me these middle game ideas
he'd be he'd be well used to he's used
to uh knowing about basically it's it's
interesting you say that Simon because
I'm just checking the data and I can see
there are no games in my database but
this exact position so I think it's the
plans isn't it you don't need to know
the you know the actual position but the
plans behind the position is the key the
key thing to to know about yeah
definitely and uh there we see black
playing a move that David suggested just
moving The Rook to the center
the speed with which nutterback is
responding to Elya Nova playing out
these plans that we've been discussing
is also shows that notaback is feeling
quite comfortable in these positions and
Simon you mentioned about uh generation
and their styles of play and you know
were very principal players and of
course very familiar with these
structures knows the plan but you also
think for the younger generation today
they're so much more adaptive and
resilient and sort of ready to change it
up but also feel comfortable in
positions that they're not super
familiar with is that a characteristic
that perhaps marks the current
generation yeah I mean they seem to know
everything they seem to be very com be
very confident play very quickly and
like you say be a good Universal Players
you know attack defense they seem to
calculate their way out and I think
that's primarily because they're just
taking the position on a move by move
basis and they're just kind of almost
kind of computing all these long
variations and just working out really
quickly I would say this is especially
true for the young Indian generation
that seems to be the school of
calculation there and uh for the older
generation it's more about plans
assignments as you know knowing where to
put your pieces how to generate an
attack and in this kind of situation
knowing how to wait in a good way
chances becomes so concrete and
calculation based now with computers
with the younger generation what is uh
David you you have a lot of experience
with not about playing against him what
would you say is not a back's biggest
trend
the lack of fear I mean he's just not
deferential at all that's why at 17
years old he was able to take down a lot
of the world's Elite on the way to
becoming World rapid champion and uh
yeah calculation as well I think you'll
write Ivanka I would say some of the
Indian players may be slightly ahead of
him there but somehow he just knows
where the pieces go especially when he
gets that chance to seize the initiative
he never seems to let the momentum go
um so especially when he's on the front
foot I would say he's one of the best
players in the world already but still
some work to do of course on certain
types of end games slower kind of
maneuvering positions
I mean I'm I'm saying this about one of
the best players out there just uh
nitpicking here but uh yeah I mean he's
he's there to stay clearly at the top
and so confident as well um yeah that's
his biggest thing yeah Fearless player
another backup de Santa it's strange to
say but he's not the youngest
participant in this tournament it is 16
year old Dennis last week and he is
playing against a 22 year old I'm in
tawa Dubai let's check in with that a
lot has happened uh David perhaps you
can just take us through how we got here
it's already an end game on the board
Simon is not happy
oh damn I got back to bed I think when I
see this this is uh I mean this is what
happens in uh the the Berlin a lot right
I mean the pieces get hoovered off and
they shake hands have a draw and that's
it basically is that gonna happen here
David uh possibly possibly although I
will say that I slightly prefer White's
position just because uh of the pawn
structure but let's jump in as Tanya
said uh we have a lot of time left on
the clock for both players I think this
was a means preparation so I'm going to
rewind back to the middle game here and
show how the pieces were uh hoovered
vacuumed off the off the board here in
this position Amin dropped his Knight
back opening up this tension between the
Queens we kind of left it just before
this moment and suddenly the Queens came
off not just that a set of minor pieces
came off and normally you don't want to
part with Bishops but here it's a bit
blocked so it makes sense to trade off
white tonight there and then suddenly a
set of Pawns came off the board
everything uh disappearing and we see
why opening up the center Knights also
disappearing and uh this is pretty much
the position we're left with and just to
highlight the kind of Contours of this
position it's all about the fact that
Black's isolated porn in the center
could potentially be a target for
White's Bishop still takes a bit of work
but you can maneuver this bishop around
and this is why I think white has a
small advantage but just the fact that
it's opposite color Bishops just the
fact that uh black is so active here
right now means that he should be able
to hold the balance I don't think you
should go too passive necessarily I
think ideally you want all the Rooks off
the board and the black king to somehow
uh head towards the center defending
this weakness then black is safe but uh
in the meantime still Dennis lazovic
with the one uh he's the one answering
the small questions
and this is his first time in division
one and we sort of seen him struggle a
little bit with the clock uh even in his
match against Fabi the positions looked
good A lot of times but he was behind on
the clock is is that going to be a
factor today as well because I mean he's
got double the amount of time
he has double the amount of time and
also I just kind of want to piggyback on
David's point I also think he has I'm
gonna get Brave here and say the much
better position he's the one playing for
two results and the only reason I'm
saying this is because take a look at
the opposing poor majorities blacks one
on the left side of the board it's very
difficult to mobilize whereas white for
white is so much more easier you can
just March those pawns up the board and
I think David just hit the nail on the
head it's going to be all about
attacking that weak Pawn in the middle
and just imagine a situation where the
bishop is attacking that ball The Rook
is defending well basic maths my math is
not that great but Bishop were three
points Rick worth Five Points well only
white can be much better and we have a
feature chat there Dennis must be
heartbroken from yesterday but I think
there were so many positives as well
David to take away from that match the
fact that he took the lead winning that
game three had his chances in all the
game and the Armageddon could have been
a completely different story yeah so
near yet so far and I think Dennis
lazovic has to take a leaf out of
magnus's book we talked about it earlier
just separating the emotion from the the
moves themselves from the chest itself
and uh I did I think he's capable of
doing so he plays so much online and
that kind of uh kind of conditions you
if you play hundred kind of Blitz Games
in one session it conditions you to
forget about the losses forget about the
setbacks you just focus on the here and
now and uh Dennis the one thing I'll say
for him is it is his type of position
it's very technical and he has specific
things to aim for
um it's not all necessarily about
tactics attacks which I think is what
admin should be doing stylistically
against his younger opponent but uh yeah
interesting that I mean it's not taking
too much risk I think it's just a sign
of respect to Young Dennis
I really like that move by Dennis this
last move putting that Bishop only for
controlling that D1 Square so that
White's Rook can't really come and
activate itself start targeting the E5
Pawn from that D5 Square so it's uh it's
a simple move but it's got it's got its
own idea uh Simon would you agree that
this kind of an end game it's really
something that Dennis feels comfortable
in and is draw the most likely result
here uh yes and yes
um basically I'm I mean Dennis has shown
that he he plays in this what what you
would say 20 years ago Very Old Man
style you know very mature style play
for the ending avoid the tactics and uh
he's only like 15 year old uh child but
he he has a great understanding of these
types of positions and a great uh
positional style to his play and uh it's
very hard to beat we saw
um him compete with Fabiano caruana the
really experienced Fabiano yesterday and
he competed on the same level he nearly
beat him in the Armageddon game and you
know Fabi is is
um you know twice his age has World
Championship experience under his belt
and he was he was grinding them down the
only time he lost his was in a tactical
battle so so I think he's I think he's
going to hold this position and just
because he he seems it it seems his kind
of position and I'm in going into this I
can understand why he did it because you
have a safe Advantage I mean it is an
advantage I think you know because that
Pawn is weak but it is opposite color
Bishops and Tanya that Bishop A4 move
was as you pointed out was a great move
I think
yeah maybe I'm wrong is anyone think
this is going to be a win I think anyway
I think it's going to be a win
I must say jaded because I once went to
a lecture by a Norwegian Grandmaster
Janet vikama and he loves Rooks with
opposite color Bishops and he says
they're not just drawn just because
they're the opposite color Bishops are
on the board you said you've got to look
at it in terms of the many plans so it's
not going to be about moves it's going
to be about whether each side can slowly
improve the position and take I mean I
do like what Dennis is doing that's very
accurate but white can just like stop
pushing those balls start trying to
probe the black position come in with
the King and there's just no way that
black is gonna get active
I agree with everything that you've said
Ivanka but I'm gonna take you on on this
one I think this is going to end in a
draw uh I agree that white seems to have
all the drums and of course if you take
the Rooks off the board it's a draw on
the spot but as long as there are a set
of major pieces Rooks and queens or even
just Rooks opposite color Bishop the
game is in over but I'm still with Psy
on this one I think this is going to end
in a draw it's a good time to switch
over because David the queens and the
action is on uh on the alienov board
yeah I'll just mention before we moved
on that uh I'm in Juventus Court I think
this one will go on a long time
should we should we have a little glass
of wine on it at some point yes yeah
okay so um I love David buy me glasses
of wine it's one of my favorite hobbies
so um that would be that'd be nice okay
Bet on that's awesome
good good uh meanwhile I don't think we
should bet on this one because it looks
crazy and then Anything Could Happen uh
since we last left it black has started
expanding on the queen side makes sense
you want to push pawns on the side
you're stronger and black has that two
versus one majority on the queen side
whereas elianov he's planted his Knight
in the center I like white tonight there
but still a bit loose and what's his
plan going to be
um it feels like this is potentially a
crunch moment a key moment just in terms
of uh who's going to be more kind of
decisive here who's going to kind of
make the other one blink first I'm
wondering what I do I'll do satoros
calculating
looks like he's trying to work something
out black looks like you've kind of
maximized all your pieces but what next
and uh also the clock big big factor
potentially uh over the next few moves
should we do a kind of around the table
here who do we prefer and why
um yeah I mean I mean initially always
drawn to White because I I like having
the center I like having the attacking
chances when I play so it's probably a
personal thing but
um so I'm gonna I'm gonna have to say
white but
I I don't know if I really believe that
as well because because you've got you
basically got one or two plans there I
mean that that Rook coming over it's
quite blunt and this is uh this is the
one plan I I would be concentrating here
if I was white you do have blacks played
H6 so you have a little what we call a
hook maybe so that's sort of a Target
that we can aim for but if Rook G3 works
great but if it doesn't work I'm not
sure I'm a great fan of what white is
doing here black seems to have got quite
a lot of counter playing the other side
of the board but you know I I would just
play Richie free and pray that would be
my my idea here
threatening Queen takes H6 due to a pin
here Simon you mentioned just uh before
we ask for Ivanka and Tanya's opinions
here just uh this other idea of using
this Pawn to blow open the king side but
risky stuff risky stuff yeah okay Ivanka
I want your opinion on this position you
know I've had a very similar position my
best with the white pieces and I did not
win I did not even get an attack so I'm
gonna say black I mean I like Black's
activity there on the left and we do see
Simon's move on the board very blunt
throughout of the queen coming to H6
grabbing that pawn but uh I'm expecting
the black king to get out of Dodge and
maybe even run towards towards the
center
yeah I mean the F7 Point there's a
couple of weak points aren't there in
Black's position here you you got the
the hook H6 but you've got F7 as well so
it's uh it's weather this attack will uh
cause black enough problems I think or
if black can Count Strike in the middle
Tanya
divide our vote here we need and this
one I'm with Ivanka uh I've also played
these positions with the white pieces
and I just feel like they look really
pleasant but long term black has got
this harmony centralized rook and also
always keep in mind I know it's a far
off dream but those Queen side bonds
that black has the A and the B Pawn in
end games once they start pushing B4
coming in it can be a big distraction
and for white to handle those pawns and
keep those Central pawns defended can be
a bit of challenge there is a threat on
the board Queen 86 once that's buried
and David I will throw that to you what
is the right way for black to get out of
that also looking at the clock situation
I picked black as well yeah uh I just
using pattern recognition here it looks
like a grinfeld but Pawn structure
um for players familiar with that for
the viewers at home yeah the grinfeld
often long-term Black's doing well but
short term white has the dynamism uh
let's go to the threats of course a pin
meaning that Queen takes Pawn is a
deadly deadly threat right now I only
see two ways to get out of that you have
to either move the king uh as Ivanka
highlighted you cannot go towards the
corner where you want to hide because
this F7 Pawn is uh loose then so King f8
and yeah it feels a bit weird it feels
unnatural okay there we go it has just
been played I was going to say the other
alternative would be to attack the white
Rook with your knight but this does feel
loose and you would have to reckon how
all this Knight is going to get back
into the game a bit later on uh maybe
you just kind of yo-yo back and forth
you keep trying to harass this Rook but
evaluation bar reacts so this is why
audition Torah steered away from this
maybe afraid of some potential tactics
against this Knight some sacrifices uh
opening up the black King David did you
answer the question who would you rather
be I mean
I would say you're probably gonna go for
black but that'd be like might be my
guess about you know me too well so am I
the only I'm the only person here who's
saying I I'm a bit outnumbered aren't I
I'm the 25 percenter come on come on
Pavel Checkmate wins the game so that is
the one who's going for the king so
totally get that exactly just go for the
king and and try to check mate I mean
it's simple it's look how simple though
Simon when you look at the clock ticking
down as well I mean how are you going to
continue as and we did see David
indicate a move I move the Rook one
square to the left to attack the Knight
it's not that simple I agree because uh
black black does have this pressure in
the middle and I don't want to play that
move because uh you're kind of offering
a draw here aren't you you're basically
saying well if black now moves the king
back we'll we take a draw and black is
playing for the win with that last move
so I don't I don't like that Retreat you
move that is a you know you can't as
soon as you start playing negatively in
these types of positions I don't know if
there's a better move it wasn't easy
you're right but as soon as you start
going negative it it backfires doesn't
it once you've taken care of all these
direct threats Ivanka would you say it's
easier to play with black because the
plan is simple right you got your Rooks
in the middle and the queen type
majority exactly and uh look we can see
it happening right now we did see an
audio back pause but that's whether you
know he and he decided Well the best
thing to do is try and take it into an
end game and this is what it was all
about right this is where we have gone
wrong we've had this on our board very
similar positions and I think that's why
both of us uh picked black here because
even though visually white looks like
you're on the offense Simon has I'm with
black now now the Queens are off I'm
changing my mind goodbye Queens I'm on
black side now definitely so why did the
Queens come off it was so disappointing
yeah sometimes I mean once you pick an
opening you have to be consistent with
the philosophy behind that opening and
here with white you have the center you
have the attack you have to commit and
go all in sometimes it doesn't pay off
we've all been there when the attacks
fail but uh yeah this time
just notice how Abdus tour of his world
pouncing on the bit of indecision on the
weakness that Eliana showed by kind of
just wasting two Tempe instantly he
replied didn't even hesitate instantly
getting the Queen's off because he knew
the black king is much more vulnerable
than the white king and now it will
never get checkmated it's closer to the
center he's basically gained two moves
for free and okay that black B Pawn
isn't going anywhere yet but watch out
for it later White's a bit stuck maybe
you have to go for that pawn sooner or
later but your Pawn Center as white will
start collapsing okay he takes time to
secure his Center there but Abdul
sotorov now has a valuable temper to
improve his pieces yeah and he does have
to take some care though because white
is actually threatening to slide The
Rook to the B3 square and attack the
pawn so he has to preempt that move and
think of ways to defend Black's biggest
asset the B4 Pawn
yeah looks like maybe you can move the
black bishop and then just put a black
Rook behind the V Pawn a bit later on
maybe there are more accurate ways here
I think I like that yeah you want to get
rid of White's most active piece in the
center and right now you're threatening
actually to capture it because notice
how The Rook on D1 is pinned as well a
really nice positional trade here David
exactly I was about to say White's night
is the strongest piece uh so why not
trade it off Black's night was kind of
rendered a bit useless just by this last
Pawn push from White putting the pawn on
F3 it often dominates a knight on F6 so
uh yeah really instructive play there
from obtuse and he's now gaining squares
on the open C file for the black Rook to
enter
two minutes should still be manageable
here for Aliano to hold the balance but
momentum has been turning okay Knight
back to D3 interesting attacking Black's
past Pawn what do you make of this
eliana's playing well actually despite
the fact he didn't go for that direct
attack yeah I mean Rook C3 looks quite
scary to me as initial move and pinning
the Knight down and uh Black is Black is
very active on that open sea file right
so uh and the B Pawn is also can move
and uh the Black Knight might even have
it has a weigh-in via B6 C4 I'm just
wondering if it can you know at the
moment also consider other routes but I
don't know Brook C3 seems like a
a very natural move but okay this this
is Could Be Clever getting the Rook
behind what I say it could be clever it
looks really odd does it invite some
simplifications because first reaction
is take the pawn yeah and the idea is to
jump out the way with the bishop opening
a discovered attack against the White
Knight but what if this is captured uh
I'm not sure which way it should be
captured first of all
let's say I take with the bishop I want
to take with the pawn but I'm slightly
worried that this Pawn will be
vulnerable in the center
so let's say I take with the bishop is
black going to win this position I guess
only black can win this position that's
that's probably why uh Black's playing
for this kind of position I mean it may
be a draw but
um the Knight is actually better than
the bishop and these kind of structures
because all the pawns are generally on
one side and that is a very weak Pawn in
the center of the board I mean this
looks like it might be happening as well
and uh it's uh it's kind of like that
two result game I mean white can never
win such a position as this unless black
does something horribly wrong see yeah
um one minute on the clock for eliano
and maybe the only way to draw this
would be some direct action with a move
like D5 but here you have to calculate
you have to uh be kind of 100 sure here
you're not losing a pawn due to a pin
for example on the D file so still some
work to do if he needs to trade off
without losing a pawn here Eliana but
under one minute definitely some
pressure on ignore the evaluation bar
which says completely level it's
definitely white answering the questions
as you say Simon it's a two result game
only black can ever win this position
and uh yeah with five and a half minutes
uh added here uh kind of extra on the
clock for Abdus tour of looks really
Pleasant okay he's going for this idea
really clever there Eliana I've got to
say
this must be his idea yeah as you said
David and he's managed to swap some
Rooks off and uh if he can just get rid
of some more pawns and most of the
danger should be and if he can trade off
the minor pieces then it will be an
elementary draw
yeah black snipe potentially slightly
better than this white Bishop the white
Bishop blocked in by its pawns so it's
going to be difficult to trade those off
but yeah I agree Ivanka that should be
one of the goals uh one of the aims here
yeah it's not easy if black had one or
two more moves if Black Knight was
already centralized if the Black Brook
could somehow go and land on white
second rank then maybe some chances but
this one feels like it should be safe
enough
the question is 40 seconds it's not a
lot you might get tricked especially
with a night hopping now threatening to
win a pawn due to this pin on the D file
I think first kind of look here first
glance I don't see an easy way to save
the pawn for Eliana
he needs to be quite creative here I
think to hold the balance 20 seconds
calm king move wow
yeah he's banking on just holding the
position upon down and uh are we going
to see moves like E5 is that his idea
this is quite an important moment
because I I don't know if I play E5 or
try to simplify by taking and yeah I'd
imagine this this is the way to go when
it's supposed to be a draw uh four pawns
versus three on the king side as a win
technically and three versus two is
supposed to be a draw but you know I
wouldn't I wouldn't like defending this
either you know it doesn't be a
nightmare just sitting here forever I'm
trying to surprise that Eliana traded
off Rick so
I mean yeah obviously
earlier renowned trainer he knows it's
end games
hand it over to our resident in-game
expert oh
[Laughter]
um yeah this one as Simon says I think a
lot of players know it's a draw but we
don't know how to draw it I must say
I've never studied this uh this exact
end game I've had it a couple of times
actually when I was a lot younger and
both times I was able to win with the
Knight but that was maybe against uh
inaccurate defense I like what eliana's
doing though he's putting his pawns on
dark squares Bishop controlling light
squares so anytime black tries to create
a passport it will guarantee that there
are some exchanges some trades uh but
yeah first I've just sort of of course
is going to go round and round he's
going to torture Eliana forever
confidently going into this end game and
we feel that he will be able to hold
this one there is a lot of excitement in
the other matchups so let's go straight
over to Dennis lazovic taking on Amin
tabatabai we were talking about bets
here and PSY are you even on the bets or
is it is it just me betting or are you
are you part of it have you changed your
mind now I told you guys
yeah
I told you so
you know I have to say I don't like I
don't like where the bar is you know I
might have to go to the bar with that
bar I think so uh but yeah is this
really bad your Banker then I mean
um
and it comes down to the flexible Pond
structure right by always having that
ability at the right time to strike with
F4 and create those passes but it has to
be done timely uh David it's still equal
material still opposite color Bishop so
break it down why does the bar love
White's position so much yeah I think we
have to jump in to illustrate why this
position is completely winning despite
the level material it's simply that
black is Frozen it's reminiscent
actually of the Armageddon game
yesterday between Carolina and lazovic
where black was passive could barely
move and white has the luxury of just
going round and round in circles uh just
kind of torturing black asking questions
this bishop first of all is going to
land on an outpost if black is not
careful here once there it's going to
paralyze the black king Black's Pawn
majority on the queen side will be
rendered irrelevant and as you mentioned
Tanya this white porn later can break
also there will be the plan of coming
around with the King sooner or later if
you time it well and uh correctly and
two isolated pawns here just extremely
weak notice how black has three porn
Islands separated white has two very
well connected Pawn chains and if we
catch up with the current position this
bishop has landed black is just
completely Frozen this Rook simply
cannot move if you shift it then your
e-pawn will drop at the very least and
uh yeah it has this bishop going it just
has to drop back and forth the black
king now is uh stepped back but here we
go the journeys began White's King is
simply going to come in and win
overwhelm the black defenses red or
white wine David I like a nice glass of
Pinot Grigio Riesling I bet you've got
expensive taste as well tonight I'll
have a glass of cognac you can get one
off
around really quickly actually it's
amazing how Amanda by has managed to
create real chances and get this winning
picture it comes down to the fact that
black is so paralyzed it's hard to
imagine moves that Rook on E6 is just
stuck defending the G6 Pawn forever you
can never give that up rook trade is the
dream but it's not happening in this no
it's certainly not happening and it's
all to do with activity and also I'm
sure if you were to re rewind those
moves you will see that white slowly and
incrementally improve the position just
by slowly just mobilizing the work
advancing the pawns and now you're
seeing white just grinding it out now
putting the king up the board now that
the bishop on C6 isn't well placed I
mean big question now are you gonna Step
Up up with the king's G4 are you gonna
play around for a few more moves bear in
mind that lazovic only has 11 seconds on
the clock I mean to stop this position
still a little bit surprising how high
the bar is because I mean that is an
indication it's like probably plus four
or something uh when it's actually equal
or material so it shows how much the
computer uh thinks that you how helpless
black black situation is but yeah it is
it is horrible as you've said there
Ivanka you know the problem here for
Dennis lazovic is that he's only got 10
uh seconds on the clock and he'll be
saddled with no time for the rest of the
game and Amin can take his time for the
Breakthrough which has just landed
finally he pushes his Pawn majority yes
he's trading off one of the black weak
pawns but he's going to create a
powerful past Pawn of his own and black
is totally frozen at this stage
um it's almost zuk Swang you can only
really move your Bishop but the white
king is coming in and uh sooner or later
important will run through
on Bishop put leap on on E5 put that
King on G5 and you have
perfect position and that's super
instructor when you've got different
color complexes you want to put all your
pieces on the color of your bishop and
now once again black completely helpless
paralyzed no moves to play but the king
is marching on but he gives up the C7
pawn and that's a big price to pay
high price yeah I'm wondering if you
take on G6 if it's a draw now probably
but that that is something because you
do have two connected passports I expect
it is a draw because they can be
blockaded
um but I'm not 100 C7 here yeah take on
C7 looks a much better move than just uh
you know you you don't really want to
swap Rooks off obviously because you
give your opponent that opposite color
Bishop ending but it's worth calculating
because right and if you just take on C7
the bishop is under attack and there you
see it being played Now The Rook offers
itself up for a trade is tempting now to
actually yeah it's the same idea asking
so far away exactly and there's not
going to be a blockade on the light
squares yeah because he's going to get
F5 and E6 or E6 in and this is just
clearly winning is that this ending same
sort of thing so
is a queen and a glass of wine coming up
the board oh I'm in Tampa to buy wins
the first game it's a best of two which
means that Dennis lazowick has to win on
demand the final game he's still on
camera probably just checking where
things went wrong because just as we
were saying this should have ended in a
draw and now Simon owes jovanka and
David well hang on a minute
where did that come from
I Love The Way You dodged out of that
one I I I'm not part I'm in production
crew maybe the people at the hotel
um anyone else want a glass
four right now Simon's not the only one
having a tough time but for Dan Laz as
well but it was a power performance by
Amin Tabata by David uh we still have
action on on the other one and this one
is inching closer towards the draw this
one is getting closer to the draw eliano
has set up the perfect uh formation here
to hold Black's pieces at Bay
essentially he's fixed the black pawns
on light squares there's no way black
can ever create a passport now without
trading too many pawns off and uh yeah
it's going to keep either the black king
or the Black Knight passive preventing
the white Bishop from hitting those
pawns so yeah just textbook stuff
experience here really shining in the
end game and uh abdusator if he's not
done anything wrong he pushed he got an
advantage but just not quite enough
against this Resolute defense
and uh I'm not gonna write it off too
soon because of the clock times 10
seconds 13 seconds isn't too much for
Eliana but he should be able to hold
this now as long as you keep the white
Bishop within range of striking against
those black pawns traditionally the
anti-young player chess wisdom was cut
them into the end game trade-off pieces
and you're absolutely fine but with this
uh this new Young Generation David I
don't even think that holds true anymore
they're so good in each and every part
of the game I disagree Tanya if you look
at Magnus Carlson's games from the World
Cup beating Vincent kaimer in the muscle
win situation as soon as the Queens came
off he outplayed him beating gukesh in a
rook end game beating Prague in the
tiebreak game it's only end games that
Magnus was winning there against the
younger players it's not because that's
Magnus it's because it's Magnus but I
think a few players need to take the
leaf out of his book uh
uh it's not coincidence so what about
you would you trade the Queens off if
you're playing against in uh under 20
player I think that's why people change
Queens off against me you know
on the 20th under 20 at heart this this
youth here and uh I mean I I think you I
think it's Bobby Fischer who just said
he plays the best moves he was asked a
similar question like what what kind of
area of the game do you excel at and he
said well I just tried to play the best
moves in the position and uh I think
this is what the the top players do as
well they they literally now if they see
the best move whereas an ending whereas
a tactical idea they will just go for
that but uh yeah David made an
interesting point there that uh you know
Magnus is still getting most of his
points in the ending and uh you know
this is this is an area of the game that
you cannot avoid even if you want to
yeah it can be quite fun at times I'm
allowed to say that yeah I know what I
like about the way that Magnus has been
handling these years is he has been
trying different approaches I remember
on the Champions gesture store last
season he is playing in a really
provocative way he he's would play this
kind of come get me openings and then
they would go full force and attack and
he would just residently hold still and
then of course him being Magnus he would
then just get them on the counter attack
and now we've also seen him switch up to
the opening so I think this is the whole
thing so to the end games this is the
whole thing about Magnus he's so
flexible
yeah and uh I produced a tour of I'm
gonna say is one of the best Queen end
game players out there and he's beating
Magnus in two queen end games and really
important clashes and uh he knows how to
maneuver those but
um yeah I think some of the young
players maybe they just need to buy
magnus's latest book that's coming out
today co-written with me grind like a
grand master
learning how to grind down those end
games it's a chess book then chess book
yeah based on our chest records
just confirming the fact so I can
confirm okay but not dance skills
those are severely lacking in this
generation in the 1990 generation but uh
okay I've just thought of he's making
progress visually symbolically but again
look at how White's Bishop is just tying
the Black Knight down to these pawns
it's like you cannot pass you can kind
of get your king to this phenomenal
Square this really active square but you
will not go any further and
hey Eliana leaned back there he has
secured the draw Abdus satorov gives up
his winning chances big fight there but
a confident hold in the end game by
eliano they will play their final rapid
game not a back up to satrobe he's got
reasons to be pleased even though the
result did not go his way with the black
pieces it was him who was pushing
throughout but experience and end games
do go hand in hand and for elianov this
one ends in a draw a little bit of a
relief there uh David what was the big
highlight for you from these two games
that we just witnessed yeah the big
highlight was the performance of aminta
batter by where he did outmaneuver
Dennis lazovic in this simplified end
game we left it a bit earlier around
here and I just want to highlight this
one maneuver that uh kind of clinched
this decisive advantage that we saw
later on that completely froze the black
position here it's all about the
weakness of the e-pawn black's Rook is
already tied down as Ivanka says a rook
worth five tied down by a bishop worth
just three but it's all about opening a
second weakness a Second Avenue of
attack and it was indeed Harry H4 a
textbook idea that Magnus uses a lot
himself just to open up this file open
up a line for the white Rook to enter
and if we fast forward just a few moves
we saw after a trade of horns it was
indeed the open H file that allowed the
white Rook to get in and totally
immobilize Black's Army really textbook
win there and I recommend playing
through it if you want to learn about
end games excellent technique thereby
Amin tabatabai and he reacts there after
his game taking that win against Dennis
last week if there were any doubts that
I mean was uncomfortable after that
Magnus interview that can be put to rest
he's shown some amazing performance
today in his game one against Dan Laz
takes the lead which means that Dennis
has to win the next game to force an
Armageddon meanwhile the alienov Abdul
satrov battle ended in a draw the final
rapid game in the losers bracket is
coming up don't go anywhere you don't
want to miss the action we'll be back in
just a few
[Music]
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things buckle up the 2023 speed Chess
Championship begins this Monday
September the 4th 16 of the strongest
competitors in speed chess will duke it
out until only the speed chess champion
remains will Magnus Carlson continue his
winning streak and add this title to his
name will Hikaru Nakamura defend his
crown or will world champion dingler and
prove his might in faster time controls
the speed Chess Championship presented
by coinbase begins September 4th tune in
to our stream on YouTube or twitch as
always use exclamation point SCC and
chat for all the details
mark your calendars we're teaming up
with supercell for chess clash an epic
series of Chess and Clash challenges
featuring your favorite creators it's a
star-studded lineup as Alexandra botes
Gotham chess clash with Ash sapnap and
more battle it out in the ultimate
strategy game competition which clan
will prevail tune in to chess clash on
September the 7th at 2PM Eastern Time
use exclamation points to clash and chat
to learn more
[Music]
thank you
this tournament is presented by Julius
bear a bank that upholds generation nil
values and in celebration we introduced
you to bodana sevinanden an
eight-year-old who has been creating big
waves in the Chess World with her big
wins and here's what happened when she
took on a former British champion the 79
year old Peter Lee oh
[Music]
well my my father taught me when I was
about eight or nine and I I read all the
all the chess books in the Chelsea
Public Library and I got very interested
one of my dad's friends was throwing
away some stuff during covert and then
inside there there was a chessboard and
I was curious about the pieces so then I
I watched videos on YouTube and chess
kit and I started learning
I'm not thinking I'm going to suddenly
improve and be back in the England team
no I just do it for enjoyment
um
women's world champion as well what did
you say you're racing 1900s 1800 18.
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
well she played she played a lot of very
sensible moves did you think you were
winning at one stage maybe slightly
better slightly maybe slightly better
yeah you probably were
[Music]
that was pure relief on Peter Lee's face
thereafter getting surviving with that
jaw against uh badana and Madonna the
first time that I saw her smile was when
the game ended David what can you tell
us about her game and her future well
she is a star I've played her in Blitz
I've given her puzzles she's just so
quick so sharp and if she continues this
trajectory then she's going to be uh
yeah aimed for the very top but that
specific game as well I just want to
mention she was very nice she could have
tried to grind down Rick and Bishop
versus Rick at the end there but uh a
draw in the end was a fair result and I
was present at the match it was very
close so I hope the views stay tuned for
tomorrow's uh the next game the next
Edition yeah there are more challenges
coming up with bodana against fideli and
it's going to be a lot of fun to watch
uh and it's not only budana who has to
be super sharp everyone watching you
gotta be super sharp right now because
we've got our trivia question of the day
coming up and here it is on your screens
who is the youngest player to qualify
for the candidates and when uh that's a
fun one and get your answers ready also
meanwhile check out what happened when
David and Simon tried to get this right
[Music]
ah okay
I don't know if that's right that one
me neither
can I can I put two answers
oh you know what I think I know the
answers to that one and I know Ivanka
you know it as well
you're a history expert no I'm not
but I do happen to know the answer
because they told me yesterday
I thought we had a chat about this over
lunch
yeah maybe lunch you can submit your
answers on Twitter using the hashtag
chess Champs and we're giving away a
surprise
Clash chess Mystery Box we don't know
what's in it but it's something fun and
you definitely want it so send in your
answers on Twitter using chess Champs
and uh you could win The Clash chess
mystery box and right now we've got some
big clashes coming up over the board as
we go into the final a rapid game Dennis
lazowick has to win on demand meanwhile
for Eleanor and not back the score is
level but you haven't got that much it
felt like was a little bit of a
psychological victory for another bag
yeah definitely because he was also
playing with the black pieces and
traditionally match strategy is always
you draw with black you push hard with
the white pieces and uh there on the
camera we can see young Dennis lazovic
he lost for the black pieces so now he
will have to push as hard as he can
possibly against uh I mean tata bye I
love his medals at the back that's what
I'm looking at that is a lot of
Victories for a 16 year old are they are
they color coded as well like it's all
in gold and then
along with the chess books but he's got
a really big task ahead of him he needs
to win his game against the 22 year old
ahmedabadabai who did Show excellent
technique in the opposite color Bishop
end game where is Dennis's big chance so
how does he get by in this one David
well I would say that Dennis should
stick to his guns he should uh just
continue playing his openings his style
of play
um ideally with maybe uh kind of better
long-term prospects than he did in that
previous game he went to an end game
which normally would suit him but he had
those long-term weaknesses and he was
ground down so if he can keep some
pieces on the board some tension ask
strategic questions of uh I mean to
batter by then I think still decent
chances
um he's not the type of player who's
going to go all in at least not on the
attack unfortunately Simon no I mean he
plays these positions really well though
doesn't he and and he's an expert in
this the Catalan open uh opening and uh
this this is grown in popularity I would
say the last sort of 10 20 years so I
think it was Boris haverick who first
wrote some brilliant books on on this
opening and that's where a lot of Club
players got their inspiration from but
then many many world championship
matches have also started in this way
since then and um is that Bishop isn't
it that Bishop yvanka I think you've
done this to me before as well put that
Bishop on G2 across the diagonal and um
it's it's an annoying piece of black
that one yeah that I can remember
vaguely doing it to you but not in a
Catalan because I don't think we've ever
played definitely I wouldn't put that
black porn in the middle of the board
far far too dull so uh or sensible
um no we haven't had this particular
position by any means and the both
players developing in a really normal
way White's big plan is just to Castle
and if possible get in the E2 E4 phone
break and black on the other hand is
going to be all about developing that
light squared Bishop I think you get out
and have a purpose in life then black
will be satisfied
and very often in these positions white
wants to get a timely E4 break-in to
open up that Catalan Bishop so we might
be seeing those ideas arise as well but
I'm in uh
forcing tennis to fall back with the
Bishop David 985 is not a move that I'm
very familiar with getting that Knight
on the edge uh can you break this down
for us yeah often it's just a game of uh
tickle here the Knight wanted to trade
off for this uh White dark Square Bishop
the dark Square Bishop Retreats but now
it's on a worst square a block Square
often the Knight just goes back where it
came from over the next few moves and he
says okay if you want to kind of do this
dance with the bishop at night then fine
it's just going to be a repetition and a
draw and uh you mentioned as well Tanya
Ivanka both of you were alluding to this
E4 break White's Pawn whites King's Pawn
wants to step forward blow up in the
center kind of sees extra space but now
that's impossible so it's just doing a
kind of specific one move purpose here
that Black Knight on the edge not well
placed and we will see it kind of
recentralized again soon uh maybe even
this move
from Tabata by out to White Castles yeah
I was wondering whether
I mean is going to be super ambitious
and try to actually lock down the center
with this move F7 F5 and I suspect with
this little poor move he might be
initiating the pawns coming forward very
interesting because amen needs only a
draw to wrap up this match uh meanwhile
the other match is still Level and the
players are ready to start their final
rapid game up the central of this time
with the white pieces what are the
opening predictions for this one
I think he's in the mood for something
crazy Abdul sotor of he's uh held with
white uh sorry he's held with black in
the previous game and we saw it last uh
month against Levon aronian on the
previous Champions chess Tour event he
was trying some crazy stuff he tried uh
the Portuguese opening against uh Wesley
so he went for some crazy Pawn
sacrifices like a reverse Stamford
Gambit against Iranian uh okay it's just
the Spanish though
but not the Berlin so that's the good
news yay it's nice that we've seen so
many berlins uh you know so far it's
nice to have a change and uh this is a
more more traditional isn't it but this
is how skewed the Chess World is but
when we get something that's not the
Berlin we're like it's so exciting oh
yeah no ending anymore it's like great
and it isn't that much more exciting in
this position just a very classical
Spanish opening Roy Lopez where White's
light Square Bishop has done a bit of a
journey and uh traditionally white as
maybe a small Advantage black is the one
trying to fight for equality here but
very symmetrical very stabilized and a
lot of maneuvering ahead
and very often when white decides to put
that Knight on C3 instead of advancing
the C Pawn you kind of want to take
control of that D5 Square so ideally
white would have wanted to trade the
dark Square Bishop with the Knights of
the movie 86 sort of preempting that
stopping any Bishop G5 ideas yeah and
that's a nice positional move from
Eliana and uh now that he's kind of
avoided that Pitfall he just now
concentrates on developing his pieces
and I I suspect it's all going to be
about the those light squared Bishops
um I'm expecting the black Bishop to
retreat and perhaps maybe the um the
bishop on C8 can go to esax and
challenge yeah I mean one of my biggest
regrets in chess
um we won't go to the rest of them let's
stick with a chest and was actually not
learning these positions as much as I
would have liked to when I was when I
was a kid uh like learning the Spanish
learning to roll like pairs I always
played the French defense so I never
really uh embarked on understanding the
Maneuvers in the these structures more
obviously I know a bit about them now
but I wish I'd learned one E5 as as a
child which I think David might have
done because this is kind of like your
bread and butter of uh chess you know
it's one of the longest ever uh recorded
openings they're all Lopez by the
Spanish monk uh pre-steven who he came
up with this and uh it's just a really
good way to learn chess because you've
got to maneuver all the pieces remain on
the board you've got to wait until the
right moment to strike and often things
do come to life because all the pieces
on the board so it's just a great way to
improve your knowledge of Chess in
general I I feel so uh David you you
learned this as a kid I guess so yeah
with both white and black I've been
playing this opening since I was in my
pan campus and uh I'm not I'm not saying
I enjoy the pictures we can bring up
with that show you later Simon um but
thank you David yeah these um these
types of positions it's all about yeah
just as you mentioned where to put the
pieces which Pawn breaks to go for uh
it's all kind of pattern recognition and
every position kind of looks similar
looks recognizable but there are always
little different details little nuances
that uh kind of switch up depending on
how your opponent plays and uh yeah I
was gonna say just while Abdu tutorial
was thinking a moment ago White's Knight
jumped into the center I have actually
studied this exact position before until
that move and uh White did have the
opportunity to push forward like G4 was
even a move there very aggressive idea
but it does look like now it's going to
take a more positional strategic turn so
I was wrong with my prediction abdusator
of definitely giving a lot of respect to
his uh experienced opponent and he's
just playing classical chess sooner or
later he's going to try and do something
in the center or the queen side because
you need open lines with white in order
to fight for any type of advantage and
if for example you play unambitious
chess such as trading off a set of
knights trading off the white uh the
kind of light squared Bishops then it's
just gonna fizzle out it's not going to
lead to anything significant so I think
both sides have reason to be happy with
the opening but uh Abdu story of needs
to try something in the next few turns
and Knight to D2 does hint that he might
throw his F Pawn forward
things might be heating up but when we
do see a pawn break and this is a good
time to get another uh round of bets in
maybe for another run at the bar Simon
you could equalize what you've lost
today if you get this one right is this
going into an Armageddon
I'm waiting for someone to say something
first right okay here we go I'm not
buying it by the way I'm only paying
with David sorry Rebecca I'll buy you a
drink if you really would like me to but
I mean this is just that I thought you
were betting with your Banker let's get
the rules clear let's not try to swear
they're into that uh
certainly did touch the trees
me and Simon are going to say draw and
then later on it's like Simon's buying
the drinks but okay right I will double
my bet with David oh I'll buy you a
drink if you really want one you know
it's like but um with David
white is gonna win this one double or
quits oh well can I can I just take it
white and black because the question was
will it be Armageddon yes I might no it
won't be Armageddon
but that's what David said as well he
thinks we're going to have a decisive
result are you guys on the same team so
I'm getting one possible result you're
getting two positive sounds sounds like
a fair bit to me okay I'll take it just
because I like uh so hang on wait are we
paying the kids I don't even know what
better not even more anymore it has to
be uh double or nothing so either you
buy him two glasses of the Pinot Grigio
or okay you're good but I wasn't quite
sure what no what you guys decided do
you think it's going to be decisive
result so do I so we're not really uh uh
we didn't really get a bet there did we
okay you know what just make it a bit
I'll go it will be Armageddon then come
on then let's just put it on the table
and again with you cyber I'm not part of
the bet but I agree with you I think you
will see an arm again what about you
Ivanka what are the chances of this
ending in a draw as well this position I
know it's really early to call I don't
think it's gonna be Armageddon
yeah that's a bad sign for us David and
Ivanka and this sounds like for me
because you take these bets so then you
make me pay for them and it's just like
you'd run a very successful
um Betting Company not that we recommend
that but you know you'd be yeah let's
get back to the chess
uh we will see if this heads into an
Armageddon right now the match is level
and it has been a close equal level
fight in uh their first game as well
Knight D2 the last move and Eleanor in a
big thing David yeah it's a really tense
position and I like what abdusator has
done he's just planted his Knight in the
center on D5 and he's saying you sorted
out you deal with uh that night now
because actually It's Tricky for black
ideally you want to trade off these
Knights but you cannot do it in White's
terms here uh if you ever take of course
it's just a double attack a fork and uh
one of the two black minor pieces will
be lost and if you take with a bishop
it's very committal yes you don't lose a
piece this time but uh Forever This Pawn
will be kind of a bone in your throat
here and white can back it up with a
move C4 yes maybe you maneuver your
knight around and it's still roughly in
the balance but uh it definitely changes
the nature of the position so you have
to be 100 certain uh giving up the
bishop pair like this giving up all of
the light squares and if you don't get
rid of this Knight then what else are
you doing uh if you don't touch it then
at least white is hinting at uh maybe
Pawn breaks such as support A4 Pawn to
F4 a bit risky but uh definitely
something to be wary of and if white
gets the time of course uh a very
thematic idea of opening the center as
well so white is super flexible it's
very much about how black deals with the
tension
yeah I I'm really liking White's
position primarily because I'm all about
Pawn breaks and white controls every
single Pawn break they have the
possibility and I just wanted to
highlight another one uh c2c4
that one
was it the correct plan for in hindsight
for Pavel to places like Square Bishop
in front of his Rook because Pavel would
like love to play Knight takes Knight
right uh because that white knight in
the center of the board it's a real pain
and if you if you don't want to exchange
it off which it doesn't because he would
have played it by now you're gonna have
to leave it there
um for a long long time and it's always
going to cause you problems I mean you
know how did you deal with that I'm not
even sure you'd want to play a move like
Knight E7 maybe but you you can't even
play that move because uh you would uh
destroy your king side so that Knight is
an issue and for that reason I think
white white has a small Edge but what
you just said I mean gives me the idea
and I was just about to say you want to
move that night to push black white
knight from the center so get it to A5
and he plays it I see you on the board
the bishop will have to fall back and
then you get a move a Tempe to actually
uh go C6 and bond breaks D5 might be in
the air at some moment and be careful C6
don't you because the bishop B6 was a
bit of a killer but
um but this yeah that that looked like a
great plan yeah instead C5 and he's
basically bypassing this Knight he's
playing around it sometimes your
opponent has a strong piece on an
outpost and you just have to forget it
you just have to pretend it's not there
and uh just uh yeah he's playing around
this piece I quite like this because now
he's saying at the right moment I might
take this Knight and then the pawn
structure is completely different uh you
have to as both colors here way up the
pros and cons of that one uh White would
end up with doubled pawns there but of
course white doesn't really want to
capture on Black's terms either because
suddenly black is very active black
controls the center Black's Queen
Black's sir yeah just doing extremely
well here so
um I like what both sides are doing to
be honest it just looks like a high
quality game so far but eliano has been
burning a lot of time and now it is up
to uh Abdus to decide which porn break
to go for B4 looks like something to
calculate it's on the board David oh
he's just played it yeah
forcing the Black Knight back and again
what to do next you could just keep the
tension and move like C3 would be very
typical here but if you really want
chaos then you can start calculating I'm
just like C4 as well
and really hasn't hesitant to suggest
that for but definitely on the radar uh
to lots of horn breaks here and full
tension still all the pieces on the
board
well uh as we can see that it is white
in a driver's seat in this one just like
in the last game not the back trying to
get the edge we will keep an eye on this
one and jump back to it but let's get a
check-in with Dennis last week against
amen amen needing only a draw and wow
that's quite a position we've got with
black over expanding on the side uh
where he's castled and that can always
backfire does this give Dan Laz a
long-term chance at initiative against
the black king definitely I think in a
must win situation like this one Dennis
is going to be really happy he's got a
solid position as white but also
attacking chances against Black's king
and the main thing when you need to win
at all costs is imbalance here you have
an imbalance in terms of Peace
configuration White having the Bushman
Knight versus the two Bishops but also
the pawn structure and uh yeah it feels
like black is taking significant risks
to battle by he's just trying to play
principal chess I understand what he's
doing black long term is doing quite
well but uh short term Maybe some
troubles here Simon you're the attacker
how does white initiate uh something
here against black king
yeah maybe there's nothing immediate I
mean uh you've got to look at the pawn
breaks which Ivanka uh mentioned earlier
and
um my favorite pawnbreak is something
which is always on the radar H4 because
it's just looking where your opponent's
weaknesses and the position and uh uh
you mentioned David the G5 Pawn uh that
pawn on G5 is a problem for black
because it exposes Black's King so you
look at ways you can try to uh find a
way in so at some point H4 and this is
another Pawn break I was going to
mention E4 just trying to open things up
uh bit by bit and this is playing in the
middle and maybe just waiting uh for uh
King side action to happen a little bit
later I clicked on the Run game back to
this one route to d8 played this is a
pawn sacrifice if I'm not mistaken from
Tabata by yeah he's trying to open up
his Bishops I guess with with that that
idea there so white can take a pawn in
the center you're ganging up on that
pawn three times but if we see
everything disappear from the board then
at the very end the black Bishop just
moves out the way and uh attacking The
Rook if there's a rook trade suddenly we
see the power of the Bishops this is a
weak Pawn suddenly white has no hint of
an attack and black has full control
I love what tabataway's done that
decision Dynamic uh sacrifice of a porn
I'm not sure Dennis should actually go
for this but we're headed towards that
direction
last pause right now uh not immediately
going ahead with the natural capture is
he considering an intermediate
Intermezzo Bishop B5 Ivanka yeah it
looks that way and I I certainly do like
that move because one of the problems
with going porn takes Pawn is okay it's
on the board is that as David intake
indicated white is not obliged to
capture that pawn I would be tempted to
actually draw from a pattern that Simon
referenced which is to just play around
that and say well now the F5 square has
been opened up it's unprotected put a
knight onto the D4 and then start
threatening E6
that night is so strong I know I mean I
if I was black I'd really want to get
rid of that night as quickly as I could
yeah I think this is actually a key
moment uh this Pawn might just be
poisoned in the center very natural to
be greedy here I'm very materialistic
but once you see the blacks Bishops
really come to life uh along these
diagonals also peace trades help the
side with the bishop hair that's uh just
generally uh kind of a rule
um yeah I think I would avoid this and
like Ivanka says this might be a key
moment don't get tempted to take the
pawn if you're Dennis lazovic you have
to just plant the knight in the center
actually your pieces are doing good work
here uh Black's Bishops are far less
happy they have fewer open diagonals to
play on
and then is slowing down in this very
critical moment not to get greedy is
David's advice but David even for this
Young Generation playing for the
initiative playing for the attackers we
often see that kind of approach from
them they they don't usually go for
material or trying to pick up bonds when
they've got the option to keep the
trumps in the position
then last uh if you have to predict I
think Knight D4 is something that would
come naturally to him here yeah I think
first thing he would be calculating
taking the pawn I think that's very
natural why not in chess if you can go
material up and there are no
consequences then why not uh but yeah
he's very principled he'll be working
out the ins and outs and if he can't see
anything uh kind of in that variation
then he'll look for Alternatives and
he's a very positional player so Knight
to D4 Outpost centralization makes a lot
of sense
um yeah Tony I think you're right
actually this modern generation there
just supremely good at that kind of
playing deposition the demands of the
position not counting too much uh not
being too focused on the material it's
coming I think he's about to reach out
and make his move uh Knight D4 is just
also aesthetically so nice because that
bar on D5 is actually more useful for
White alive than off the board it's a
long time long term weakness you can
always Target it but it really takes
away the activity from blacks Bishops
and the centralized The Rook on d8 94 is
what I'm hoping to see but he's got to
make a decision fast you often seen him
really fall low on the clock and then
not have enough time in those critical
moments right and this is a critical
moment and I also just want to mention
that maybe he's pausing not because he's
contemplating between Rook takes porn
and the Knight coming to D4 but he could
also be thinking about breaking up the
black king side if I actually playing
Simon's favorite move h2h4 and maybe it
is a rook that is going to repair on the
D4 Square yeah
I was thinking Knight D4 I've had to be
played and I thought a key line here was
Bishop C5 because you can't allow that
Knight to go here maybe the exchange
sack and E6 followed up was was quite
interesting but I I think uh I think if
if white gets any more time here white
white will be doing very well and I
think you have to play Bishop C5 and
then you can obviously defend that
Knight in a sensible way but you know
there's an interesting idea of
sacrificing The Rook just to gain some
more time and then trying to open up the
position with E6 for example I don't
know if E6 works you might even have
time to do something else here but this
is the kind of move you look at first
because it's forcing and you get the E5
Square for your queen uh if E6 doesn't
work I think you still have quite a lot
of compensation there maybe you can then
play this H4 idea or or something
similar here and I'd certainly be
looking at doing this with white pieces
but is this is this Dennis you know
we've seen him play so many uh brilliant
endings and quiet games uh if he's gonna
play in this style I'd be very impressed
because it shows he's got that other
dimension to his game where he's willing
to sacrifice I mean I'm not even sure
this is a good idea but it's it's an
interesting idea Simon you've given up a
rook for Bishop but the evaluation bar
still roughly in the middle that shows
it's promising or at least very playable
and I agree in a must-win situation this
is the type of thing you should go for
and maybe that's what's making a mean to
better buy pause he wants to of course
harass this strong Knight in the center
this kind of Knight on an outpost but if
you hit this Knight you have to work out
the consequences Black's light Black's
dark Square Bishop sorry is uh the kind
of most valuable Defender here and it
might just be eliminated if you move to
C5 so yeah critical moment and I think
for the first time he's sensing danger
to batter by
um definitely feels like it's turning in
kind of Dennis lazovic's uh yeah in his
way right now but still a long way to go
I mean I'd love to have another bet here
but we won't because of that a lot but
after Bishop C5 wood Dennis sacrifice
The Rook the exchange or would he play
more and is the style he's shown so far
by just moving the queen to like d tree
which is probably a good move but if you
need to win you need to unbalance things
so uh I don't think we're gonna see a
sacrifice I'm gonna stick my neck out I
think he's probably going to choose a
move like Queen to E3 keep the Queens on
the board and then continue on with
destabilizing moves such as H2 H4
I
it just we haven't seen him take too
many positional risks and after Bishop
Rook takes Bishop you know yeah
I don't know it's one of these risk
assessments um maybe it's not a good
idea it's just very interesting to give
white more time and your knight is so
strong it seems instinctively uh quite
an interesting idea for sure and we
might not even see Bishop C5 and Chester
kind of uh not only fighting your
opponent's moon but your own mind as
well so for amen whether Dennis actually
gives up the exchange or not come second
because in his head he's trying to
evaluate this position so he might even
have a different approach of perhaps
trying to trade off The Rook so Rook see
it comes across as an option would could
he consider that instead I think that's
a much shot of shintanya we mentioned
with the bishop pair trade-off pieces
and kind of challenging for the open C
file makes a lot of sense if you can get
Rooks off the board you're much happier
you brew the sigh of relief if you're
the black king so I think that's what he
should be doing to better buy but it is
very very natural as well to hit that
white knight in the center I think that
would kind of at least with the match
situation in mind that would be a big
mistake
just psychologically to allow that
sacrifice to allow that attack I'm just
intrigued here I'm curious whether
Dennis would go for it so I want to see
it happen on the board Bishop C5 but uh
I do think Tabata by should maybe play
it safe here yeah and not even allow
that option also armin's the kind of
player who would probably sacrifice The
Exchange he would go Rook C5 he is an
aggressive player so for him to just
avoid or give his opponent that chance
would be very difficult uh in his own
battle with his mind and we see a move
is on the board as a very natural Roxy
it
makes a lot of sense and there we do see
a trade of works and how is white going
to continue the attack
do you play h2h4 or do you step forward
with the queen
it's interesting it's not easy suddenly
without one set of Rooks on the board it
feels like you're running out of
ammunition somewhat whites rook in the
center now kind of you're tied down
defending the night how do you get the
queen in and I'd be tempted to move the
queen forwards get a threat and maybe
try to get my light Square Bishop to uh
D3
um and then and then I launch everything
at Black's king
um maybe now Bishop C5 Simon because
there's no Rook C5 in the air that's a
good point yeah I I I'd love to play
Brook takes C5 there I might get in a
bit of trouble if I try that one or
thrown off the chess.com server so uh
yeah that that Bishop C5 is quite
annoying I mean if there is a mass trade
on D4 white White's gonna be better
there so it might not be the end of the
world for white this position I mean I I
I'm I'm tempted with F4 but I don't know
uh F4 H4 the game goes on and um you
know I'll still rather be white in this
this position
I think yeah
um I think I would choose black Simon
Just long-term potential of the Bishops
yeah uh you know me but either way that
black King's still vulnerable so Dennis
has a chance yeah and Gary it is she's
fine the G Pawn that moves forwards and
uh well this is a nice move with a
concrete threat of the night coming to
F5 with a check
yeah yeah I did not see this one coming
I've got to say it's anti-position also
can kind of fair play to Dennis lazovic
going against his Instinct against his
uh nature weakening his own dark squares
but with a very concrete Dynamic idea in
mind Knight to F5 we've talked about it
before it will Thrive there that's a
really nice move and because black
doesn't have a knight that can jump onto
the weak squares it makes a lot of sense
but it's not the first move you think of
but once you see it on the board it just
seems to put the pieces together and
you've Uncle your idea of Knight F5 if
there's a trade those two pawns on F5
and E5 would give a huge a winning
chance for white uh with those bonds
down the central board uh by the way
Simon asking for a friend what was your
bet about the Armageddon on nordeback
versus eliano I said that it will
definitely 100 not be an Armageddon game
and I bet you Tanya at least three
glasses of the finest Norwegian Rose all
right let's check in on that we will
come back to this and see if Dennis is
able to take it to the Armageddon but
wow David A lot has happened on this one
this position has explored loaded it's a
total mess here but it is a mess in
White's favor if we do a quick count
white is a pawn up uh with those doubled
a pawns now white has also infiltrated
the black Camp look at White's Rook on
the seventh Rank and if you look at the
other side of the board blacks Knights
don't make a great impression black is
kind of all in here on an attack against
the white king definite shades of Wesley
so against pavalelian Eliana from
yesterday but it's hard to foresee that
attack being too dangerous uh White
controls the light squares as well which
really really helps I think we need to
jump in and see how we got here let's
just do a quick back track not that many
moves have been played but it was this
committed decision back here uh after
white dip move did play the move C3 I
think uh that have Pavel will regret he
took with his Bishop giving up the light
squares and suddenly White's pieces
started pouring forward and uh here as
well opening up the C file for whites
Rooks did backfire whites Rook did get
in Via C1 and it was here that uh yeah
the white Rook did enter Rook to C7 and
which catch up with the current position
I don't really see what the plan is he's
just retreated his Queen let's say I
just improved my worst place piece this
is why it's Rook on F1 let's say I just
double up on the C file uh maybe
threatening at some point to kind of
sidestep to B7 and land both Rooks on
the seventh what does black do next
how do you at least create some chances
against the white king he has played
that the most natural move on the board
you need to go all in here yeah I mean
it's but it's very it's going to be very
hard for black to ever attack with the
queen being so passive I mean if uh uh
that black queen just seems to be tied
down and you have to try E4 or F4 right
I mean you can't do anything else in
maybe you do this and then go F4 or
bring the Knight to the center but
it's gonna be very hard without your
queen so E4 looks worth of Punt and I
think he's played E4 right so this this
seems to be a good try at least yeah so
what next let's say I continue being
greedy continue taking the bait well
let's say I move my knight to a better
Square this this again seems quite
logical and uh and now I'm gonna try F4
here and I actually
maybe I'm getting a bit more confident
here in my disillusion I'm sure but you
know my I got some a nibble here or
something
you'd give a lot of money right now a
lot of glass of wine Simon for a light
squared Bishop as black uh definitely
unfortunately you don't have that light
Square Bishop so you struggled to attack
on that color complex but at least yeah
you're in the game and fair play to
Eliana for giving a second Pawn uh to
keep the fight going
some chances in a position like this but
at a time situation I think it's going
to be very important and Pavel was half
the time of nordie Beck as well so that
that could actually count quite a lot
but this E4 I like that I think it's a
it's a good try at least in in what must
be a bad position and uh White didn't
even capture that pawn wow and I like
that move from white white is basically
saying if you want to move your knight
into the center of the board I will
exchange queens and then your attack is
going to be non-existent without the
Queen's being on the board and our win
all positions because my Rooks are so
good yeah and I was
really impressed with nordeback's last
move you know moving the queen to H5 and
one thing I just wanted to point out is
that yeah it looks like after Pawn takes
born Black's pieces are very active but
the bishop on B6 is a fantastic Defender
defending the critical F2 Point did see
that piece of anchor I must admit
too as well it's a long way away that
Bishop that's why I pointed it out it
was hiding that in plain sight and uh
you'll move Simon on the board I think
this is a good try just to mix things up
and make it chaotic it's like the team
of the day they sacrifice a Central Pawn
give that up for play for activity for
that very key Square for a night in
front of that sacrifice Bond we've been
seeing it throughout the games and this
is another display of that so despite
being in a difficult position eliano of
trying to create a Chaos on the board
and not a back returns the favor
creating a square for his own night he
literally said it Tanya that's the theme
of the day giving up Central pawns
seeming
says anything you could do I can do
better and uh he's basically saying okay
if you take with the Knight Queens are
off the board any end game white is
always going to win because of the past
a porn and because of the Rooks on the
seventh rank uh so Eliana if he's faced
with the quite ugly decision here of
allowing White's d-pawn to become past
or just going into an end game I don't
really see what else uh White Light
Square Bishop as well ready to drop back
to C2 to start hitting those Black
Knights lined up on the same diagonal
really really clever that last move from
Naughty Beck and uh he shows you at this
level that the players are so willing to
give material up just to keep the
activity in the position activities the
main main thing these players uh want to
get absolutely a really nice uh Central
Bond sacrifices all through the
day-to-day by the way we are getting a
big update that I'm in tabatabai is in
big trouble in his game Let's quickly
get an update on that as Dennis lazowick
might be forcing an Armageddon wow it's
another rook and opposite color Bishop
end game this time it's rolls reversed
however it's uh yet again white winning
but this time it's Dennis lazovic on the
side with the advantage and not just to
see two pawns up temporarily but Black's
B Pawn is about to drop whites Rook will
land on the seventh rank it's beautiful
look at that thorn in the black side the
white protected past Pawn on E6 it's
going to make sure the black Bishop is
tied down forever and this one should be
a matter of technique as they say two
minutes against 10 seconds should be
helpful helpful as well but then a
slazovic it was all about that G4 move
he landed a knight on F5 and tobacco I
shouldn't have taken it uh it's just
been one-way traffic ever since
beautiful play Dennis lazovic striking
back Armageddon Simon you called it
right yeah that's right yeah yeah I
called it I'm sure I did no doubt about
it but you did Simon so now you don't
know anyone or wine you're welcome by
the way yeah thanks I'm not really sure
what happened with that but um yeah I
mean it's uh but it's great yeah I mean
Dennis then is fighting back I mean that
shows real character in there in the
position he hasn't done it yet but can
you just got yourself in here push the
corner is king of seven slightly
uncomfortable for white for black and he
stops it he does stop it and I think
this is the key E7 now a huge threat so
this is why the Rook has to retreat but
how is white gonna break through I mean
is it just a case of advancing the A4
Pawn or is the black king in danger of
getting checkmated you do feel that like
any piece David know as well I know what
Tanya wants let's show this there's a
flashy move right now like it talk us
through it
I don't know if it works or not because
black does have an option but I would in
an instant play the move Rook GA check
here just because it's so pretty and the
point is that black can't really
recapture the route because now the
e-pawn moves forward giving a check and
you promote it to a queen but David I'm
afraid that after Rook G8 check black
and simply sidestep King 287 and you
still have E7 under control so it really
doesn't get white anywhere it doesn't
get white anywhere it would have been so
beautiful though it might as well play
it doesn't change anything uh Dennis
could then have just moved his Rook away
uh as he did in the game but look at
what he's done uh he's traded off the
Rooks he uh let's just go back he
brought his Rook down to B7 Force those
Rooks off the board and we said opposite
color Bishop end games are drawn often
but here the difference is that white
has two past pawns the a pawn and the E
Pawn and the difference here the key
fact is that they are three lines apart
if you notice between the E Pawn and the
a pawn uh often you need three lines
between pass Pawns in order for the
black king and black Bishop to be too
stretched and uh here White's King will
eventually support the advance of one of
those pawns so this is just matter of
time I think we'll see at the end game
technique required here from Dennis Las
Vegas still winning well it looks like
this one this one is headed into an
exciting Armageddon battle but it feels
that we will not have an Armageddon in
the other game earlier nov in big big
trouble against
norderbeck let's bring that up wow it's
Checkmate for who okay let's Checkmate
on the board
is that game over already
tends to do that it just ended Knight G5
played and that is a game over another
back up to such Trove he continues his
run in the Julius bear generation cup
for Eliana it has been a difficult day
and he has been eliminated wow David do
you want to just quickly show us what
happened in the last few moves yeah
let's just do a quick rewind just over
the last few turns it was here white is
actually winning Eliana sacrificed a lot
of material just to go for an attack
against the white king but White's King
is actually super safe and after the
move Rook takes F6 it was the
devastating back rank check forcing the
black king forward and then pin and win
this is uh of course a Checkmate because
the black porn cannot move on H6 and
capture this Knight the black king
trapped uh just beautiful finish by
updated tour of absolutely stunning with
his own King on G3 let's go on to the
other game and where we are expecting to
have an Armageddon any moment and that's
it we do have a result Dennis lazovic
has done it with those two passes it is
game over and there we have tennis on
the screen what a comeback by Dennis
yeah what a comeback just when it
mattered and you know he played so well
breaking in the center piling on the
pressure on on Amin and I can't wait for
the Armageddon now
and for amen he is not a happy player
right now he had it in the bag but Donna
slazovic the 16 year old he forces an
Armageddon and we will have the players
bidding for their time it is not over in
the elimination bracket two very
exciting uh games to very exciting
matches David what was the highlight for
you in round two for me there was one
star move in that second game and it was
by Dennis lazovic in this position uh we
were talking here about how maybe black
has decent Chances with the dots with
the uh Bishop pair but it was this one
move that uh tipped about to buy over
the edge Pawn to G4 really
counter-intuitive not obvious not
instinctive at all just cementing a nice
Outpost for the White Knight and we saw
I mean so shocked by this that he
actually went wrong immediately he moved
his bishop and after a check he should
have resisted the temptation to capture
this Knight he should have simply
dropped back with his King when the game
goes on maybe white king NAB upon but
the fight's still alive instead as we
saw after taking this Knight this
structure was simply terrible for black
this white porn on E6 just cementing the
advantage Forever This Pawn soon dropped
the pawn on B7 later dropped and in the
final position as we saw black simply
resigned because this Pawn is too strong
this black Bishop has to move and also
the a pawn will begin running beautiful
strategic play by lazovic
fantastic end game technique first
almond shows it and then then last it's
going to be a close battle in the
Armageddon this is our score line in the
elimination bracket not the back up to
such a advances through meanwhile uh I'm
in tabatabai has a setback as Dennis
lastowick scores a comeback Victory and
we are being joined by notabeck after
his win against elianov nordeback
congratulations on winning but not just
that also finding your form it felt like
you struggled a little bit yesterday how
satisfied are you not just with the
score but also the quality of your play
yeah yesterday was a tough match
uh obviously he was a
uh he was much
he played much better than me
and uh yeah he will he deservedly like
uh won uh three now
um yeah
today's match was better
but uh
yeah in second game I I think I played
uh a good game
but um I think he blundered Bishop B6
uh which gave us up a Pawn on A5 and uh
yeah that was it for today and
yeah looking back to my
uh my play so far
um yeah it's not uh impressive at all
um
yeah and I hope to do uh to do well in
next match
now the back you're already into to the
Toronto finals so does that take the
pressure a little bit off the whole
champion star and what's your ambition
in this one
um no it's like uh
I have a motivation like in every
tournament
you know to to do better
um to improve uh but
yeah obviously it
uh it it has some impact on my play
um because it you know
it's easier when you know you that you
are in finals and uh that's that's
uh that's why like uh it's much more
easier to play
about a
uh but I think
my play was a
was a stable during the whole uh
Champions chess tour so far
and uh yeah I I think it will be very
interesting to to uh to play in the
finals and yeah I am really looking
forward to it
yeah we're looking forward to all your
upcoming matches as well not a big and
you've had a busy month uh World Cup and
then in Dusseldorf a really nice
performance there congratulations for
that as well uh how are you on the
energy are you feeling a little bit
tired or is energy not a factor
well it's only the beginning I think
it's like I'm going to play in uh five
or six tournaments in a row
uh from now on like it's basically uh
I'll not have any like more than like
couple of days of race day and uh yeah
it's going to be a very uh energy
consuming but
uh well if if I stay
um
uh fit then it should be fine
that's really nice to hear another bag
and we wish you all the best for your
match tomorrow enjoy the rest of the day
thank you
not a backup disaster with a very
convincing win over Pavel eliano and
he's got five six more tournaments
coming up the younger generation no such
thing as fatigue no such thing as
feeling a tired for them and the two
players who can't be feeling the fatigue
right now Dennis lazovic and Amanda by
we've got a big Armageddon coming up
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
[Music]
Superman
[Applause]
foreign
find your local group or take the lead
at meetup.com chess that is meetup.com
chess and the one player who is perhaps
taking the lead in momentum is Dennis
lazowick after his comeback win against
Amin tab of tabai take a look at what
David has to say about what makes Dennis
such a beast
[Music]
thank you
Dennis lazovic is an online sensation
the teenager known as denlaz has been
taking down experienced Grandmasters for
many years already
specialist in Blitz chess and Rapid
chess Dennis lazovic has now qualified
for division one of the Champions chess
tour and he did it in style with his
uncompromising tenacious and resilient
style of play Dennis lazovic is truly
unique for such a young player
he's able to positionally outplay his
opponents he's able to outmaneuver them
and with his solid openings he has a
perfect base to emphasize his rapid
skills
when given a tactical opportunity
however Dennis lazovic does pounce check
out this position from division two of
the aim chess rapid which lazovic went
on to win here Dennis lazovic who's
White against Parham mag Zulu White had
a material advantage being up a rook for
Black's Bishop but the finishing touches
to this game are still needed
lasovic here of course found the most
brutal way to finish the game the most
decisive move and it was a sacrifice
Rook to h8 giving up the Rook on an
empty square a check of course this Rook
simply has to be captured and this
allowed the White Queen to zoom in to f8
a square no longer protected by the
black king again black has only one
legal reply King to H7 and this allowed
the finishing touch the other Rook
slides over to the vacated H1 Square
that's a check the black king is simply
trapped and here Parham maxulu resigned
rather than giving up his Queen on H6
this would have led to Checkmate anyway
and Max Zulu won a masterpiece going to
h8 checkmate
will play his second Armageddon of the
Julius bear generation cup can the
youngest have a participant of the
Champions Chester continue his run in
the event or will this be his last game
a huge Armageddon coming up as we wait
for the bids Ivanka is there a favorite
in this Armageddon oh I'm actually gonna
say that Dennis the young 16 year old is
a favorite you know he had the
experience yesterday he came super close
to beating Fabiana caruana and also he
just won his last game momentum is on
his side
David would you agree with that with
that comeback has the momentum shifted
it does feel that way we shouldn't
forget about to play to butter by played
a very impressive game when he had white
as well earlier today uh both players
just crushing each other with the white
pieces so I think actually this
Armageddon has that Twist on it not it's
not necessary that they want black this
time which we're used to seeing in these
Armageddon bidding wars uh I think
actually both players maybe should be
banking on the white set wow and we've
got the bids coming in the let's take a
look at the Players bids for the
Armageddon and there we have amen
tabatabai really going for the white
pieces with 14 minutes 50 seconds Dennis
lastovic 9 minutes 20 seconds David you
were on point with that yeah
I mean uh wow I mean I'm shocked I knew
he might want white just I've played to
battle by before he's so aggressive and
he loves the white pieces but uh that is
Brave
will want to play with the white pieces
Dennis last will start with 9 minutes
and 20 seconds he will have the black
pieces but result odds which means that
I'm in with base time will have to win
with white on demand and of course there
is no increment Simon what are the
chances of this one being decided on
flagging
yeah it's very high whenever it's
Armageddon it's always a good chance
that it will come down to the clock come
down to flanking
um so they they don't have that
increment they've got to move quicker
and the tension is going to be a lot
higher we saw how exciting it was
yesterday uh when Dennis played against
uh Fabiano respect the same again now
nine minutes 20 seconds that's quite a
bit of time trade-off for the black
colors let's take a look at the
regulations and uh the winner of the bid
gets to choose the color colors which is
usually black and black gets result odds
which means that if it's a draw black
wins the match white has to win the
demand and again there will be no
increment it's just the final game of
the battle between
we're all feeling the tension right now
and it's liftoff
almond starts with white starts with the
Queen spawn opening and in London wow
the London system he's been playing this
consistently throughout the last uh six
months last one year to batter by I'm
slightly surprised he switched it up
from a really successful opening in the
first game of today when he took down
the Berlin defense uh so convincingly
but okay it's the London system we see a
trade of Pawns here and it's actually
transposed do you have anchor to pretty
much the Karo Khan defense uh where this
Pawn structure which we call the
Carlsbad structure
um it's all a battle about who can
maneuver
kind of better with their pieces often
white just has a grip it's harder for
black to break out it is definitely
harder for black to break out but on the
other hand the pawn structure is very
solid and black will have something to
smile about and that is the bishop on G4
and there we see white just show his
cards he's saying I want to expand on
the left side of the board with the
pawns and an unusual move played by um
black just moving the pawn to H6 I say
this is unusual because usually the
bishop wants to drop back to a better
diagonal and okay the bishop does drop
back to F5
yeah this really reminds me of a game
from the world championship between Ding
and napoleonishi where ding ended up
actually checkmating uh his opponent
there white was able to kind of uh get a
grip on the dark squares on the queen
side it would create this bind also that
evolved from the London system I think
uh the first and only time the London
system's been played at World
Championship level 100 score there for
white um but yeah this Pawn structure
anyway it's thematic it rises from lots
of different openings and uh lasovik
he's keeping up the pace at least he
spent less than 30 seconds and it's
already moved 15 uh so good signs for
him is black we've been seeing the
London so many times that Elite level
chess even in many of the critical games
at the World Cup and it makes an
appearance here and while white is
playing for those dark squares the
Knight jumping on maybe the queen Side
Pawn cramping the position more
advancing from A4 to A5 now Dennis
lazovic he defeated uh Fabiano caruana
in the bullet Championship recently with
an 11 and a half to nine and a half
score we know that his chest.com Blitz
rating is over 2 900. we're quite aware
of how strong he is in speed chess what
do we know about Amin tabatabai's mouth
skills Simon but he's a very quick
player I mean all these players are
extremely quick and they can turn up the
pace when they need to
um he's a very aggressive player
normally and I think the more you know
going back to the chest more pieces that
get exchanged the happier that Dennis is
going to be because uh you've got to
keep pieces on to win the game and with
this last move from black throwing the
Knight into the center is uh quite
interesting maybe that Knights can be
re-routed uh to the center and uh the
question is how is white Gonna Keep keep
this tension up here and I like this
move he's locking down that Queen side
David mentioned this game from the world
championships and this is exactly the
same thing that uh ding did against nepo
he was able to get his Knight to C5 and
play B4 in that game and if white can do
that I think he'd be very happy but it's
not clear how he's going to do that at
the moment
yeah I like what lasovic's done he's
maneuvered a knight to the D6 square and
actually in these types of Pawn
structures D6 is the dream Square for
any night likewise uh White Once a Night
on D3 but uh yeah at the moment it's
just this tension uh on the queen side
white pieces are slightly tied down
defending whites fire Advanced apron
so to better buy is trying to use
tactics now a slightly nasty pin to try
and release his pieces but he can now go
Knight C5 and he has played this and
this is the ding plan with the pawn
maybe coming up to B4 to support it and
then white has this really nice grip
right on that area that side of the
board so
um I I think progress being made now
would you exchange Queens here I mean
it's not really what you want to do when
you want to win the game but you still
have an advantage I would have thought
that I don't know if it is an advantage
but a grip at least on the queen side
here it's a good idea I've had
came about and I was the victim of it
and the first time that they did this
they just traded off queens and then
they just did the idea of going b2b4
establishing this grip and it's like you
guys were saying very very difficult to
break out and well for Las Vegas it's
just a question of holding Farm
holding firm and the one thing that did
lead to one of his defeats yesterday
against Carolina actually in the
Armageddon was in fact he was slightly
passive he lost the first game today
when he was slightly passive but luckily
here there isn't that much tension and
okay he's playing very very quickly he's
still only used just over a minute and
now we're at move 23 almost in the end
game with the Queens off the board uh
Tanya you mentioned the kind of Blitz
bullet skills uh I did just check on
chess.com lasovic is 100 points higher
than Tabata by he's 30 he's over 3 000
uh Blitz and he's over 3 100 at bullet
um so he's about 100 points higher than
tabataway in both Blitz and bullet
formats which shows his mouth skills
might be slightly Superior if the clocks
do tick down not bad at all not bad at
all but one thing I just wanted to
piggyback on is about online chess I
mean when you ask the top players how
many online games they've played I mean
the answer is like tens of thousands
and you know and you compare that advice
to say from vernick's time like in the
1950s and he was writing you must not
play more than 55 games per year
I'm I'm following that advice these days
but yeah her days
[Laughter]
yeah I did look at my stats recently I
did just see that I mean to better buy I
think he's played 15 000 on chess.com
alone how many numbers it's kind of
similar to Poker this is why everyone
got so much better at poker because they
were suddenly able to play online and
they could play something like 10 000
hands of poker a day maybe not that many
but if you play multiple tables it's
possible and they were learning so much
better than they could do in the past
maybe it's the same with chess you know
you can all of a sudden play so many
games of Chess learn so many things
quicker that you couldn't do in the days
of botanic
grew up on chess.com he's uh I don't
even know what's uh what's the amount of
games but it definitely runs in the tens
of thousands there so this younger
generation and I think that's what also
makes them so adaptive to how computers
have changed the chess and modern chess
and sort of just taking traditional
wisdom chucking it out of the window in
many cases being more concrete all the
principles that we knew now there are so
many exceptions to them and we always
see these younger Generations sort of
challenge all those older beliefs and I
think that's a big part of that is
because they have grown up playing so
much online these speeches fast chess
formats yeah absolutely and in the
meantime well Janice he's just been
moving around with his Knights just
trying to establish a plan meanwhile why
it has improved the position stepped up
with the King it's creeping forward and
now G3 G4 is in the air
but there is no big rush for I mean no
he's played it immediately yeah you
might as well I guess it's Armageddon
the players are Keen to release the
tension but it's all about the knights
it's a dance of the knights and if you
compare them white has two beasts two
octo knights we call them uh yesterday
in the middle of the board black snakes
are still looking for squares looking
for purchase here looking for outposts
and uh I mean you would pick white here
every day but still where's the
Breakthrough feels like Dennis has just
set up his barricades he set up his army
he said hey if you ever stepped any
pawns forward my Knights are ready to
jump and uh yeah I don't really see what
comes next it feels like uh ameen to
battle by has maxed out uh position he
needs a bit more what comes next I think
it's about that question we had earlier
on will this be about flagging and I
think there's a very big chance that it
is going to be about Dennis's clock here
with those nights that you're pointing
out more difficult for black to continue
playing moves for amen it's just going
to be about trying to get Dennis to run
out on the clock Meanwhile we're getting
huge update from division three where
minlay has uh defeated in a shocking
result he's defeated Anish giri one and
a half to half so Gary drops down to the
loser's bracket and you can follow all
the action from division three on
Grandmaster Ben feingold's twitch
Channel meanwhile action continues in
this one and now amen has slowed down
David as you said sure he wants to get
Dennis's clock to come down low try and
flag him but you still have to make
moves right now so how do you continue
in this position I would love to reroute
that Queen side Rook somehow yeah let's
just jump in while Amin has maybe his
first real long thing the game and Tanya
you want to kind of reposition repurpose
this Rook where to put it that's the big
question okay
thank you I mean for answering that
question for me and he drops it back and
okay we see a trade of Pawns I'm really
shocked by this to be honest uh yes the
Black Knight jumps in uh into E4 but
this is committal by Dennis lazovic and
we see now at least white does have a
plan of pushing the H Pawn I thought he
was just gonna sit there forever just
kind of curl up into a ball Dennis
lazovic but uh yeah now suddenly there
is a clear-cut plan he needs to
concretely justify his decision Simon do
you like this uh from last of it was
that saying if it's not broke you you if
it's not broke you don't need to fix it
that's the one and uh he had a nice
Fortress there and he could have uh
basically said to I mean you you're the
one who has to prove how to break down
his position so I I'm with you there
David he didn't need to play this I
still think the position is absolutely
fine for black though he's uh finding a
Target here with his last move and both
sides have these tricky Knights and if
they get shorter time it's going to be
very hard
to keep an eye on that the first
question is how do you actually defend
that pawn now yeah you cannot to find
that pawn on C3 because if you try to
defend him either your Rook you let go
of the protection of the ageful porn
yeah White's rook and H2 is tied down to
the H4 Pawn uh if you step this Pawn
forward the other Pawn in the center
drops with a check if you take Black's
Knight in the center then just to show
this uh the pawn on C3 drops maybe
there's something even better there for
black but uh this is a track and the
Knight will drop back to the center next
move yeah this is why the Young
Generation is so good I'm looking at
General kind of principles here I'm
thinking oh you let the white Pawn start
running you Let it Loose giving your
opponent a potential passport but no
they have concrete specific uh kind of
tailor-made uh kind of replies here and
yeah he's making it work just based on
just where White's pieces are positioned
right now that's
right now he has to find a way to fight
against the threat and he fails to do
that he simply moves the rope that means
an extra Pawn for Dennis
Bank it take that pawn and which side do
you take it with David
that's for Dennis last week to answer
that's too tough for me uh two choices
here
I normally I mean clients always I'm
biased to it towards taking away from
the scent kind of towards the center uh
but wow wow White Knight is trapped on
E5 yeah this is even bigger problem Oh
my God it's gonna be game over I think
yeah and I'm in reacts he missed this
idea completely as did we yeah not
obvious we were getting tempted by a
free Pawn but White's night is and to
Simply No Escape squares F6 is coming
next and we have to remember that this
is like you're out you know this is your
your big chance both of these players
haven't been in division one before and
if they lose this game uh they're gonna
be out of the of the tour so it's a
massive moment and uh you know this is
where you can see the emotions on the
faces and look at our men's emotions
there he he realizes that he's probably
going home
yeah because there's no coming back from
this you lose a pawn you can still fight
here he loses an entire piece and it's
we were talking about this being the
Octo Knight just a couple of moves ago
and now it's uh that meet F6 and the
game is over next yeah and uh it's
completely why it's our own fault you
know the Kings on F3 The Rook is on D3
He trapped his own Knight in the middle
of the board I mean it's just one of
life's blind spots and like you say
Tanya you can't get back from losing a
piece although there is history
I mean I remember this was in the
opening in tata steel he did lose a
piece and he did manage to complicate
things but here no chance he eventually
he won that game he won the game he won
the game but right now it is a
completely different battle the end game
and look at that amen he did shake his
head he's in disbelief he almost had
this match right in a best of two you
get the first win in you need only
a jaw and then you get into this
Armageddon you start with the white
pieces you bid for the white pieces 14
minutes and 50 seconds he's still
thinking but it's not gonna help
too late now it's too late now I mean
the question remains David like as you
said why did he change openings because
there's not really enough there wasn't
enough time for Dennis to uh work out
reply to to that first game that he lost
why didn't he just repeat that and put
the question to Dennis I mean obviously
everything's easy in hindsight but this
this didn't work out this plan is played
here he didn't get an advantage he
didn't get the kind of position he
wanted and even though he's winning a
piece here he wasn't making much
progress anyway really yeah and uh I
mean he probably wishes he blundered a
piece on move six uh like in that King's
Gambit game rather than blundering on me
40 where it's just too late no pieces
left to fight back no chance and that's
why he's uh thinking here I think he's
just coming to terms with the fact that
his journey in this tournament will be
over and uh yeah Simon his preparation
in game one was so deep with the white
pieces in that Auntie Berlin suddenly he
went into a London system which Dennis
lazovic has probably faced hundreds of
times before here we see the key move F6
that white knight had no Escape squares
uh it was blocked in hemmed in by itself
pieces and there we go it falls off the
board he has let's do a quick count one
punt
for that night but that's not enough
this is heartbreaking to watch
yeah I'm in can't believe it
yeah that's chess chess is cruel
unfortunately and he just needs to pick
himself up and try to create one chance
uh towards the end just at least give
the opportunity to lazovic of going
wrong but very unlikely at this stage
and the clocks are level as well and I'm
in there in complete disbelief
burnt out his time Advantage as well
he's down a piece uh David is there is
there an easy way for Dennis to to wrap
this up right now
probably
um do you just capture on H4 he starts
with a check yeah I would have been
tempted to simplify he starts with a
check and uh repurposes his Knight this
time that night is going to do a great
job of just holding everything together
while the black Rooks invade uh the
black Rooks will double up on the f file
most likely there we go and they're
coming in not much to do okay trying to
create a distraction in the past Pawn
the only hope is that somehow by a
miracle you trade off all the pawns on
the board and you might have some
drawing chances there but the operative
word is drawing chances David and
remember that I mean is in a must-win
situation and uh there you can see the
black king safest houses and the past G
Pawn well
doesn't have too many ambitious hopes
and we're coming to F1
it's going to be game over pretty soon
just amazing board awareness by Dennis
lazovic spotting that night trap we were
all thinking about grabbing the pond
getting greedy with the pawn but F6 an
idea and he played it in seconds uh
really awesome to see that and yeah I
mean just continues
to shake his head
I don't even think in his mind he's
really fighting it's about just
acceptance right now yeah it could have
been so different if he'd taken that
winning opportunity against Magnus in
game one yesterday who knows how that
match would have turned out uh here he
had the lead game two just one subpart
decision and Dennis punished him for it
and again this last game it was in the
balance for so long uh he had extra what
was it five six minutes on his clock but
uh not sufficient in the end and Dennis
just putting the finishing touches on
this one he's rounding up that white
g-pawn
White's gonna have to contort himself
just to hold on
for a few more moves
and the Knight can block checks on the
earth rank as well the king can March
forward to safety on C6 you probably
want to do that after rotated King D7
King C6 everything is safe on the king
side he's trying to hold on to the G
Pawn is there any hope at all for uh I'm
in this position with that jeep on and
the King
assisting it no no
I'm also just looking at moves like the
like retreating to E8 just so that it
can get ready to spring forward to the
F6 square and give a check
and uh there you can see it on the board
I think we're just waiting for the
inevitable but I I think uh as Tanya you
mentioned is I mean just you come into
terms that you know he's out and uh you
know he was but you know this is a
really exciting tournament for everyone
to qualify for now this is probably the
creme de La Creme of like online
tournaments everyone wants to get in the
first division everyone wants to get a
chance to play the top players and you
know losing two matches in a row it's
gonna be disappointing so uh he's he's I
think just uh acknowledging that fact
it's always painful to lose at chess it
never really gets less painful and uh
some of us are more used to it than
others
but uh you know it's part of the process
you know what I would do here Simon
good call good call David I do the same
I thought David your team never resigned
normally just reside right here yeah
look at that white Rook on G6 next to
the white king just completely trapped
uh can't get much worse can it can't
move what Black's just going behind now
Rook to H1 trade off that white Rook on
the H final and it's just gonna be
Checkmate I think he's gonna resign
because you know oh he's oh he's playing
yeah Rook H1 and okay this could be
quite funny actually you could try to
Checkmate the knight in King at some
point coming up
okay there's a G6 check coming in
Staying Alive
he's fighting
yeah I'll just wait give a check no he
takes Back The Rook first but oh the
evaluation bar oh and armor and he
suddenly leans forward does he sense the
chance here
half a chance maybe to possibly draw a
little bit half a chance or something
that's right this last move I think was
what Dennis missed actually he was
trying to provoke the white Pawn to go
forward to free up the Black Knight but
now actually yeah half a chance the
white Rook is coming up to F7 with a
check where it could start picking off
Black's Queen Side Pawn
yeah unfortunately black does have a
runner of an e-pawn so it's a recent
list
he's got a passport all of a sudden two
pass pawns and it was hopeless just 30
seconds ago and now it's just a little
bit less hopeless
well the evaluation was really teasing
us here
White's gonna give a check with the Rook
maybe can trade off a set of Pawns in
the center first it's just a pure race
and I don't think either side has got
time to calculate this out just got to
play by Instinct it feels like black
should be quick enough because black
spawn is so close to promotion uh but
yeah anything can happen in races I'm
sure we've all been there where we've
miscounted and suddenly things get out
of control
but we do have to remember it has to be
a win for white as well because if white
somehow salvages a draw here he still
gets knocked out so it's uh it's a big
ass kill and with things you can't I was
thinking you could check the black king
here but then
repeating positions is absolutely fine
you don't need to win as black so this
is what's happening just move the king
back and this is an example of going
through the draw here white has to play
for a win which is kind of like he's not
going to repeat he can't afford to
repeat it's it's as good as losing and
he has to just keep going but now it's
done last who's got more time than Amin
as well
it gives a track that's asking a
different question this time hinting
that he might capture the black A6 Pawn
B5 looks tempting as well just to start
running with all of White's remaining
pawns B5 looks worth a punt you know get
as many past pawns as you can as quickly
as you can if you couldn't believe
Black's D Pawn off the ball but somehow
like you know just like you know sweep
it off then you've probably got some
chances here good chances your good
chances to win from that situation but
unfortunately the Deep porn does exist
and that will be moving forward
and his time as well he's already he's
also half half the time of Dennis now
which when you don't get increment you
don't get any extra time that that's a
big thing you know you could you know
you need to keep ahead on the clock in
bad positions I mean terrible positions
terrible indeed the frustrating thing is
you just cannot get that white Rook
behind Black's d-pawn the Black Knight
covers some key squares uh the one thing
you cannot do here as well is give
another check with the white Rook that
would be the third time we've seen that
position one minute left okay he tries
this is his last gamble to about to buy
but Black's Pawn is two squares away now
I think it's too uh too fast it's over
gonna become a new Queen wow yeah and
that 98 which looks uh like it's doing
nothing is actually doing a very
important job here stopping White's Rook
from defending the d-pawn and now you
give a check but with D1 in the air
there isn't much to be done black can
simply fall forward go ahead with the
King you don't want to fall back because
the a pawn then advances with a check
so yeah and often you get these
situation situations where both sides
Queen at the same time but it's the
person who Queens first uh when there's
pieces on the board and you you could
get this now who normally just ends up
checkmating uh because with a rook queen
and the Knight on the board the white
king it's just gonna be too exposed so I
think you can safely get a queen and
Checkmate yeah my queen D3 should be
game over yeah it's gonna be forced
Checkmate here just within a couple of
moves
probably multi multiple ways to do it
but don't give Rook H1 check because
that Queen on it can grab the Rook they
just don't check on any Square covered
by that long diagonal I think get the
knight in looks good as many yeah as you
say you still have to calculate it
though I mean there's still chance to go
wrong you've got Queen F3
[Music]
we're all the ways black and lose queen
of three rookette 20 gives a check from
it seven forcing rookie it's six will he
come in with the Knight now
looks like a killer okay he gives a
check with the queen also very efficient
here diagonal checks always seem to work
in Queen and games could we see a queen
a free blunder
I don't know we need a bit more drama
somewhere
and uh I can imagine myself Falling For
The Rook H1 oh yeah Jack were you for
instance I think white is absolutely
forced to kind of intercept that check
with the Rook
[Laughter]
and that's it he has resigned after
Queen F7 16 year old Dennis lazovic
continues in the Julius bear generation
cup what a performance after losing the
first game making his comeback and then
taking it in the Armageddon despite
losing the bid for ramintama to buy it
has been a heartbreaking loss David I
know you have a lot to choose from what
was that one big moment for you I think
we just need to show that blunder of the
piece again uh Dennis lazovic really
opportunistic here he spotted something
that we all miss here in the studio that
his opponent had missed after the move
wrote to D3 which seems innocent
innocuous actually it's taken away the
one remaining Escape square of this
white knight and uh after trading off he
did pounds Pawn to F6 and you can see
why this Knight needed to have access to
D3 it simply couldn't move and going up
a piece we saw a few twists and turns
along the way but eventually he did
guide the game towards Victory as black
this incredible board awareness there
and this was the moment that I'm in
tabataba realized it was all over after
that blunder something that was so easy
to miss but Dennis lazovic really on top
of the game what a fine what a trap
there and head shakes it dejected
disappointed um it is the end of his
Road in the Julius bear generation cup
after a great performance in the planes
but it is Dan Laz who continues forward
in the losers bracket and not a back up
to such of who took the win in his match
against Pavel eleanov
and uh we will be
joined by Dennis last week
in just moments we'll be right back
[Music]
um okay we're playing a defensive move
Nakamura offers a draw that move and
Magnus accepts Magnus wins the
tournament Magnus Carlsen is the winner
of the new in chess Classics he knows
it's going to be all over soon 20
seconds and practice wins wow look at
that Magnus Carlton in Armageddon one
Pawn marches forward one is blocked the
other goes and that causes Artemis to
resign Magnus Carlsen is the winner of
the aim chess U.S uh rapid but there it
is it ends here Magnus Carlsen winning
two games today he is the winner of the
air things monster she has a Defender
look at that smile
um the Champions League's Magnus Carlsen
wins the charity cup
to win the tournament wow and there it
is it's over ordinary guys he resigns
facing an impossible world number one
Magnus Carlton with a slight smile there
he is the winner of the Julius vert
generation cup let's have magnets in the
picture as well as he finishes the 2022
season there it is the winner of the
match the winner of the Wild Water
championship in 2022 and the winner of
the tour finals it's over we have a
winner Magnus Carls who takes it he wins
the air things Monsters the checkmating
it's on the boat Simon there we go oh my
God and we have a winner from
checkmates Wesley so and wins the aim
chess Robin
he plays and he wins Magnus Carlsen with
his incredible performances in the past
champions chapter he's already won two
events in this season he will be in
action in just a few moments from now
taking on world number three you drive
but it is The Clash of Titans as he will
face Fabiano caruana and the five-time
three day world champion recently
winning uh the only the only title that
eluded him the World Cup as well we will
see him in just a few moments but first
we've got the 16 year old tennis last
week joining us Dennis congratulations
to armageddons you've had in this
tournament and today you turned it
around how are you feeling
I feel good
Dennis your match
sorry
yeah yeah
your match against I mean tell us about
that uh because you have to make a
comeback it was a difficult situation
you lost the first game how did you get
that confidence to keep going and make a
comeback in this match
um yes in first game he's a completely
outplayed me and
actually
I I didn't think that I can can win
first
second game
but uh
after the opening I
I had
[Music]
some interesting position and
uh he maybe he played some bad movement
then
I had this opinion game
yeah it was it was awesome to see you in
the second game and then a fantastic
Armageddon especially when you trapped
his Knight with the move F6 that was
awesome uh Dennis what's it like to play
in division one uh to play against these
uh these big pairs what does this mean
for you
all right
it's very nice to play I I'm I'm very
glad to play in
first divisions
[Applause]
I
yeah
it's amazing
it is amazing and you're the youngest
ever player in the Champions uh chess
store division one so it's awesome to
see you in the field and Dennis we've
been really admiring the medals at the
back as well is that your trophy cabinet
no
it's it's just my room and it's uh
[Music]
nice experience
well it is a very inspiring place to
play chess from and that is great
performance today and we wish you all
the best for your upcoming match
thank you
with a big win against
but big names continue in the winners
semi-finals we will have Magnus Carlsen
against Fabiano caruana and also Wesley
so taking on alireza feruja we spoke to
Fabi yesterday we asked him about his
thoughts on playing against Magnus take
a look I think I've I've usually managed
up in magnus's side of the bracket so we
we were supposed to play or like we were
kind of slated to play in um
in this second event but we didn't
because our time we have beat Magnus and
then we did play in the one previous to
this
uh and and Magnus beat me two and a half
one and a half so I'm hoping to get some
Revenge of course I don't expect it to
be uh to be easy of course my playing
Magnus is always a colossal struggle but
but hopefully I'll be up to the task
he didn't get the match he wanted
against Magnus in the final but he is
looking forward to today's matchup it's
never easy to play against uh Magnus
what are you expecting from this Clash
David well Magnus does start is the
favorite just because he's been so
impressive in QuickTime controls over
the last few years of course they had
that history 2018 it was decided in
Rapid after all their world championship
match Magnus won that but Fabiano has
been turning things around especially
the last 12 months 24 months he's really
upped his game and if he catches Magnus
cold in the first game or two I think
he's uh yeah he's got a big big chance
but it will come down to the first game
or two I feel uh yeah he can't let Magna
strike first yeah this is going to be a
really exciting match I feel I mean
you've got two players who won the best
form uh out of anyone in the world at
the moment you've got Magnus who's
winning everything and uh you've got
Fabiano who's also playing great chess I
mean he's just done extremely well on
the World Cup he's that he's played uh
brilliant I think he's played really
well since ding since Magnus actually as
step down from being world champion I
think Fabiano's kind of realized it he
could actually have another shot
becoming world champion himself and uh
this uh this is another chance to sort
of prove that point so uh yeah I don't
know I'm looking forward to it I am
certainly looking forward to it because
uh Fabi also mentioned that he was out
for Revenge that's my most favorite
personal reason
yeah it is uh going to be a big fight
between these two and really interesting
what you said Simon that perhaps uh
fabi's Founders renewed motivation and
we've been seeing him play some
excellent chess uh this past year and
let's take a look at our format in the
winner semi-finals it will be a best of
four it will be a best of four and two
and a half points wins the match as
always the players get 15 minutes with a
three second increment and it's not just
Fabi versus Magnus we have another big
Clash Ivanka I'm super excited to see
what happens when Wesley the soul solid
Wesley takes on the very aggressive
alireza I know that one is going to be a
real Clash of styles and we haven't seen
alireza farisha play too much of late he
didn't play in the World Cup he did not
play in the world wrap it and Wesley did
play both those events and wasn't too
successful but farouza showed us that
he's been working hard and yesterday he
put on such a powerful performance he
just completely blew off uh abdicator
from the board
that was uh incredible to watch it's
always great to watch alireza play some
tests and today will be an exciting
battle as he takes on Wesley so the
clocks are ticking one more time which
means that the players are getting set
to make their first moves and while we
didn't see alireza in the World Cup
definitely a disappointment for a lot of
Chess fans across the world he's back in
the Champions Chester he hasn't won an
event he hasn't booked his spot yet in
Toronto so this one means a lot to him
this could be his shot to get that seat
uh to the season and final and for
Wesley as well yeah for Wesley as well
you know because the winner of this
event actually gets the Toronto spot so
everything to play for and you're right
you know when feruja first played in the
air things Masters he was eliminated
pretty quickly and there we see Wesley
so on the screen in his home in
Minnesota getting ready to play I think
Point as well I mean Wesley if he wins
this match he he guarantees himself a
place as well in the next round but
um that actually came down to Dennis
Dennis must be hoping that Wesley loses
because Dennis still has a chance to
qualify uh for the Grand Final by
winning that last match
um good good camera action going on
there
yeah and uh yeah he does need to get
cleaner though I think that's clear oh
and uh oh what's that bit of massage
stuff going on there but it's quite
funny to see their pregame routine he
has said it before he's got this ice
pack I think just he's had some historic
uh problems pains injuries uh maybe he's
just yeah playing hurt here he's
pretending he's injured Leo Magnuson to
a false sense of security but either way
we're about to get action we're about to
kick off Magnus we'll start with white
and I can't wait this is going to be a
fantastic fight it always is between
these two never any quick draws ever
between these two and uh okay we see
action it's a case opening what will
Magnus go for will it be the Spanish
seems to be the theme of the tournament
the opening of the tournament so far the
Royal pairs the Spanish opening and uh
okay which variation will Carolina
choose for it's the Archangel the
arkangels variation and Magnus he showed
some preparation against this he's faced
it a few times in recent history had it
yesterday against the men didn't he say
yeah I think and he got a very good
position there didn't he David in that
one I think so yeah he faced it at the
World Cup too I remember kind of a
mammoth battle in this one as uh kind of
between these two uh warriors uh I love
man a few years back with colors
reversed when it was actually Magnus
employing this opening against Fabi so
mind games they're kind of going down
this well-trodden path where uh of
course there's so so much Theory it's uh
definitely Magnus in recent years he's
kind of steering into that despite the
fact that kind of traditionally it's
Fabiano with the opening uh kind of
knowledge the opening expert
interesting moment here white has
various ways to play
like this the first one to think first
one to Blink yeah this bishop C5 move
that we we see uh Fabiano play the
Archangel variation is probably one of
the the sharpest variations the Royal
Lopez because black is trying to develop
that dark Square Bishop to a very active
square but it does come with downsides
because you can walk into a pin
um that Knight on the king's side can
often be pinned we saw that happening
yesterday Magnus beating uh our men with
that with that idea and this is another
idea with a black the dark Square
Bishop's facing off against each other
which can also be dangerous at the right
moment white can push the pawn in the
center and make a favable exchange of
Bishops here so it's it's a really uh uh
quite I don't know courageous way to
play but it is very heavily theoretical
isn't it this line because uh um both
sides can get in trouble very quickly if
if they don't know what they're doing
rookie eight first think is Magnus
and Magnus are trying to figure out his
middle game approach here and don't be
fooled because there are always tactics
here it might look like the E4 Pawn is
under Fire but White's got ideas uh of
his own with that light Squad Bishop
Magnus base is his own rook in the
center it's going to be a slow strategic
fight meanwhile we have got kickoff
which is about to happen in the west
Lisa against the alireza matchup Wesley
starting with the white pieces and what
are we expecting in this one David will
Wesley start with the King's phone
opening it
yeah I was about to say Tanya it's
likely one E4 because it brought
Wesley's success but he also started
with the Knight of three in that final
game yesterday against Eliana where he
just needed a draw uh so uh Wesley here
just showing that he can kind of serve
in different ways he can open uh he's
really flexible in the opening and okay
it looks like it's headed towards a
king's Indian defense for Russia here
feeding katowing his bishop and it's the
main line King's Indian this shows
fighting Ambitions here from farrugia
um this tends to lead to really
imbalanced play Knight A6 not the
mainline uh but still well known and
yeah she has both players not playing
safe at this early stage this is what we
were talking about right The Clash of
styles and alireza deciding to play a
very ambitious opening against Wesley
means that he wants to get his kind of
positions he does Andrew I remember a
few years ago that Wesley was playing
like the most critical moves here but
again recent years he's kind of taken
more safety first approach so we're
gonna see how how exactly he's going to
continue is he going to step up with his
Pawn or is he going to play another move
yeah it's like a game of chicken this
type of position it's like black is
saying Please block the center please
close the center please step forward
with uh the white D Pawn to D5 and then
black can decide maybe to switch play
against the white king and uh okay
where's where's league on hide and seek
no where's Wally where's uh where's
Wesley
and uh okay he's back uh meanwhile
thinking and yeah he is the one to
decide to close the center to break the
tension often you can wait a bit longer
there as white but sooner or later this
happens in very typical King's Indian
plans yeah yeah I know I remember
actually a friend of mine commenting on
Wesley's like opening strategy in this
particular variation and he was like
yeah Wesley's not afraid and then I do
remember commenting on a tournament
where Wesley absolutely got destroyed by
Alexander grishak and well Wesley he is
a man who knows his stuff so I'm eager
to see what he's going to play now it to
me it looks like Pawn takes porn is
absolutely forced otherwise the bishop
is gonna get trapped inside porn storm
here coming from black and often this
Pawn break is kind of the most thematic
break in the king's Indian black is
struggling for space on the center Queen
side so you need some activity on the
king side and if you can capture as
white on the F5 Square as Wesley has
done and Force black to take back with a
piece you're usually pretty happy but of
course there are some details to work
out here the Black Knights going back
and white king will be a Target no
matter what uh Wesley has to reposition
re-maneuver his pieces uh in order to be
ready for any oncoming attack
Simon you've played this opening
yourself a few times yeah I really I
really enjoy playing the king's Indian
defense as one of my favorite openings
it's perfect for players who like an
aggressive game
um you know like attacking like
counter-attacking Bobby Fischer um going
was one of the first people to play it
and then Gary Kasparov of course
um and I've seen like you mentioned
Wesley uh playing the main lines of this
on the white side a game everyone should
look at is actually a game he lost to
Hikaru Nakamura in the main line that's
a brilliant game from Hikaru there but
this is a common idea white now trying
to get that
Square in the center of the board and
I'm thinking black should probably push
that pawn now in the center of the ball
because if white gets a grip by moving
that Knight into E4 it is always going
to be a small Advantage white there's
nothing can do and
um this this Knight will be very hard to
budge and white can play around that
square another common idea so this is
why uh farouza has stopped that plan
moved his pawn and opened up his own
bishop and an interesting position we
have here yeah King's Indian Bishop very
happy with that last decision uh Tanya
what do you make of uh the chances here
looks really complicated to me I love it
I love uh this opening approach by
alireza and I think E4 was absolutely
critical to make sure that white knight
doesn't land on that square we've been
seeing so many Pawn uh pushes in the
center to get that space going and I
think the team continues with this one
Simon you mentioned Bobby Fischer played
the king's Indian and then we had Gary
Kasparov uh in chess can we also Trace
certain Styles back to iconic players
yeah certainly I mean historically
um going through the world champions
they they all brought something
different to chess I mean steinerts the
first world champion official world
champion
he really liked the center and he wanted
to control the center and uh every world
champion
um basically gave something new and uh
progressed the game and I wonder what
magnuses will be when people look back
in 100 years and they think ah Magnus
Carlson he was the grinder and him and
his great pal David their book the
best-selling book I learned everything I
know from that book which came out today
so make sure you get yourself a copy
grind like a grand master
um great great thanks Simon I'll get you
a glass of wine later
we're all about a subject of uh
players and the influences they exude on
the world I read once that the top
players of every country has an
influence on the coming generation so
when Mikhail tal was around all the
Latvian players obviously looked at him
as their Idol and they became very sharp
players and it just seems to follow that
everyone just looks at their best player
and goes okay I like that style and
therefore they play like way yeah
they're sort of inspired by the play
they study they grow up idolizing like
that like for me you know I was really
influenced by Michael Adams you know I
saw that the way he played and I thought
isn't this beautiful the way he just
moves his pieces and finds good squares
and it's all about Harmony and so I very
much modeled my game and my openings on
him and I think for all of these Indian
youngsters it's uh right his Universal
style of play uh him being the lightning
kid in his younger years and that's why
we see so many of them also being really
inspired to play speech chess his style
of play his approach to game his
Fighting Chess his ability to adapt in
situations I can go on and on this needs
its own broadcast but I think you're
completely right Ivanka that these
iconic players of the past they really
truly do leave a big mark on the Next
Generation you were asking what Magnus
would be remembered for I think we could
agree with that just his end game
technique it's one of the biggest points
and I think he's really changed over the
last 10 years how people viewed end
games and end game play you'd very often
just agree for a draw and we will
continue that conversation but David a
big move on the board huge move and a
committed decision from Far Asia we saw
him go into the tank there for a few
minutes and eventually dive forward with
his Pawn into E3 it looks like the most
tempting moves uh move in the position
now you are attacking this Knight of
course trying to open up the white king
too and if this Pawn is captured I guess
the black Queen's just going to come in
double attack and uh there are some
tricks here I was wondering if you could
sacrifice your queen if White's Bishop
blocks for example you could take this
bishop trick the white king into coming
forward I don't see a Checkmate I wanted
to try and trap this king I don't see a
way at the very least you could win back
the material you can give a check
discovered attack and uh after King H2
also do the same
which is very very exciting so yeah
pretend I saw that one
and a check and the white king gets
chased onto the f file where you can
suddenly again unleash an attack move
win the White Queen and level material
but black has the advantage and all the
fun of course in that position so I
don't think you should get tempted after
Pawn to E3 to take it
but what else
do you have to move the Knight maybe you
can move your Bishop out the way uh you
can step the bishop to F3 maybe to H5 uh
maybe this one just to try and pin the
pawn against the black queen
no time to go and take the White Knight
now
and if you trade off at least white can
safely take back and no tricks against
this guy the white king
and then actually there's no sense to
Black's position at all you know because
the white Knights are then going to jump
into the center and I don't know about
you but I feel that the G5 Pawn is gonna
be weak yeah
really weak
and uh
looks to me like this is turning in
White's favor so Wesley lots of choice
here you can move the knights as well of
course which is attacked you can move
the bishop to other squares but
evaluation partly says it's in White's
favor and uh he's rightfully thinking
here
and if you just felt like such a scary
move when it lands on the board it
definitely makes you just take a step
back and evaluate what's going on so
everything else apart from taking on E3
would be a good option for white hair
yeah I think so I mean taking on E3
looks just far too dangerous because you
allow Black's Queen to enter into the
position and why allow your opponent's
Queen the most dangerous piece to get
active uh if you don't take that pawn
then the black queen can't can't get
into the position so I really like
David's bishop move because it stopped a
rook coming across but maybe you can
move the knight uh but this this move
just seems so logical uh and great minds
they do do you think alike okay there
you go on the board and we're now gonna
have to see what uh farusha's idea is
here because obviously he would have
seen this and I'm trying to work it out
you know he he didn't have to push that
pawn he had a I think a decent position
anyway but it was very tempting but you
need a follow-up you have to have a
follow-up and what is that follow-up
here I mean there's some crazy ideas but
they all look
rubbish
[Music]
um yeah so I don't know it'd be
interesting to see what he's going to
play here okay he's just taking one of
two David but I don't really believe
this because
um if anything the opening of the
position probably helps white because
white gets the open e-file for The Rook
yeah I think we should give this
position some time to breathe because
it's still Level material but uh I'm
choosing weight here all the time
and I agree or with you David because
also yes white looks like you've got the
better safer Pond structure your Rook on
the e-line but even for black you've got
you've got play along the f file uh the
bishop on F5 looking active if Black's
Knight can find its way to the center of
the board uh things could get better and
uh gas de valbar says that white has a
big Advantage there's still a lot to
play for and it's far away from calling
uh calling it a day for black so we will
come back to this one let's head over to
Magnus versus
Fabi and a lot has happened there and a
double beep on for Magnus yeah this
position has blown up and a lot of
exchanges a lot of Trades uh still Level
material we should mention maybe we just
wow I was about to say let's jump in and
do a quick uh action replay of what's
happened but suddenly I'm noticing
magnus's clock down at five minutes
against almost 13 and a half minutes uh
so maybe Magnus has walked into Fabiano
caruana's preparation not the first time
anyone's done that uh Fabi famous for
that of course but now Magnus putting
his Knight on the rim I was gonna say as
well in the other game for Russia with
those two black knights on A6 and H6
didn't make a great impression now white
tonight slightly sidelined
do you fear for Magnus despite the fact
he's still got control White Queen
nicely centralized
instincts here Simon Ivanka who would
you pick and why
I'm I mean I I guess positionally white
seems to be doing pretty well because
White's got a nice Queen in the center
uh got some holes on on the queen side
so White's pressure on the center on the
queen side but black has this beautiful
Knight hanging around White's King and
that's a real nuisance and uh also this
this move H3 uh this is a real Target
the the bishop of fabianos is pointing
at that point you're looking at what I'm
looking at Simon wow I'm ready yeah I'm
definitely thinking about taking that
and getting to Rook around I mean if
black could ever get the queen into the
king side the attack would be uh
tremendous here
um but fortunately White's night stops
uh Fabiano's Queen ever coming in uh but
there's there's potential here maybe
some some move like this looks yeah it
is definitely setting up Bishop takes H3
now if black gets one more move black
will be have a winning attack here with
that idea you know just to show this
Simon Bishop takes H3 would be a killer
Checkmate would be incoming Queen and
Knight The Dream attack and combo sorry
Ivanka go on how do you see a defense
here yeah I was gonna say play becomes
very concrete because of this threat and
I feel that the only way to handle this
is you need to get rid of this Knight on
F4 by Magnus playing my move before I
get to show it green E3
wow and G5 he's really committing he's
cementing uh this Knight on F4 this
really strong attacking piece but it's
coming the cost of Black's King safety
if a white knight ever ends up on this
side of the board near the black king
that could be devastating but uh still
in the air we should teach porn
really interesting stuff I mean maybe
you can go Knight D4 now maybe this is
magnus's clever idea and we saw again a
bit of bit of shades of yesterday the
way he won against I mean yesterday was
a Min played this move G5 and Magnus
managed to get his Knight into the
square next to that pawn the F5 square
and he's done it again this also stops
the sacrifice because uh the Queens will
come off and obviously you don't want to
sacrifice then exchange Queens generally
so uh I'm not sure I mean whose King is
going to be weaker here now
time being there are no white pieces
sniffing around Black's King so it's not
a weakness per se and I would actually
say that because White's Knight on A5 is
completely misplaced that black has
enough activity and compensation to
offset this kingside weakness so I'm
expecting Fabi just the kind of activate
your work put it on C8
and uh just let the clip let the play
Flow organically
why does playing without a piece which
uh is slightly worrying but I guess
Magnus still has some Targets this D6
Pawn is isolated long term White's doing
very very well here but Abby needs to
play dynamically he's got nearly seven
extra minutes on the clock maybe he'll
look for something a bit more direct a
bit concrete here uh yeah this position
could go either way despite the fact
it's level material roughly balanced so
far uh both players going for it
love to see it absolutely David and
Fabiano with the very straightforward
player very directly and when you're
playing against uh Magnus Carlsen it is
about trying to get him get him into
these chaotic territories uh where as
Michael Dal we were talking about
influences of iconic uh past players as
Mikhail say is a sort of a forest of
complication where the part is narrow
enough for just one player to get out so
when you make a move like G5 when you
start targeting the king side you're
playing with the black pieces I think
this is exactly the kind of play that
you need uh if you want to win a match
against Magnus yeah it's Dynamic he's
imbalanced and when David started saying
maybe you need to be a bit more direct I
was thinking hang on a second F5 D5 and
okay we see Fabi has taken that advice
to heart and uh launched the F Pawn
forward
wow
I certainly playing aggressively I mean
I I love seeing this from Fabi he's
playing the most aggressive moves
possible and uh this is this is the way
against Magnus right I mean he's got so
much experience playing Magnus he he
knows his strengths he knows if there
are any his weaknesses and uh I I just
love I I love the confidence of playing
G5 and F5 I don't know if it's any good
but it's it's certainly
um very interesting yeah trying to get
the rook in the game yeah that's right
he's playing the man he's I mean if
Magnus stabilizes then he'll slowly
outmaneuver you he'll weave his web and
uh you'll slowly get strangled so he's
playing the man here fabid by trying to
attack but he's also playing the clock
seven minutes up still great preparation
of course from frabby uh to get this
time Advantage but also this last move
it sets some traps uh we need to jump in
and see what happens if Magnus takes
this Pawn I think already taking would
be a significant mistake because Bishop
to D5 would open up an attack against
the White Queen and gang up against this
weak G2 Pawn suddenly white would be on
the back foot instead he does move his
Queen out of Dodge out of the way Queen
to G3 and uh okay still a lot of tension
the whole idea is after a trade of Pawns
here Black's Knight is actually attacked
because it's not technically defended by
the G Pawn the G Pawn is pinned so you
do gain some time in the process here as
white uh to kind of set up your pieces
on better squares but really really
complicated I wouldn't be surprised if
Fabi finds another way to continue
attacking to continue uh creating
threats maybe you just move your king
out of the way of the G file maybe trade
off pawns first before doing that I
really want to get the black queen to
kind of uh find a more active Squad
don't think you can come across yet
because still some tension on the F5
Pawn but watch out for this queen uh
kind of finding a better Square in the
near future
this one I again the clock times I'm
normally a stickler for kind of those in
time trouble I'm saying okay it's enough
time it's enough time but this is a wild
position it might not be
three and a half minutes in this kind of
position just doesn't seem enough and we
haven't seen Magnus with so much of a
clock deficit usually he's the one who's
got the advantage on the clock putting
the pressure and Fabi with the black
pieces going all in on this one once you
push Gary the Jeep on Freddy the F Pawn
down the board F5 G5 there's no backing
out now now you have to continue with
Dynamic play any end game any long long
battles will favor Whitetail yeah
totally and strategically you can just
look at this and go well the pawn on A6
will be a Target in the end game and
like you say it's all about King safety
and Black's King is weak and he needs to
generate some compensation so I was just
thinking about David's moves and which
one would I over choose I I feel like
just getting the king to safety is my
initial thought because I feel like porn
takes porn and would improve the placing
of the white work
big big moment in the Magnus Fabi
matchup and we're getting some big
updates from division two as well if you
haven't been following it on chess
dojo's Channel you've been missing out
on some
some really interesting battles in Juicy
fights as Levon aronian who is fighting
for a spot in Toronto with door points
has defeated Alex is Serana he needs
those wins and he is true too the winner
semi-final where he will face vladislav
artemiev who defeated Laurent frasenet
in a big margin two and a half to half
in a very fascinating battle Jana
pamishi also goes through uh to the
semi-finals and will be playing against
Amin basem Yan took down Vladimir
fettucci a little bit of a heartbreak
there for fedorship who's looking for
those tour points to get into Toronto
and then for ramen Bassam also a good
day as he'll be facing Yan in the
semi-finals after he's taken down Solem
only so the action will continue in
division two where the stakes are high
ten thousand dollars for the first prize
as well as 50 tour points and the winner
qualifies for the next division one uh
Champions chest or events and for a
bunch of these players including Levon
including Big Fish Vladimir feducev
there is a a lot on the line as they're
looking to make it to Toronto
it's all about those points and I mean
at this level anyone could be anyone
some really interesting results there uh
also yeah I think maybe the only doctor
out of the Champions chess tour
um yeah representing Africa of course
he's
doing so well these days just one of the
best rapping players out there
also such a nice guy yeah I mean all of
these guys
they're too nice they're brutal over the
board they hate each other over the
board but uh in person they're very very
it's it's an interesting weather Dr
basem he's like like you said a very
very nice guy he's from Egypt uh the
only African player to her past 2700 and
he has his own chess score so talking
about inspiring the generations he very
much is doing that I don't know how he
does it because he's a practicing doctor
as well
not practicing oh he's not
he's not because he's
so many years uh but uh yeah I thought
he was uh or maybe he is maybe he is
actually yeah
he's doing surgery on someone now
well he did manage to win against
suleimanley and he will be facing Jana
Bombay that's gonna be quite a battle
with Jana against bassim and of course
you can follow all of uh division two
action it's got some of the biggest
names in the Chess World fighting it out
for these critical tour points and it's
all happening on chest dojo's twitch
Channel and right now all the action is
happening in this game uh Magnus with
three and a half minutes but Fabi has
gone into a huge thing after that last
move not an easy decision to make once
you've over expanded on the king side no
finally after almost five minutes of
thought he does trade off in the center
Ivanka wasn't such a big fan of this it
does improve the white Rook big big
threat on the board of taking that black
knight okay now that Knight is backed up
by The Black Queen but this has allowed
the other white Rook some really nice
juicy squares to zoom over to and yeah
it definitely feels like this last trade
it was reluctant from Fabiano but he
didn't find anything else he didn't want
to take a time out to kind of improve
the black king
it's not clear where the black king
really belongs with such an open kind of
formation around it so what he's done is
very solid but of course he wanted a bit
more aggression and wow jumping in
Magnus Carlson with a knight this is a
deflection tactic the Knight is actually
on priest and we as we would say it's
attacked it can be captured by The Black
Queen but then White's Rook would take
the Black Knight on F4 so it's just an
offer of a trade but meanwhile yeah that
white knight was doing nothing it was
offside why not trade it off for Black's
beautiful uh steed nice tactic yeah yeah
I mean it started to look like uh I'm I
was thinking Black's position was going
a bit wrong uh because White's King just
seems so safe here and white has this
beautiful night in the center quite nice
coordination and uh I think Magnus is
trying to build on that with this move
and there's a bit of danger here for
Fabiano I mean for example if he did
take that Knight you can just see his
position completely collapsing
um because you know white would win the
piece back and uh look at the Kings
that's all you have to do the king
safety White's night beautiful and um
this position I think Magnus would would
just be winning winning this uh to be
honest with the black king being so weak
so you have to avoid that so so what's
on the board it's on the board I mean
okay I I I'm amazed this on the board I
would have tried to find another
solution if I was happy here because you
pointing out some some moves there David
H4 Rook F6 you know Black's best move
here is G5 G7 move that pull him back in
front of your king and you might be okay
but with the pawn on G5
it just looks too loose to me it looks
way too loose that's why he's moved his
Queen over to the G7 Square you do have
to remember Queens are fantastic
attackers they're also great Defenders I
think this is a good idea big threat on
the board of taking that Rook but Simon
I completely agree with you
Flex position is looking shaky and uh
there you go white centralizing The Rook
getting ready to line up on that file
line up on that file and you want that
Knight to jump into F5 so Black's got to
watch out where you move that Bishop you
don't don't want to lose control of the
F5 Square it looks like things are
turning around we were talking about
Fabi being aggressive but suddenly the
last few trades Knight B7 it's got to be
a star move that one beautiful move but
I'm really confused why was Magnus
shaking his head there he looks really
annoyed at himself really unhappy with
himself for a second but now he's
recomposed uh he was just like oh maybe
he thought there was something even
better but to me it looks like he's
played some really uh flashy clever
moves wow apparently a blunder on the
board from Fabiano what is this he's
jumped out the way with this bishop
this was based on the fact that the
White Knight will be hanging after a
rook trade but what is the winning blow
here for white
computer confirms this is winning now
for Magnus Carlson Kent it's a very
clever move here it takes A6 wow I think
it's queen bee free and then you come on
H6 with check
oh maybe is that possible look at that
guys the computer suggests three moves
they're all winning both of your
suggestions both Rook takes A6 Queen to
B3 sliding across with a check and even
trading Rooks first same idea I think
visual k6 is lovely as well sorry yeah I
sort of love that idea if it works
that's really nice Rook A6 you see the
way Magnus just reacted after Bishop H3
leaning forward he could sunset uh
probably first shock and wait a second
was this move even possible but he
realizes that this shouldn't work and
David there is more than one way for
Magnus to get a huge Advantage it's more
than one way he has chosen Simon's move
the check just to show uh the other one
equally effective actually there Ivanka
really nice geometry Rook takes Pawn
overwhelming these two black Rooks no
matter which Rook takes a white Rook the
other Rook will fall if you take this
one uh this one Falls with check this is
decisive uh with the attack if you take
the other Rook the other Rook towards
false with check and this would be game
over but instead he's uh gone for maybe
the more human approach uh Queen to B3
and as you say Simon the black simply
there's nowhere to go yeah this is the
G5 movie which weakened it but I think
the artist's move was Rook takes A6
though right that that was definitely uh
had a bit of flair to it but this move
the problem is uh
um the black king yeah it's just far too
weak you exchange Rooks you take the
bishop and uh
well you know it's easy to see what what
will happen here now we see why we
tricked the black king into the corner
because you take this Pawn with check
the king moves you can take another Pawn
with check if you want uh you can give a
check on this Square yeah everything is
winning now your material up and with an
ongoing attack this is on the board and
Magnus Carlson is going to mop up
everything it's going to take everything
with check Queen takes Pawn as well and
uh the black king hunted maybe Rook a
free as well yeah at the right moment I
mean just just time it well if you can
and uh
why not I only see one check and your
king seems to be pretty safe on H2 yeah
because you need to get another piece to
in into the game to finish this off the
only other piece of The Rook so let's
swing it around and uh looks like a
killer right so
yeah it looks like a killer Magnus
Carlson's gonna win this game it was a
blunder from Fabiano but we should
mention it was a difficult position uh
his King was already weak he was already
facing long-term difficulties
uh but wow what a start to this one wow
I
could Fabi deciding to go Bishop HD when
there were so many ways for white to
refute it no because um mistakes don't
happen in a vacuum and as David said the
position was getting difficult you know
he'd already missed a star move which
was a magnus's knight to B7 that
completely turned the tables and well
mistakes come in pairs and there we can
see Magnus well
he is known for his Safety First
approach when it comes to nurturing
those one positions just taking care of
the king and he's just a material up
like it's not long for this world yeah
even if material were level here white
would still be winning just because the
White's King has so much protection you
have Pawn shelter Black's King is I
didn't remember to get dressed that
morning uh no clothes around it and uh
black and get trigger happy here you can
start taking some pawns on the queen
side those white bee pawns are very weak
but as soon as the black queen loses her
centralization White's Rook uh will find
its way towards that black king and I
think David it's not about white having
the extra pawn it is that black king the
weakness of the king when you've got
these major pieces and it's very clear
to see that it's black skin that's going
to be under a lot of fire once The Rook
joins the body but not that easy because
now if you do a rook lift and the
BlackRock can come in with a check and
there are uh there are a couple of
checks to be given but the last move
Ivanka I think it hits on the it hints
at the king stepping up to G2 which
might be the safe square and we might be
seeing Simon's move Rook A3 next I
totally agree but Tanya I I have to hold
you up on one comment it's not all about
the extra Pawn it's always about the
extra material
doesn't hurt I mean it must be horrible
to be like playing playing magnets in a
position like this because okay you're
getting attacked and normally you'd be
like okay I'll get the Queens off yeah I
might be a pawn down the ending but you
know I'll have a way to grovel the draw
but you know if you're going to pawn
down the ending against magnet you're
just gonna lose so you can't even try to
get the Queen's off so you've got to try
some move like this to try and just
complicate things but now if white can
just get his rook in and there's a
couple of ways I feel he can do this
Rook C1 looks very simple to me
um it must be it must be coming to the
end right and just look how accurate
Magnus was you know giving a check
defunding the pawn on F2 with tampo and
now the Rook on A1 can get greedy as
Simon indicated okay greedy yeah Simon
was looking to slide it across I knew
eubanker would want to grab that yeah
now your two forms up always grabbing
the extra four yeah now I agree Ivanka
material really counts in this one
you've got these two extra pawns and
they're gonna roll down the Border some
point but we might still be seeing the
Checkmate happen first before the bonds
count in this one it's really not a
great option for black to trade he can't
give a check on E1 and then give a check
with the queen on e4 but Magnus might
just put the King on H2 and even
or does that run into queen h8 queen H1
there is a trap we should show right now
yeah Magnus avoided the Trap okay maybe
we'll show it a bit but uh okay Queens
are off he didn't bring his King to the
H file where it would have been checked
by The Black Queen on h8 and that would
have been disastrous a Checkmate David
definitely I love the way they've gone
straight into this ending now it's like
literally they're following the script
they're like okay yeah I'm gonna try to
grovel the drawer in the ending but
Magnus is not gonna draw this one Magnus
doesn't look uh too stressed out right
now looks pretty calm two connected plus
pawns are always better than uh one solo
Pawn running
it says magic when Magnus plays what
happened to that seven minute lead that
Fabi had he's not only down in the
position suddenly a big turnaround but
also just 30 seconds on the clock and I
agree I think uh the move of this game
has to be Knight B7 all the action is on
one side of the board and then suddenly
on the queen side you make this tactical
move not aimed at Checkmate but simply
trading Black's most important piece and
that seemed to be the decisive move of
the game
yeah Fabiano simply couldn't recover and
what Magnus is doing now is just really
uh kind of instructive he's just
stopping any potential counter play on
The Queen side uh the white king is able
to kind of Dart across if it needs to to
stop Black's pawns advancing and you
don't need to rush that's the key in
these types of end games whites f and g
pawns the two connected past pawns on
the king side will start moving forward
but only when Magnus is ready and uh
okay this B Pawn will be hunted but it's
only going to be a trade and this is
actually pretty much identical to an end
game they had in their world
championship tie breaks when Magnus
there also had two connected passports
running Fabiano had one solo Pawn but
Rook behind that pawn and uh now it's
just one-way traffic white we'll finally
have a free hand to stop pushing
yeah looks Badger yeah
easy is it to convert these
with these two extra bonds
if you're Magnus very easy yeah that's
that's the other thing right if you're
Simon not so easy
I think this one is quite easy because
the aim of the game is just move the
king and the king is the one that's
going to support the advance of those
pawns and the only thing that you have
to be very careful of is when the black
porn gets to B2 the white King has to
have some shelter yeah
and right now if the black pawn was to
get to a B2 white can come back with the
Rook to E2 and just make sure that black
stroke stays tight defending that pawn
uh could be a good moment to think about
start pushing the Jeep on or does he
need to be a little careful he decides
to First bring back The Rook once you
put the Rook behind the beep on yeah
yeah tying down the black Rook making
the black Rook passive here you similar
defense against Hikaru Nakamura didn't
you Gibraltar it was a different
position but where you defend the you
defend the port from the side I think I
was commentating on that one maybe with
Ivanka actually yeah was that right yeah
we were commenting yeah but uh it was in
those days the commentary abandoned for
dinner time but actually it was ready to
set up a master class so we were all
watching David play Hikaru at dinner
time and it ended in a draw David
what was the name of the defense
Lucy the Vancouver
for anyone interested at home check out
that game from the Gibraltar Masters
2000 and a long time ago uh yeah it's
the Vancouver position if you're
interested it's against the a or H pawns
and here it's a bit different Magnus is
simply making a new Queen it's over yeah
resigns uh and uh Magnus Carlsen takes
the lead in there best of four match
Fabi they're still checking perhaps what
went wrong what could have been done
differently he did go all out he did try
to create his chances but with Magnus
it's just never easy David for me it was
Knight B7 what was the big highlight for
you I can't disagree with you Tanya and
I don't think you'd ever forgive me so
let's jump in and show Knight B7 uh in
slow motion it was this moment it looks
really complicated and actually we were
mentioning that this white knight was
offside when the action is actually
taking place uh towards the king side
but it was jumping back Knight B7 now
towards the action hitting this Pawn
threatening a nasty Fork against the
queen and Rook that really clinched it
for Magnus Fabiano didn't react well
here actually he needed to embrace the
tactics and calculate extremely deeply
with a move like Bishop to D5 but this
is difficult for a human it looks like
it allows Knight takes porn instead of
allowing all of this Fabiano chose the
sub standard queen takes B7 but as we
saw in the game suddenly the black king
was open and after this move Bishop
takes H3 the final blunder already Under
Pressure Magnus clinched it by this
check Queen to B3 pushing the black king
in the corner and as we saw started
cleaning up Queen takes Pawn was the
beginning of the end
beautiful Precision there by the world
number one let's take a look at the
scoreline because this action was so
intense in this match we didn't get a
chance to look at the other game but it
did end peacefully uh between Wesley and
alireza Magnus takes the lead in his
match we will be back with a game two
action very soon don't go anywhere
foreign
[Music]
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things
and as the greats of the game battle it
out in the winner semi-final in the
Julius bear generation cup we visited
another great of the game a visciana
that is home in Chennai full disclosure
it was one of the best days of my life
and the five-time world champion shares
his thought on the golden generation of
Indian chess
it's a golden age of Indian chess and
it's all because of one man vishwanathan
Anand today we're outside the home of
Aruna and visionen to get a peek into
their life let's go
Hi how are you it's lovely to see you
thank you
[Music]
yeah this is the special room so let's
see who's there inside
is this the famous room where when India
has a new Grandmaster there's a
tradition that we've heard about he's
invited to your home is this where
it happens yes we obviously they're
allowed to sit there as well but
invariably they want to come in and have
a look and then I think there are
pictures of Prague coming
what are the conversations that happen
here with the young kids
usually we get very quickly many of them
are tongue-tied so we usually we get
very quickly to why don't you show me
your last game man then they open up a
lot
there is an X Factor there is something
unknown take our own golden generation
if you like
uh
I mean I selected them because it's
obvious they're ridiculously talented
some people just have an attitude for
just like Magnus his Ascent was so fast
how do you really explain it
I might sense that someone is very good
but still when it happens it usually
catches me of course when did I have
when when you know when did they become
this strong and on for first of
September for the first time in 37 years
UK shall be India number one he's a
student of the Westbridge honor chess
Academy how do you feel about that I
feel very proud and definitely you know
I was able to give gokish a lot of
suggestions a lot of advice I'm not
really his coach but interacted with him
a lot and things like that with Prague
as well I've interacted quite a bit
clearly they have their own
long-suffering parents they have their
coaches and things like that but we're
able to chip in so I feel very proud
it's also partially a relief how long do
you want to be waiting for this to
happen and that's the thing about being
semi-retired is that you're much more
detached of it personally
but it is still a shock that
to realize that something you expected
to happen eventually and you never
defined eventually in your mind
eventually means eventually
when it finally happens it's
you feel funny in your own skin let's
put it that way
you're not sure what's different and
something is different in the air
[Music]
this is arnon's first ever mention in a
newspaper
you were in those first Grandmaster
today India has 83 Grand Masters the
biggest talents are coming from the
country and for most of them if not all
You're the Inspiration what does it mean
to you the impact that your success has
had on Indian chess I feel quite proud
that um
let's say in just first up started up
here in the newspapers and in the media
because of my play and then there was
this long period throughout the 90s and
even the zeros where
I was competing with the world title
competing in the best tournaments and so
on and
just really started up here in the media
and and you felt this is going to
produce a result already you could see
that people are starting academies and
towns doing a lot of coaching children's
competitions running out of space in
Halls to play this sort of thing there
were some anecdotal stuff and then
slowly the number of Grandmasters
started to pick up anyway over time you
get the sense that you're having an
impact and uh
you realize that the sport has grown a
lot
but that's my world junior
I I 87. it's difficult to
tell you how many doors that opened for
me
what does the future look like for you
and how much more of competitive chest
you have left in you I figure when I
have had enough competition no
competitive chess I'll know and then
I'll take it then I don't imagine it
being too long I feel I'm in a very good
place now you get to a point in life
where all the things that once seemed
very Central you managed to put them in
their proper place and that's also very
relaxing
the other nice thing is
I feel like I can experiment with many
things now and there's no pressure on me
and I can just do this just because it's
nice to try yeah I can't complain I am
very happy most of the time I'm very
very happy
that was just amazing Wishing on and
five-time World Champion the winner of
five Oscars the winner of every single
Elite event uh that one can imagine and
he's inspired an entire generation of
chess player there's in India across the
world as well uh every name that you
take that's coming out of Indian chess
whether it's pragnananda
they all go to the Westbridge on and
chess Academy the impact he's had it's
just not enough uh anything that you say
about uh his impact on Indian chess who
was it for you David who paved the way
for you to become what you are today
such a strong Grandmaster
um oh tough one there's I had a lot of
Heroes I mean I worshiped Gary Kasparov
I guess in English chess circles as
Ivanka said Michael Adams was always the
one uh to kind of hold up he was world
number three world number four when I
was uh growing up uh played through a
lot of his games but yeah I mean I guess
everyone has their Heroes and it's just
not that he's had such effect I just
want to mention you've been to that room
now so does that mean you're India's
next Grandmaster it's so close already
so lucky David usually The Story Goes
that when India has a new Grandmaster
Ireland specially invites uh them over
to their home which is so special I feel
like that's an extra incentive and that
room while I was there it's Goosebumps
he's got these trophy cabinets all
around we're the biggest trophies that
you can imagine a beautiful chessboard
it is his training room it is where the
magic happens just being there I feel
like you gain 100 points yeah I can
imagine yeah and just that history right
and uh I mean he's a legend he's such a
living legend and he's inspired like the
whole of India right I mean this new
generation they all look up to him and
uh yeah his influence can't be
understated at all and it was so so nice
to see you so happy there you know you
were like oh my gosh it's like Santa
Santa Claus you know it's like yeah it
was the really special day and I just
kind of wanted to say that it's actually
remarkable that someone of his stature
and his strength and the whole legend
behind him has actually made himself
very accessible to India's young youth I
mean just think about it when when I was
growing up I didn't I didn't actually
talk I didn't get mentored by any of the
top players and I don't think David or
Simon were either so there was none of
that accessibility there was no talking
there was no sharing of ideas and to
have someone this big head of chest
doing exactly that Legend yeah
absolutely what a time to be in chess to
be a chess player when you can have and
interact and learn from the very best in
the world and that's why we're seeing
the new crop of generation new crop of
chess players all across under 20
shaking up the very best in the world
speaking of the very best in the world
he is on the screen Magnus Carlson ready
for his game two he's taken the lead in
his match Fabiano caruana it's not going
to be easy but he does start with the
white pieces how does he switch it up
where is his best shot
I think he needs to bank on opening
Theory again use some of his preparation
he's going to be armed to the teeth at
this point having just played the World
Cup the world uh rapid team championship
and okay he opens with the English C4 so
maybe a less theoretical battle ahead I
was going to say do what you did in the
first game Fabiano where you have kind
of got that seven eight minute time
advantage and then try and put the
pressure on with white but
um okay Magnus playing with a really
flexible first move and White's trying
to take the center I don't see Magnus
going to a Mainline King's Indian like
we saw farusha do a bit earlier on but
you never know with Magnus he can uh
surprise anyone at any time
yeah the one thing with all these
players nowadays which has really
changed probably going back to the days
of Anand and when Anand was uh was a
junior is that they they play so many
different openings right I mean these
guys they can go into a main line King's
Indian defense they can go to a
symmetrical English they they're much
more flexible modern players and I don't
know about Anand but I mean he had his
favorite openings when he was a junior
and he probably didn't play well he
didn't have the information available to
him to learn as many openings right
didn't have the internet didn't have
those possibilities uh to to learn
everything like they can nowadays so I
know um you can actually read about
Alan's life and he's very honest about
it in his book The mind master brilliant
and there he talks about
um he was living in Manila for a while
and how he kept saying he kept winning
all the pro all the book prizes and in
the end they were like okay just come
just come to our library and then you
can have open access to it there's
actually this amazing story from Manila
that Anand did share in that interview
but I'm not going to reveal it we are
going to uh probably hopefully bring
that up at some point but you're right
those years were super formative for him
when his family moved there Simon but to
your point one of the big things about
Ireland has been his longevity and his
ability to adapt to this changing time
it's not something that a lot of players
from his generation have been able to do
he's been in the world top 10 for so
many years with the magnus's generation
being at the peak as well and I think
that's been really special about his
career uh that uh you know being able to
adapt to these new opening ideas
learning and really learning chess
Concepts that have been challenged by
the younger generation yeah no 100 I
mean he did so well in the candidates a
very um what say very Advanced age that
sounds really harsh but an older age and
uh he yeah he has adapted I mean it's uh
is is and no one thought he was going to
do that either I don't think really you
know not many commentators but what
about is going on in the chess here I
mean I was looking at that I was
thinking has that been played before
when I was checking the database and I
was thinking no I mean it's Magnus has
played the North Sea hasn't he and is
this a version of North Sea David wow
there's a lot that's happened here and
we will jump back and David we'll break
this down for us but the other game has
started a much more sooner a much more
calmer better off on the board in this
one yep a Petrov or the Russian defense
sometimes uh as it's known Rock Solid I
don't really see Wesley employ this too
often uh so interesting that he's going
here rather than uh maybe the Berlin for
example but okay Farooq has chosen a
very ambitious variation
and uh yeah slightly asymmetrical Pawn
structure at least in the center for now
so yeah it's often like butting your
head against a brick wall trying to play
White against this opening
farouza at least he's found a way I'm
expecting him now to develop his Queen
side night Black's night in the center
just really strong there we go trying to
trade off uh still very well known
territory will Wesley play Fabiano's
move here a really mysterious move of
just moving the black queen down to D7
just down one square uh or maybe the
older moves of doing something with the
Black Knight still theoretical and this
one far less interesting than the other
at least in the opening stages
but uh yep early days Wesley at least
showing that he wants to just draw this
game stay Rock Solid and postpone the
inevitable tension
you started David we see a Petrov on the
board it's a theoretical battle I think
we're all thinking about the Magnus Fabi
game and uh
let's do it not enough butter rush back
because that was absolute madness out of
the opening David you've got to take
this from the top yeah I'll take it from
the top I just want to say though look
at the evaluation bar already on black
side look at the white king misplaced
the Queens are off the board but uh
definitely a bit of an opening disaster
I think for Fabiano uh let's jump in and
go from the top uh we left it very early
on where Magnus was playing a spin on
what we call the North Sea defense or
the Norwegian rat and I'm going to take
you all the way back to the start
position because Magnus is famous for
playing this opening looks like he's
going for the modern defense but instead
of feeling tattooing this bishop he
brings his Knight out and this has a
really bad reputation or at least a
dodgy reputation Magnus has had mixed
results here including losing to Michael
Adams at the 2010 Olympiad but the whole
idea is to bring the Black Knight to the
edge it looks like an Alicorn defense
you've kind of provoked white into
gaining space in the center though but
at the cost of time and Magnus has got
an improved version of this uh where
here white for example could start
attacking the Knight already instead
after C4 he did the same thing he
provoked the white Pawn to step forward
gaining space but uh White's pieces are
not backing up the pawns here and look
at what happened Fabiano instead of
going for the main move as I believe
Pawn takes Pawn when the position
becomes more rational he pushed forward
before porn attack or at least a spin on
that and now after this move he was
forced to trade Queens off the board and
suddenly if we catch up with the game
this is the current position I just
don't like why it's development here the
king stuck in the center what are these
pieces doing is fast asleep what are
these doing fast asleep black has three
pieces out in the game already not just
that he's about to get a fourth out with
a check he's about to Castle queenside
potentially with a check as well
I think it's a disaster and that's um
if you didn't know who was playing this
game and someone was showing it to you
yeah let's just say randly and you had
to guess the ELO of both players would
it be above 1500
yes or no is fine
the over to you first Ivanka oh to me
yeah you're stinging me there Simon
um bit harsh I I would not say it was
two of the world's elite players playing
this
especially not with white is that harsh
no maybe just true yeah I mean the thing
is though
there'll be people at home saying but
you know take a look at that pawn chain
that's very nice and uh oh
that pawn chain might be very nice but
of course one of the things of pushing
pawns forward is that they leave behind
weak squares and there's Magnus putting
the boot in because with that bishop
move he's threatening to move it to E4
and trap The Rook so that's not good
news I mean it's you know the pawns are
doing a great job though I mean our
pawns better than pieces though and the
the answer is not really pieces are
actually better and you know if you can
somehow maintain this position blacks
pieces on the right hand side will start
to look stupid the the dark Square
Bishop out of the game the Black Knight
is out of the game but it just seems
there's too many holes in White's
position here and Black's also going to
Castle Queen side bring a rook into the
game and there's a big threat on the
board with that last move you're talking
about lights where's Bishop E4 would
actually
a white Rook on H1 so development is key
I saw a feature chat there which said
that no one is immune from the Magnus
effect what is this Magnus effect David
simply he's in their heads uh you think
he's unbeatable you think he's gonna
outplay you in middle games and games
any type of position and you start doing
crazy things you start taking risks when
you don't really need to you start
miscalculating you start in your mind
maybe playing making negative negative
decisions playing for the draw and
they're kind of bending to his will
um I've been there myself and I've had
healthy positions against him suddenly
two moves later I'm like wait why am I
playing for the draw why am I kind of
allowing him to bully me into his type
of positions and it's hard to It's A
Hard mindset to get out of and it feels
like yeah the first game the first
result has affected Fabi here but uh
yeah tilt adding to that as well adding
to the Magnus effect that's a really
interesting point about not letting
Magnus get into your head and a lot of
players Ivanka struggle with that do you
think the younger generation is better
at dealing with that yeah absolutely I
mean we've seen a lot of the young
Indian kids take off points from Magnus
you know practice good cash did it
did it so I mean we do see them not
struggle with that so much but I still
think that Magnus has a big effect
because a lot of people are very
satisfied with a draw against them and
so they won't necessarily choose the
most aggressive openings if he plays
provocatively they won't necessarily
choose everything that's Cutting Edge
because after all they're happy with the
draw and that leads to a lot of negative
decisions and they're on the board we
can see that Magnus has castled to the
left and uh poor fabi's King
and like had to get out of it I mean a
black knight jumping into the middle
looks very very uh a typical movie I
mean I think White's only hope is if he
can defend against the immediate threats
and get developed he will actually have
a better position because Black's piece
on the right hand side could be bad but
there's a lot of ifs and butts there
he's gotta defend against the blacks
pieces which are which are flooding in
and um
I don't know is there any I mean Knight
D4 looks so tempting doesn't it just
just put the Knight into the middle of
the board here but uh other things you
can do you can try to
um open up the uh the the pawns that are
blocking the middle of the board so you
can think about playing G5 or F6 F6
looks looks like a good move here as
well right uh just to try to open up
some more lines and get rid of those
annoying pawns that white has uh you
want to open up the position when your
king is safer even when the Queens are
off the board every other piece remains
on the board so let's just get some more
lines
um you know the other Rook can then come
into the middle and uh that that would
mean every single black piece is is
partying quite hardcore and White's King
here
so this looks nice yeah this just it's
violent at this point Knight to D4 has
landed and uh that forces uh the White
Knight to deal with the threat of
jumping in with a nasty night Fork
Knight to A3 yeah Simon I think you'll
move fits uh about time there we go
Magnus does player F6 but white is only
one one move away from Castle and queen
side
and then it'd be okay maybe probably not
even there it'll be okay but let's
remind the viewers that's not legal it
is a joke white has already moved the
king so you cannot Castle anymore this
king is destined to stay stranded in no
man's land forever he's one game away
from yeah next game maybe
but I like this F6 so Magnus has got all
the pieces into the party into play
place them beautifully and then decides
to break to try and get that one Rook on
h8 on the open e-file that is uh coming
up and fabi's still struggling with
development it must be it's also really
frustrating playing with white and sort
of ending up in this position in on move
12.
yeah yeah it hasn't hasn't gone well
Magnus has played very provocatively and
it is Magnus who has the opening
advantage and that we did see the reason
why white can't capture the pawn on F6
and Fabi well he's trying to exchange of
pieces but this is going to come at the
cost of a pawn did you see it Magnus was
laughing as well he was laughing then he
kind of hit his head he was rubbing his
hair now he's trying to block his
laughter as well I don't know what's
happened
she's been enjoying his uh I mean
enjoying his position understandably but
okay now back to Poker Face
not sure if I was imagining it but I
don't think I was uh definitely
something well maybe he's waiting for
fabulous Castle now because he's got
Checkmate in one move then Knight E2
Checkmate so uh oh you mean queen side
Castle in 92. you sort of seeing some
weird things on the board but
um I mean if happy if happy can get out
of this it he's he's got some chances
and he's now got all of his pieces
developed I mean uh is it is it that bad
no and there is one trick uh Fabiano is
banking uh his hopes on one tactic here
uh he's offering a trade of knights yeah
would release the tension would lower
the pressure if these Knights come off
the board and now I guess he's hoping
that uh a pawn move such as G4 might
work probably doesn't even work yeah now
that I see it now that I see it Knight
takes porn and if I take your Bishop
Knight
check I'm with my king take on D2
yeah this is what uh I guess is both
players are calculating right now is uh
what Fabiano's banking his hopes on but
as you say Tanya at the very least you
go for a variation such as this one
maybe the fact that the Knight is
trapped saves me here because I can take
this Pawn but if for example I were to
take this Knight then a position such as
this would be hopeless uh black with two
well with a rook and three pawns for two
minor Pieces Just Simply winning Magnus
doesn't go for any of this uh long
calculation though however
um his trademark these days to avoid
calculation uh especially against these
younger players but uh even against
someone like Fabi Bishop to E4 now this
time and he's trying to pin lots of
targets on this diagonal
looks very strong as well
yeah I mean can Fabi now start
exchanging pieces this is the the one I
think it has to doesn't he I mean he's
got so but how to do it
yeah Knight takes his Knight takes D4
losing is it and then the bishop takes
bishop and then move the rookie one was
here maybe at the very least black just
moves the bishop out the way and I mean
it's still terrible but uh
Rook F1 when you have to make a move
like Rook F1 on the board you know that
things have gone wrong already and this
is a pawn sacrifice we shouldn't forget
uh at the very least now Magnus can just
trade off everything on this square and
capture a pawn this cannot be recaptured
because the uh F4 is pinned or it's
Bishop would fall
maybe Magnus has something even better
than this but this is the very minimum
right now
and uh Fabiano just Clinging On for
survival uh with his fingernails right
now
ugly position it really feels like there
should be something more in the position
than capturing the E5 Pawn he retains
the Knight on the board on D4 uh White
Skin's still in the center you can't uh
pick up the pawn on E5 because of the
tactic that David mentioned and the
Knight comes in with the check on F3 I
kind of like that David you keep the
knights on the board and if white is
forced to grab the H5 Knight then you're
kind of happy to trade the H5 Knight
instead of the D4 Knight yeah really
nice uh
well lack of any bias there by Magnus
I'm always this is my I think my biggest
weakness I always want to preserve my
Bishops but here he's saying okay that
black knight is better than any of
White's minor pieces and yeah you're
right Tanya just this move looks like it
might clinch it for Magnus
Fabiano if he could some somehow Castle
I'm just drawn to uh getting that white
king to safety White's rook in the
corner without being able to Castle as
well takes an age to ever activate
yeah this one porn down and with a
difficult position not looking good for
Fabiano
and the Knight on A3
is out of the game
and uh sometimes I've even played
openings that have been based on one bad
piece like a knight on A3 or a Black
Knight on A6
um yeah it has not gone well for Fabi
it's hard to suggest a move for white
here Simon does anything what comes to
your mind how can Fabi try to at least
keep the game going right now
yeah it's very tough I mean uh
I mean I I just want to try to get some
coordination and and White's position is
completely lacking coordination here the
king gets in the way of the Rooks uh
Ivanka pointed out the bad Knight even
the Bishops you know you've got the
bishop pair but they're actually just
targets so I I mean I'd maybe think
about checking uh just to try to gain
gain a move and then I'd be looking at
moving the other Bishop I want to get
rid of that Knight but yeah I'm
struggling to find a an easy way through
through this position here definitely
yeah I mean some something where I can
exchange off but this does drop another
Pawn I mean I think if I do this you
know and two pawns there's gonna be too
many here black can just uh well maybe
maybe some other good moves as well but
I don't know I'm struggling to find
something here like uh in the position
like one thing that I was also drawn to
I was thinking about Bishop takes Knight
and uh at least you'd have some double
pawns and then maybe moving a rook
towards the game but I don't know E4
also looks really strong I'm just
cementing a knight onto the F3 square
but that's not even necessary you can
just go porn taste pool yeah at the very
least you trade off a set of Pawns I
guess and I think we're headed in this
direction Ivanka nice prediction game on
point there this has indeed happened
this is the game position and Magnus has
a very pleasant decision uh he can push
forward uh cementing the Knight on a
nice outpost on F3 with a check next
move or you can just trade off after
Rook to D1 and simplify the position
better minor piece as well this Knight
better than white snipe and Europa pawn
and with the safer King
everything adds up here he plays Rook to
f8 instead just keeping the tension
no rush
if white was to take the central Bond
and the Knight jumps in with the check
so you can't even really take on E5 so
really keeping the tension and adding
the pressure on the F4 Pawn things are
looking very tough for Fabiano caruana
in this one he's on the defense uh let's
take this moment to jump into our other
game alireza ferruja against Wesley so
the first game ended in a draw and this
looks like a fun position what's going
on so peace has been captured on H4 yeah
a White Knight has just been captured uh
on H4 and now ferrugia is debating
whether to recapture with the White
Queen or with the white dot squared
Bishop some tactics and calculation to
do there just in case black can grab
White's uh Pawn in the center white E5
Pawn either very strong or maybe a
weakness
yeah this is by far kind of the least
boring petroff I've seen in a long time
uh often this opening Fizzles out very
quickly but of course farouja whenever
he's involved very aggressive play for
ambitious play uh Instinct wise who do
we prefer here evaluation bar doesn't
give us any clues really
it's back with the bishop
I do like the bishop uh
yeah I always like having this Pawn on
E5 as well in such positions because it
can be a real real problem for black and
um white has quite a big threat here I
think using the other Bishop to harass
the queen so if it was White's movie
Bishop G4 attacking the queen looks like
a really really strong move when uh the
the e-pawn is is flexible and can start
forcing its way forward so
um I definitely prefer white here I mean
can you take the pawn uh that that is
the big question because if black can
take the pawn maybe get the Queens off
the board then things things will be all
right so um can he do that but uh
through
you are going to see that the safe
I've got Brook CA I was hoping but do I
have Rook C8 I don't know
this is what I was trying to because I
don't wanna I don't want to lose the C5
Pawn you're right that'd be horrendous
and you know if I I mean this this seems
better than it was
uh for uh
for black I say that quite slowly
because uh I'm still
actually because uh Queen takes porn has
been played yeah
it makes sense because uh that you know
I think getting the Queen's off
generally helps Black's position here
because uh keeping the Queens on that
Queen was very exposed to attack
let's see let's see what a move is I
mean there's other possibilities you can
go Bishop takes poor now
um but that doesn't look very inspiring
I mean this this doesn't look scary at
all for black this kind of this kind of
position we could get opposite color
Bishops equal material I don't think
black would have much to fear here
yeah this looks like the safety kind of
uh bailout option now for farooja if you
want to draw he'll just take this Pawn
restore the material balance attacking
this Knight in the center and uh the
game will fizzle out opposite color
Bishops we've seen it twice already
today especially uh between Amin and uh
lazovic but yeah this is very different
this is just very very balanced but if
he wants to play ambitiously for the win
Bishop to E7 looks likely uh maybe also
this move just to kind of attack this
other port in the center it's these two
pawns these weak pawns that give white
compensation uh for the gamuted porn
earlier so still in the balance this one
but uh I like the bishop here as well if
ferrugia can do something active
energetic in the next few turns
bigger had to go upon hunting uh in that
position and he's done it so playing
very direct here and now for our liresa
definitely the bishop bear has enough
compensation I think it's fair to say
that it's a balanced position like
having the extra Pawn White having
enough compensation we might even see
him re-grabbing the pawn really quickly
and um settling down the material
imbalance but should we rush over to the
other one because I see the eval bar and
there's a lot of action there it looks
like Magnus has managed to get an even
bigger Advantage from his lead in
development wow David A lot has happened
and lots of pieces are hanging yeah
suddenly white does have some threats at
least some hope of counter play Black's
night in the center that glorious
beautiful night is under Fire Magna is
still one Pawn up but I'm seeing moves
like the black Bishop jumping into E3
attacking White's Rook defending black
snide at the same time I'm also seeing
the clock where Magnus has a huge
Advantage it's growner there at least
but yeah Fabi fighting well impressive
even got to this point do you know the
problem these positions is you're
playing Magnus
and like you know you survive the attack
you try to get an ending and you're a
pawn down and then you lose the ending I
think I might have said that once
already today but um it's it is material
advantage and the initiative still for
black so it's tough but Fabi fighting as
hard as he can from uh probably dubious
dupious opening that he got
gotta find a way to get out of this I
mean a two-point deficit would be
absolute disaster you don't come back
from a two-point deficit against uh
Magnus fabi's already lost the first
game and as you pointed out the bishop
jumps in attacking The Rook defending
the knight uh Magnus going aggressive
with the Rook he's still got that extra
Pawn
is the ending wow it's a repeat repeat
of the first game I think not just for
an extra one soon
yeah I mean it is only one pawn it was
only one Pawn last time but it says it's
just one Pawn
this is different at least it's not a
rook end game where Magnus knows exactly
what to do he hasn't done this a
thousand times before like he had in the
previous game
uh at least here with reduced material
there's some hope if you can trade off
as many pawns as possible
um
yeah it's not going to be easy I'm
expecting him to try and activate the
white King right now there we go putting
the pressure on the black Bishop but
this does allow Magnus to trade off the
Bishops
and then we get a knight and pawn ending
and you know what they say about night
important endings they're basically the
same as a poor King and pawn endings
every single factor that is a huge
consideration there it's the same night
in games so when you have an extra Pawn
a King Pawn ending is winning and the
second best hand game that you can get
is with just a pure Knight and yeah on
end game so Bishop D4 is the movie
that's what I'm talking about
looks logical white does have a threat
of pushing the g-pawn forward kicking
the Black Knight which holds the black
Bishop so you pretty much have to move
your Bishop right now and not too many
other logical squares you can go back in
two different directions but I'm on team
Ivanka here and trade those Bishops
very nice better night more pawns there
we go quick call Ivanka and uh up on the
clock as well Magnus with an extra pawn
and that 17th piece that we keep talking
about uh Fabiano Carana down to two and
a half minutes and a very difficult
night Pawn ending to hold uh David you
step back with the Knight now give a
check on F5 because Black's got to find
a way to get the king into the game now
yeah the one downside for black is that
you maybe don't have too much time to
stabilize the night White's King is more
active than the black king
um I mean the other thing is that you've
survived this far so you'll be pretty
happy uh if you're Fabiano this is the
best position he's had since move five I
think uh as white uh some momentum
has slightly changed uh but yeah it's
I'm expecting a check because you say uh
Tanya maybe the Black Knight can go back
to the E6 C6 as well you can back up
this Knight with a pawn potentially but
some calculation there
yeah you would be thinking about C5 as
well because Knight on D4 is a nice
piece that is uh true that was my first
consideration because I like to push
pawns but yeah I know as David was
saying there is some calculation needed
because the white king can get very
active can snake its way to the left
side of the board
I like C5 because um at the moment the
Black Knight is stopping the white
knight from coming back into play
um so if you move the Black Knight The
White Knight has an easier route back
into the game so I think you know C5
seems quite logical
because then white has to go Knight B1
it's the only way to get that Knight
around again so I don't know there's
probably many many options here but it
you know maybe
maybe white is like you said David he's
going to be a bit happier Fabby because
he's got his King active and that will
give him some hope here is it time for
some predictions do we think Fabiano is
going to hold this game it would be a
miracle if he does I can't see him
holding this I mean against Magnus I
mean it's uh you know it's it's possible
but I'm very unlikely
she's coming back to that whole point
right that it's against Magnus uh any uh
any of the other best players in the
world and we'd say that Fabi has a shot
at this and that's the unique thing
about Magnus and again probably the
Legacy that he leave behind will be his
ability to get into his opponent's mind
uh just uh incredible stuff so he does
fall back with the Knight to C3 at least
fabi's managed to centralize his Knight
it is looking better and have we written
this off too soon uh yvanka does Fabi
have a reasonable chance here
and he has chances I I wouldn't
necessarily go as far as say that
reasonable because like you say Magnus
press and game player in the world
yesterday I remember him winning a game
against our men in a night in one end
game very instructive and uh he knows
what to do he knows it's all about
mobilizing the pieces
what can you do but uh Fabi this is the
best position he's had and he just has
to take it on a move by move basis and
just players
I don't know just move his pieces as
forward as as possible we played guess
the eagle earlier if you had to predict
accuracy the accuracy that Magnus has
had in this game I'd love to see what it
is because it almost feels like a
Flawless game by black what do you think
it would be about 90 a pretty high like
97 96 yeah you know I mean talking about
accuracy I was looking through magnus's
games yesterday and you know that last
game that he played
it had
um I think he'd only made one inaccuracy
and the rest of it Flawless wow
not bad pretty decent chess player
Knight B5 on the board a Fabi does
create a threat David yeah and Magnus
did Grimace slightly on the camera I
don't think he kind of uh saw this one
or at least he underestimated it because
if the black king is forced back to
defend this uh support on C7 that the
White Knight is attacking then at least
white would gain some time to go active
himself and Magnus is going for a race
uh we do know that H pawns and a pawns
those Corner pawns The Rook pawns there
uh they are what night struggle against
the most and Magnus he's trying to
create a past Pawn for himself there uh
forced the white king passive now and
he's getting active with his own Knight
really instructive we talked about it
earlier today not materialistic at all
Magnus is giving away all of his kind of
uh material advantage here level pawns
but suddenly the black king is superior
to the white king the Black Knight
superior to the White Knight and uh some
serious threats grind it like a grind
Master
this wasn't obvious but classy stuff
again the golden Dutch in end games by
Magnus Carlson he so quickly went into
this line of a four-piece activity just
giving up that c pawn and uh Ivanka you
were on point we're getting an update
the accuracy 94.8 percent by Magnus
Carlson in this one disappointing you
should never doubt my guesses
it's just incredible stuff so David he
does give up the C7 Pawn but he captures
the A2 Pawn so once again uh up material
but he might be losing another Pawn he
might be but it's all about those a h
pawns Magnus is obsessed with them in
night end games not just did he beat a
mean yesterday using the uh those
running pawns but also if we have if we
flash back to the previous Champions
chess Tour event he defeated Jordan van
forest in two consecutive night end
games there so Magnus his track record
is good and look at this he doesn't even
care about the black e-pawn it's he's
got bigger fish to fry here A5 he's
getting ready to run with that one white
B3 point is next a target for the Black
Knight I think it was Judith pogaro um
the top female player of all time he
said about Magnus who said uh
um the one thing of Magnus is his
Knights he he uses his Knights so well
and she said uh she recommended that
anyone who plays Magnus tries to remove
his Knights as quickly as possible try
to exchange magnus's Knights off and uh
you see it time and time again uh when
he is using the knights which are the
trickiest pieces to to work out how to
maneuver because they can go they can go
all over the shop and uh he's incredible
how he how he weaves them around the
board and that was that that was I
thought a really nice observation
because a lot of a lot of people say
it's magnus's endings they're quite
generalize his skills but the knights
get rid of his Knights that's what
you've got to do if you're playing
Magnus
um do you think he knows how the horsey
moves
he's got a good idea yeah
yeah no it feels like Magnus has uh
brushed up on his night end games
and where where do you strike right you
talk about night end games being the
best when it comes to Queen and games
knowing what the queen below is so
difficult to find
checkmates even Magnus
will will lose the game if you Checkmate
him it's a tough Journey up there but
yeah if you manage it it could be done
but right now it is magnus's King that
has marched on the board so Fabi didn't
go for that pawn on E7 he needs the
Knight to keep things guarded but Knight
C1 is coming in you still lose the B3
Bond still Fabius defending Knight D2
but as again it's a question of timing
you see that the Knight on D2 is
completely tied down and why it spawns
they don't move they don't they can't do
anything and all Fabi can do is just
Shuffle the king from the G2 Square to
the F2 square and now it's going to be
operation
porn time it's going to be operation
epon time yeah like there you go H5
maybe B6 if you want interesting you
know enjoy yourself yeah he's oh he's
six so E5 E4 because you want to give up
that E Pawn and grab the beep on E6 is
the move the sadistic way doing it so
just take your time moving in one square
at a time it's just crazy no matter what
position you give him what middle game
end game always his opponents seem to
barely be able to move uh Magnus he just
completely paralyzes them and whites
Knight tied down defending the B Pawn
the king tied down and eventually one of
them is deflected at the cost of Black's
E Pawn but now it is one of those Corner
pawns at the h-born and Harry gonna
become Queen Harriet soon Simon yeah and
you can even go Knight takes B3 probably
and get use the other one I love the way
you call it trousers legs the other day
I thought that was cool so is he gonna
go Knight takes B3 yeah I think he will
reborn pick it up oh he is I thought
it's not even sacrificing and uh yeah
the trousers legs are are coming down
right I mean uh for her assignment oh I
mean it was a good move and um on the
board the problem with knights is you
can only defend against these pawns from
one side and you can't jump off the
board
yeah it's game over Fabiano caruana
resigned and with that Magnus with a 2-0
lead he did make this one look easy
Ivanka this was brutal yeah it was
brutal I mean it was just a poor opening
Choice from Fabi he tried to punish
magnus's unconventional choice but in
the end Magnus just showing his class it
feels like it was perfect play from
Magnus Carlson with the form that he is
in David is it impossible to beat Magnus
right now I'm glad I'm not playing in
the tournament
um I'm glad I'm not Fabiana right now
it's going to be an uphill struggle but
uh Fabiano at least he will have another
life even if he can't fight back in that
next game but first of all it's this one
high stakes and it does look like some
chances for furusia it's again theme of
the day Rooks and opposite color Bishops
white however is a pawn up and uh can he
utilize that
Black's Bishop very passive the black
king stuck on the back rank it feels
like it should be great for white but uh
always this Dynamic of opposite color
Bishops adds this drawish factor and
okay repeating the position
no he's got to try no he's got an extra
Pawn he has to play on but look at the
clock he's down at just over 10 seconds
for Roger will he take a dry hair with a
check
surely he'll play for the win there we
go side steps with his king and the
black Rook needs to start attacking some
of the white pawns you can barely move
your bishop or King as black
fighting with the lone Rook
going for the win at some point you've
got to start pushing that extra Pawn on
the queen side it feels like the way to
make progress now
but you you can take your time with it I
mean I would first suggest like
maximizing the bishop on F2 move it to a
better square and try to force the king
from F7 to the G8 Square because it's
not very good there
yeah I mean that's the great thing with
these type of endings you can just play
a lot of empty Moves In order to build
up time on your clock
is to build some time Wesley because I
think if it gets down to level time on
the clock uh it's only going to be for
Asia who can win
okay he's at least slightly activated as
Bishop the King has to now defend this
piece
still tough to break through for weight
at some point as Tanya says just you
have to push the C Pawn forward I've
been now
the board always watch out for a G5 move
at the right time you try to win the G7
Pawn by giving the G4 pawn and then
you'll have another parcel on the right
side of the board the F5 Pawn so just
putting the bishop on a very active
Square I think the clock super important
he's down to eight seconds will it be
enough while he Reza with the extra Pawn
position really really convincingly in
the past
that's that's
oh that must be a
that must be a draw offer really we're
not a draw for but I mean it's going to
be a draw now Wesley's probably the
toughest player to beat uh you know in
the world I mean you could say Magnus
but uh Magnus sometimes takes takes some
risks and when Wesley's on four I mean
he's so hard to beat yeah and Wesley
there just completely showing everyone
how it's done he eliminates that
dangerous Pawn on F5 and there you go
is gonna be a draw yeah wow I'm not
gonna lie I was quite surprised with
that quick Rook trade I thought that
alireza had a chance had an opportunity
to at least go on in a position where
he's completely safe but with that Rook
trade uh all troubles were over for
Wesley so and the second game ends in a
draw as well two big fights two big
battles Magnus Carlsen Green Supreme in
his uh game two against Fabi David what
was the big moment for me it was the end
game technique there when only Knights
and pawns remained on the board from
Magnus Carlson we saw a catastrophic
opening from Fabiano caruana he fought
well and he reached this position maybe
thinking he had some drawing chances by
hitting this Pawn but Magnus realized
that end game activity is key and he
just gave that pawn in order to race
forward with the King also recognizing
that this potential Queen is going to
start running through Knights so bad at
stopping these Corner points because
they can only block from one side of the
board and as we saw it forced the white
king passive and now the Black Knight
jumped in and it was the other Pawn the
apron that started deflecting the two
white pieces Knight to C1 Knight to B3
threatened and as we saw later on it was
indeed this H Pawn that ran through to
Victory becoming a queen to end the game
yet again another endgame Master Class
by world number one Magnus Carlsen and
he takes a two-point lead against
Fabiano caruana which means Fabi has to
win the next game to keep the match
going to take it to the fourth round
Magnus needs just a draw to wrap things
up meanwhile the other big matchup of
the winner semi-final still a very
peaceful with two draws in that one and
as the players battle it out are
fighting it out in the Julius bear
generation cup the winner will get a
really cool Trophy and you can get
this exact same trophy there will be a
fan Edition you can bid for it right now
at chess champs.io not only do you get
the exclusive trophy but also VIP
tickets for the 2023 tour finals in
Toronto which will be played in person
by the eight qualifiers in Canada this
December submit your bids at
chesschamps.io4 the chance to win that
Trophy and the Fight Continues it is a
big ask for Fabiano caruana he is down
two points can he do it can he win the
next game against Magnus Carlson we will
be back with game three in just a few
moments
[Music]
foreign
did you teach uh certain positions or
openings or middle games or what what
did that you're what did your training
uh people look like I'll give you one of
the secrets here so a good a good coach
will correct your moves
but a great coach will correct your
thinking
and um all right hold on hold on I want
to repeat that again for the people in
the back you just repeat that again so a
good coach will correct your moves
and a great coach will correct your
thinking so really part of the magic of
coaching is holding a mirror up to a
child's so they can see their own
thinking
and sometimes you made the move because
you were overconfidence uh you were
dismissive of your opponent and so these
whether they were this kind of self
knowledge this self-awareness is part of
the cognitive process and it helps to
accelerate the alerting curve as as
players
um and so meaning games in that loss
because you didn't know that Roy Lopez
you know the 14th move of the Roy Lopez
or because you couldn't execute a rook
and upon that end game yes of course
these are these are technical things
that you need to win chess games but
games are also lost because of lack of
self-knowledge so
um
the issue of spasticity losing super
Trojan uh you know and I tell the story
many times waspassky lost the world
championships have chosen in
1966. spasticity goes back to baffinic
and he says you know why did why did I
lose now uh people many people may not
know but spaski was an incredibly
talented chess player right in many ways
he's considered one of the first
Universal chess player he can attack
like Tao and he can defend like the
Trojan but he loses this match and
Buffet told him uh the great talented
Boris basket uh did you study betrozan
right so meaning it wasn't he didn't
think it was important to study the
opponent the famous line from Sun Tzu
know your enemy know yourself and the
Thousand battles you you will never lose
uh heathus thought it was about about
Sebastian and so he had to take the time
and recognize that he needed to
understand petrosion beating you means I
must understand you chess is a
conversation is a it's a dialogue
between the two chess players so by 1969
he knew what to expect at the chess
board he has he has studied uh betrozan
and he eventually becomes uh the 10th uh
world champion
foreign
[Music]
thank you
500 carwana famously had a 7 out of
seven start at the 2014 sink Full Cup he
also challenged Magnus Carlson for the
2018 World Chess Championship title how
does a player get there you might ask
for five out of carwana it is feared
opening preparation he is a theoretician
like no other in his 2016 game from the
London chess classic Fabiano Carr wanted
them trade how deep his opening
preparation can go with the white piece
against Hikaru Nakamura Hikaru
sacrifices a knight temporarily with
Knight takes G4 after Fabiano takes this
Knight on G4 with his Bishop hikara
looks to win back the piece with E5
hitting the queen and the Knight with
his Pawn but Fabiano caruana was a man
on a mission he says you're not going to
get your piece back I'm going to
sacrifice my queen on F6 and after the
bishop took the queen he puts his Knight
on D5 the queen slides back because
under attack as the bishop of d8 and he
plays Knight F5 getting two pieces for
the queen but with a dominant positional
Advantage he went out to win this nice
game and just a great demonstration of
his excellent and deep opening
preparation
[Music]
2014 the singfield cup 2018 The Big Year
in Fabiano Carolina's life where you
were just two rating points away from
Magnus Carlsen and then now he is back
in form with a fantastic performance
over the last year he is the reigning
U.S Champion uh did play the world
championship match in 2018 which went
down to the tie breaks it was a level
match in the classical and he has the
third highest rating in classical chess
history the 2844 marker and David I
remember the time when Fabi was so close
to overtaking Magnus yeah they've been a
few times uh 2014 he was on the rise of
course 2018 when they had that world
championship match just one win for
Fabiano would have seen him LeapFrog
Magnus and I think that just added to
the stakes both were so nervous so much
to play for and it did come down to the
rapid Magnus clinched it there and seems
to be doing the same again today
yeah he came so close and I I mean we
mentioned it earlier but it feels like
maybe Fabiano thinks okay I've got
another chance now that Magnus is not
running I've been facing Magna so many
times in my career and it's pretty
frustrating because he's so good but now
Magnus is outside the picture okay I'm
better than everyone else I I can become
world champion and uh I think that seems
to invigorate invigorated him again with
his uh very recent good performances and
uh you know he's he's getting on a bit
now as well you know all the youngsters
coming through it's sad to say but he is
getting older so uh do you say that
chess players they kind of to get their
peak in their 30s so maybe Fabi will be
thinking about that and I also must
mention that in their last classical
encounter in Norway chess I think is the
last classical encounter uh it was Fabby
with the white pieces that won
um having said all that what face is
Fabby right now is black pieces against
Magnus Carlson now unfortunately for
Fabi Magnus does know how to lock the
game down and to simplify the position
so and get a secured get a good draw but
we'll see yeah it's going to be a tough
one while Fabi did come close to
overtaking Magnus today in this matchup
he hasn't come close in any of the games
uh Magnus Carlsen doesley with two
points sabi's got black he's got to win
in the next game uh it's gonna be a
tough one Simon as you mentioned renewed
ambition for Fabi around the world
championship match and he's made it to
the candidates already and David you
were mentioning earlier that there was a
very interesting Insight from Fabi about
his generation of players that's right
just a few days ago Fabiano gave an
interview he said that his generation
he's including Magnus the 1990
generation I think up to maybe 92-93
born strongest of all time and I want
you you guys to give your take on that
and maybe the audience as well the
viewers because I agree I'm part of the
same generation not that I'm part of
that conversation but uh I guess uh
there's also the
kramnik of Andrew gelfand era uh
I think it's I think it's just different
right I mean I I mean incredibly strong
generation don't get me wrong but things
have changed so much the way that people
are learning the game the quality of
Chess is much higher but it's so much
imagine giving like Fisher chess base
you can imagine how strong fish it would
have been if he had all the resources
that we have now but maybe it is the
strongest generation if you're just
taking the playing strength so far so
far yeah with this new craft of
youngsters coming up uh Prague not about
Winston camera
who knows and what Legacy these they
might leave behind but right now it is
this generation that's at its peak
Magnus Carlton with the white pieces
needs only a draw to wrap up this match
Sabi probably right now just thinking
about how can he even get a game going
yeah you would have thought Fabiano in
the 10 minute break there would have
been uh coming up with a strategy
devising an opening plan but after one
E4 he already spent 20 seconds and place
the Sicilian and your favorite my
favorite
didn't Magnus use this weapon yes in the
World Cup in the world cup to secure a
draw yeah he did and and the clinching
game against Prague the final game there
and he played the C3 Sicilian he
actually used A variation that I was
playing when I was six years old Magnus
uh not that I gave him the idea he came
up with that himself but he used that to
lock it down against uh Prague and
ensure that a draw was sufficient and
yeah I used it myself at the World Cup
when I just needed a draw in one of the
playoffs and it can be annoying for
black here to create winning chances but
Prague early in the event did beat
arigaisy as black in a must-win
situation in the C3 Sicilian so there is
some hope certain variations you can
keep pieces on the board but often you
have to take big big risks with black to
beat this one
uh Simon what do you will see here is
this something Fabiano will be happy
to face
um I mean it doesn't look very happy at
the moment you know being a body
language expert
um but I there is a line here there yeah
where you go C4 and this is this is one
of the more murky lines isn't it I mean
I don't know if G5 is is that a line at
some point I can't remember you you must
know this better than me but this this
seems a bit unbalanced at least you know
there's uh pieces on the board and a
weird Pawn structure a bit yeah um I
guess those aggressive G5 lines you
mentioned just with the Black Knight
already on C6 maybe rather than having a
Pawn on E6 here black is insufficiently
developed in order uh to kind of get
away with Pawn pushes but yeah Fabiano
he's at least kind of trying to switch
up the structure it's not the usual uh
alapin or C3 Sicilian as this opening is
called it's not that type of usual uh
ideas and uh Magnus yeah he isn't a
habitual player uh kind of utilizer of
this opening so at least taking him out
of theory out of any forcing lines uh is
the first step for Fabiano then you get
the middle game you might have a small
disadvantage as black but as long as you
keep pieces alive Pawn structure
slightly imbalanced maybe later on you
get some chances it's step by step in
these must win situations you can't just
kind of go all out as black attack
attack attack and win uh unfortunately
you just have to survive and kind of
postpone the tension until later
and while Magnus has had two decisive
games the other matchup we've had two
very peaceful draws between Wesley so
and alireza fuja and their third game is
about to start as the players are
getting ready there and uh would it be
fair to say that alireza hasn't managed
to get his kind of positions in the
match so far those chaotic messy
structures
they've been interesting fighting draws
and definitely not the chaos that
alireza excels in and while the players
are repeating
Indian is Wesley going to push forward
with that deep Pawn anytime soon
okay he chooses a slightly different
approach instead of castling like he did
in the previous game Bishop to E3 is
more flexible keeps the options open of
white king actually going the other way
and this does maybe deter from going for
his usual setup the one he employed in
the previous game and this bishop move
does invite some kind of forcing lines
some complications here
uh which one will ferricia go for again
it doesn't seem like uh Wesley's too
bothered here about necessarily winning
the opening battle but uh he's at least
asking questions of version
in this type of well King's Indian is
always complicated right and this type
of counter-attacking scenario
and future has been this sort of a
mysterious player in the last couple of
years right he's the youngest player to
ever break into 2800 uh Magnus famously
said that he'd be willing to play the
world championship matches it was
against the biggest talent of uh of
modern chess but then he's also kind of
not been seen in so many events he
wasn't there at the World Cup he's been
talking about a career and pretty
serious about a career in fashion as
well we see him sort of play when he
feels like there's all of this mystery
surrounding alireza will he play will he
continue playing and yet he is amongst
the very best in the world what do you
make of that Ivanka uh of alireza's
future and his commitment to be the best
player in the world
yeah it's a different approach I really
admire the fact that he's like well you
know what I'm not just gonna focus on
chess I'm also going to diversify and
try to develop an interest or career in
fashion design and in the meantime
I do see that uh well we you wanted
chaos and I feel that with uh Wesley is
born Advanced to D4 D5 we are going to
get chaos soon
the forcing line that you were talking
about David yeah one of many forcing
lines uh is about to happen on the board
um yeah he's still I mean he looks happy
for Asia we saw him in Norway Chelsea of
anchor
um we've seen him around the scene he
just looks very happy relaxed and maybe
not kind of all out focused on playing
constantly like some of the uh some of
his peers this Young Generation but I
mean when he comes to the board it's
still full ambition full uh kind of
going for the most critical approaches
critical openings but David is it
possible to fight to become world
champion when you've got this
alternative career that you're serious
about
uh that's my excuse why I never became
world champion you know
going big blunder but I mean it's it's
difficult right because uh in in essence
I mean people play chess for different
reasons
some play it as a hobby some play it
just uh for Pure fun to connect with
other people a lot plate for the results
but there's other I mean he's still
young enough to pursue other careers and
still come back to chess we've seen
various examples of kind of
semi-professional players make it to the
very top of one of the world champions
Max irva uh he was a full-time teacher
mathematician and I mean I can't think
of any modern world champion from the
last like 30 40 years who who has
basically not been thinking about Chess
all the time you know uh like Magnus
okay he's probably the best example he
he does have other interests but he's
always thinking about Chess not always
but he he can always sort of access it
and it's always kind of you can see on
the back of his mind but I I think you
have to have that passion right you have
to really want it more than anything
else in the world to become world
champion so I I you know I think it must
must be a bit of a hindrance if just
having other interests it sounds a bit
bad you know like you have other
interests and it's a hindrance but you
know it's it's hard to be world champion
or anything right you need to be focused
110 generally I feel that's I I agree
with Simon but also I'm at the same time
I do believe that life should be filled
with joy and say for instance fashion
design is something that brings him Joy
he doesn't have to work hard at it it's
just something to make him happy right
and I don't see how that can be a
hindrance and I think it's a really good
um thing for your brain to be engaged in
creative
other creative Pursuits as well
in Pursuit of Happiness for alireza it
has been interesting to see his journey
in the Chess World but I have to say we
love it whenever we see his action
because he just brings so much
entertainment on the board and we're
seeing entertainment in this game as
well David some very committed decisions
in the opening by alireza yeah huge
decisions and uh watch out actually not
just from attack an attack on the king
side from black but actually maybe
Wesley so is the one who has aggressive
intentions on that side of the board
usually in the king's Indian it is black
as he just pushes forward here who
starts throwing pawns towards the white
king but look how white king is not
committed this King in the center will
most likely not actually go kingside now
he also has the option of going to the
other side of the board that's why
Wesley
has uh kind of gone for this kind of
strange Bishop maneuver we've seen this
bishop on F2 kind of go around the board
one move two moves three moves four back
he's just biding time waiting and uh at
the right moment okay first he might
take but at the right moment he might
just move his Queen out the way and go
long and say okay this black king is
actually just very open very weak and
meanwhile as you say Tanya the word is
committal here because you don't move
poems backwards and it's the four porn
attack I'm wondering who wins Connect
Four actually here Black's got Connect
Four here why it's got Connect Four here
just this favor and why well white
because white got it first I did get it
first I think Wesley's gonna win uh yeah
and also there's one game in my database
between two players it was a speed
championship game between Alexa Serana
and kyriel klooking and there Alexis
Arana did exactly what David suggested
put the queen on C2 Castle the king to
the left and it was a very impressive
game from White usually here you want to
block it up as black and then start
pushing pawns but suddenly what are you
even attacking White's Kings long gone
white Kings on the other flank and
actually it's white who might start
thinking about uh thinking about pushing
this Pawn forward and opening lines up
towards the black king later on these
positions are really complex really deep
instead okay he trades off pawns goes
for a more positional approach Lance his
Knight on e4 something you talked about
early assignment and uh I've got to say
I would pick white here all day long
how about the recipe
yeah it's very nice to get that Knight
to E4 I mean uh we saw in the first game
in the match that um Wesley didn't get
this Knight here uh in time and black
was able to get the dark Square Bishop
into the game and this is kind of a
love-hate relationship that black has
with the bishop in front of the king
it's like in this situation it can be a
disaster you know let's imagine that
white ever plays G4 uh if white ever
plays this move then black will never be
able to move the G pawn and that Bishop
just can't get out it's stuck behind its
own pawns but in in other situations
like in the first game
um when the e-pawn is removed from the
board the bishop can be beautiful but
that Knight on e4 it just stops Black's
active play generally
um and um I would say that gives white
an advantage but in the king's him
defenses always it was always messy
because the pieces stay on there's
always breaks you watch out for I mean
black can play with C6 G4 and black can
think about putting his Knight in the
center so there's always so many tricks
and uh sort of active ideas available
for black and that's why it's only
players love playing the kings in
defense it's a very exciting opening
even if it maybe is not entirely sound
the computer for example hates it right
the computer absolutely hates the king's
Indian defense it thinks it's a terrible
opening
um I don't know if that's you know do we
agree with a computer do we think it's a
terrible clearly disagree with the
computer I mean even this position yeah
white does have a great night on the E4
square but you kind of highlighted that
black can also put the Knight on D4 and
the question for white is where you're
going to put the king if you do run to
the left then black is gonna orchestrate
an attack there as well so I mean
okay computers Play Perfect Just humans
don't and well okay pushing the pawn
getting ready to support the night
coming to the C5 Square now I didn't
think about it but now it's on the board
I kind of like it I'm gonna do a bit of
trivia test for all of you guess the
last opponent I played the king's Indian
against
as black as black and I haven't touched
it since this was about
very very strong opponent it wasn't at a
tournament it was an exhibition game
exhibition game Kasparov no not that
brief
um exhibition so when you played it
against
um I was part of a team playing against
Alpha zero Alpha zero I got crushed we
got crushed as a team and ever since
I've just refused to touch the king's
Indian it made the opening look uh
essentially refuted
yeah so traumatic experience sometimes
turns people away against openings
interesting do you think that Kings
Union is a kind of opening that works
really well when you're playing oh
against a human computer because it's
got all these Dynamics all these
attacking ideas you often sacrifice for
the initiative give up on on the queen
side so that you can continue attack on
the king side and it works really well
when you're playing against uh a human
being but when you play against a
computer that can save any kind of
position it falls apart yeah exactly
because the computer is not afraid the
computer doesn't go oh I'm not touching
that the computer will calculate using
Brute Force at times no no no no
I remember a few years ago a grand
master was playing against I think it
was stockfish a piece up and I remember
thinking I don't think The Grandmaster
will win I'm gonna have that little
faith in humankind
um The Grandmaster did win but uh still
computers are too strong and that's been
the case since 97 since that match with
the IBM D blue and now it's just
incomparable that's Trend yeah yeah
curse you deep blue
it did change everything but as Simon
says I mean these types of Pawn
structures computers thought it was just
purely winning for white because you
have extra space in the center for years
and years and years but modern computers
have kind of lessened that Advantage
they've said it is playable uh still
preferring white and uh yeah it's just
purely about the fact that black is
banking on the psychological kind of
attack uh kind of factor and experience
if computers got their own way David
they'd make all humans just play the
Berlin every single game literally
Berlin Berlin Berlin you'd see nothing
else and oh my God that's a terrifying
world that's how I got myself against
Alpha zero it played the Berlin against
me
so it's like yeah let's you know I I
love I think some of the best things in
life are things that are not perfect
right you know and that's a very human
characteristic that you know you can do
flawed things and they actually are
quite beautiful because they're flawed
and that's something the computers can't
do so King's in defense is probably a
bit flawed but it's much more exciting
having that sort of side to it the
flawed side and here we go look at this
move G4 this is this is a very practical
move I mean uh I don't know if it's
sacrificing a porn but it's uh it's it's
it's creating a bit of chaos so uh a
nice move
and before for the score
and it's a perfect example of what we're
talking about right the computer doesn't
agree with it says that G4 shouldn't
work the eval bar Rises up but from a
human perspective if you're playing
white you would be super scared of this
move it just creates an absolute Chaos
on the board and you have no idea how to
handle it well we should really dive in
and see whether it is chaotic it is
chaotic in this position G4 was played
and the pawn was captured I'm expecting
now that uh either this move or after a
rook trade okay he goes for The Rook
trade first uh then black is going to
most likely eliminate this bishop uh
before taking this Pawn back and I'm
assuming he's going to take with the
queen he could take with the King here
Wesley so just to insist that black has
to remove this Bishop from the board
because now you cannot take on G4 uh
White is simply ganging up on that point
too many times simply porn up here uh
two connected past pawns as well so
Wesley is pausing which way is he going
to recapture if you take with the queen
maybe there's an argument for not
trading off and leaving yourself with a
very strong Knight in the center on D4
and as Tanya says it's scary for both
sides it's really unclear who's better
here Let's ignore the computer the
players don't know that uh actually they
probably do know the computer favors
white because it is the King's Indian
but uh still plenty to play for white
has nice stability with these three
minor pieces in the center but what next
is really unclear
I love it super unclear and exactly it's
the kind of position that you just you
just Chuck the eval bar out of the
window and you don't care what you're
seeing because practically it's a very
difficult position it's a game for all
three results uh Queen F1 has been the
capture of Choice by Wesley and we're
expecting a recapture on G4 this is
going to be a hot hot battle it's going
to be a fun one but let's take this
moment to jump in and check in with our
other game Magnus Carlsen and eating
only a draw against Fabi goes for his
opening of choice his usual approach of
the alapin to shut down any Sicilian
counter player and I think he's been
successful in doing that he's been
successful in sucking all of the life
all of all of the fun out of the
position but Fabion has kept enough
pieces to at least ask some questions
and the pawn structure is in Balance
we've talked about that we've spoken
about that earlier today in must win
situations you need something some small
uh hope to cling on to and here it's
just the fact that Fabiano on the king
side has a four versus three poor
majority as black not easy to mobilize
that that's the one downside and you're
playing an endgame Maestro like Magnus
uh We've mentioned that a few times as
well today and Magnus is just saying
okay you don't have a plan what are you
gonna do next looks very very balanced
to me
yeah very hard to break down uh this
position I think for black or to make
progress but I've never seen Magnus when
he's got a two nil lead ever lose it so
there might be a there has to be a first
time there is there is right okay yeah
where was that um it was again this
young Christian of Duda okay and it
wasn't the I can't remember where but I
I remember it was like Magnus had a
two-point lead and then Judo was playing
black he was a caracan and it looked
like things were going White's way and
then suddenly it wasn't okay so it has
happened before then
um it's not happening today Simon with
this position I don't think so no I mean
I think there is still a bit of life
here I mean it's not the worst position
you can have if you need to win because
as David mentioned you you got uh you
know different Pawn structure uh there's
still some piece on the board I'm trying
to make it sound really exciting and
winnable and I'm not believing what I'm
saying so no okay I mean this is
absolutely he hasn't got any weaknesses
has he that's a problem there's no
weaknesses in White's position at all to
Target that's true Magnus doesn't have
any weaknesses but on the other hand his
Bishop on at starting Square doesn't
make a great impression
it's got no future I mean is there a way
for black to actually improve
his horns and his pieces okay you know
he mobilizes his dark Square Bishop
that's already good
yup makes a lot of sense uh White's
night in the center
again octo Knight just uh eyeing up a
few pawns at least now putting some
pressure there kind of pinning down the
white Rook defending its Knight maybe
the problem for Magnus as well hard to
improve it's really hard to foresee any
uh kind of productive plan for either
side that's the dilemma here
does black ever want to push before and
try and create a weakness on the Queen's
side could that be something that Fabi
has on his mind yeah at least the hint
of uh B4
definitely don't want to rush uh you
might allow white to step forward with
the seaport Pawn there but yeah at least
Magnus on every turn will have to work
out what happens if black does try to
explode open the queen side meanwhile on
the other flank it's kind of yeah it's a
bit of a waiting game
could black be tempted to also just
leave the left side intact for the
minute and just expand on the right side
of the board and I know David is reading
my mind yeah that's what Magnus will do
if he were black he'd start pushing uh
Harry the H Corner's black Gary maybe
Gary as well we're actually finding a
lot of ideas for black but not many
ideas white which Maybe
you know even infers that we prefer
Black's position slightly I mean if
Magnus is playing Black here we probably
would right
um this move I was thinking about I I
wanted to play this move but I I
couldn't calculate what was happening
after Knight takes Bishop uh which which
must be the the most critical variation
here because
um obviously now you've got an option of
even taking on E6 but I don't think that
works maybe yeah I'm not sure you can
take immediately uh this Rook is hanging
so you can't take with the Knight if you
take with the bishop I guess the black
king just side steps and the Knight will
be removed the defender of this bishop
black will go a piece up next move
after taking here so maybe you can get
away with taking I think the main
question is what happens if black okay
this is on the board what happens if
sorry white simply recaptures and wow
King to E7 just a calm sidestep allowing
this Pawn to drop in two different ways
just as earlier you cannot take with the
bishop because the Knight is removed you
lose this piece so what happens if you
take with a knight I guess just Bishop
takes Pawn check yeah I mean you love
the Bishops David I do you know you're a
big fan Magnus loves loves Bishops on
the board so uh this is at least it's on
balance this I don't think this is dead
as uh
um it's not a dead position at all is
that this one yeah not as dead as a Dodo
that's uh phrase I learned when I was
young and I was like what is a dodo man
but uh yeah this position look at the
Bishops very very strong if the Rooks
come off the board I really fancy
Black's chances here uh you could start
pushing these pawns a bit later on the
one downside here is the blacks King is
still slightly vulnerable while Rooks
remain and Magnus side steps of course
with his King
Knight C7 is the one plan here I guess
that we could get that same ending we've
seen time and time again right Knight C7
to D5 or take the bishop you know is the
other idea the rook and opposite Club
Bishop
it's why it's black to play though so if
you can you preempt that plan
I guess you can also push the B Pawn
potentially and try and calculate
something there
it feels like now or never for Fabiano
if he wants to have any hint of a win of
a winning chance he needs something
energetic I don't see it it's definitely
progress for Fabi he has managed to get
the bishop there an open position uh
will it be enough or not we will keep an
eye on this one but meanwhile big action
on the Wesley against Ali Reservoir we
will come back to this but let's check
in on that because Wesley has taken the
advantage in his game and I think it
comes down to that over expanded King
side but we left it here H takes G4 not
much has happened
uh still pretty complicated yeah just
one decision here that at least the
engine doesn't approve of and to be
honest me as well I'm really really
surprised for Russia has traded off the
light squared Bishops because in the
king's Indian the light squared Bishop
for black is like gold dust it's
Priceless uh Simon highlighted black
dark Squad Bishop next to the black king
that's just blocked in it's a terrible
piece it just looks like a big Pawn
right now and it's all about the light
squares white has 100 domination control
over the light squares because farrugia
has traded off light squared Bishops and
I don't really understand why
strange decision because we were looking
at the recapture with the pawn keep that
light squared bishop and I think Ivanka
this is something that you keep talking
about Black's Knight on A6 right right
now he's playing without a piece he
needs to spend that Tempo to get it to
the center of the board uh but that G4
Pawn without the light Square Bishop is
a huge weakness and if that falls uh the
whole game collapses right now he's
looking at getting the Rook into the
game Rook F1 another idea yeah recap one
is coming your Black's way and also the
bishop coming to G5
um that's going to be backed up by the
queen also coming into the position
um it's looking dodgy for black
all right and I'm being polite here
trivia question what do you think is
Wesley's accuracy in this game David if
you had to take a guess 96
97 97.
oh 98.
you're 94 it's 99.4 is it a Flawless
game so far wow after that move Queen F2
it's jumped to 99.4 percent wow
moves looked like they were preparation
so he's played eight moves pretty much
perfectly which is still impressive
especially in such a complicated middle
game but um this is Wesley in his
element when he's got full stability
we've talked about the center he's got
no real Attack to face here his pieces
are just slowly improving every move
he's just talking to his pieces he's
saying okay Queen you can be improved
right The Rook in the corner you want to
be improved yep slide you across next
move
okay can this percentage thing then so
this is uh telling you you know if
you're playing perfect chess or not can
it tell us what the it should be able to
tell us what the best first move is then
right
yeah because it'd be 100 wouldn't it
okay so I want to know what's the best
first move is it is it D4 or is it E4
because you know if you played a wrong
move then your percentage will drop so
uh answers on the postcard to send in
yeah E4 D4 E4 D4 what's best maybe it's
C4 maybe it's A3 maybe we've been
fooling ourselves all this time and
haven't you heard I've heard that but I
don't really believe it because you
allow the Berlin and that can't be that
can't be best it's just
so I reckon it's D4 I reckon D4 is the
best move it's definitely not G4 that's
all I know that's that's true yeah we
can't G for it up so but David you were
talking about talking to the pieces on
the board what would you be telling the
black pieces right now how can he get a
better position than what he has yeah
let's uh jump in because we see some of
the computer moves actually wow ferrugia
did find the top engine suggestion but
it might not help him here I was going
to say you need to get this Rook into
the game there might not be time to
improve this Black Knight because it
actually doesn't do much centralizing
that piece so he did find the top engine
suggestion Queen to f8 but now look at
what the computer says again huge
Advantage here for white actually you
can maintain an edge in several ways but
the best move
Queen to H4 by far the best move simply
hitting this weak Pawn which shouldn't
have been weak if you left your light
Square Bishop on the board and now you
cannot defend it simply if you bring
your queen into the game you get hit
again by the white Rook with gain of
time if you slide back I think that's
going to be nasty checks here why it's
going to start attacking uh bringing the
rook in this is going to be disastrous
for black and essentially here no way to
keep this intact I guess you have this
move Knight to F5 maybe this is what
ferrugia is banking on making Wesley so
pause
uh but I guess you just step forward
again and say yes you can trade off but
look at what you're going to be left
with uh just for illustration purposes I
want to show this type of position is
simply good night against Bad bishop and
uh this bishop is not going to enjoy
this uh enjoy the rest of this game
queen and I also uh superior to the
queen and Bishop combo so yeah Queen H4
looks decisive but even an end game in
this type of scenario uh would suit
Wesley style I believe
yeah and there we go Rick F1 actually
just on the board just keeping it very
simple and uh also looks quite nice I
mean you the problem is black Black's
got this wheat Pawn on G4 that you
pointed out uh but the the queen side
pawns are very weak for black in in the
kings in defense quite often and uh in
this situation a white can timer Knight
B5 uh to start hitting them and uh
there's there's just a lot of a lot of
weaknesses there uh black needs to get
that Knight into the game on the corner
so he needs to try to play Knight C5 at
the right moment but then he has to
watch out for B4 as well and uh the dark
Square Bishop is no it's just
everything's a little bit better for
white wow yeah I would just want to hang
in on your first point the porn on G4
that is up for grabs yeah I can't be
defended and those are two passes there
on the right side of the board so I
thought this move was forced and uh one
Pawn to the get why is he not grabbing
that ball
you're insulted by that move take that
pawn
grabbing the pawn was bad it's probably
still all right but
it's uh yeah I think a miscalculation by
Wesley maybe he just assumed he'd go a
pawn up and now we're left with this
position and actually the Black Knights
are jumping slight uh somewhat into the
square into this Square
um yeah these Knights are creating chaos
if you had one more move to cage then
maybe that night on the edge of the
board then you would have been loving
life but
she's back in it this is this is the
thing with the king's intervention you
get the worst ugliest looking position
as black then all of a sudden Black's
pieces pop out of nowhere and cause some
chaos you know I think I think it was
John Nunn who was uh one of the best
ever Kings Indian defense players we
have one more move on the board G4 but
John Nunn who who beat a lot of the top
players in the kings in defense he
mentioned about this and the benoni I
think it was he said positionally
terrible opening you know you're you're
basically lost positionally but you
always have tricks because your pieces
get so active and look at those nights
it's uh it's just a jumbler pieces in
the center and they're getting a little
bit of activity here right
and we were talking about that exact
same night which is on D3 just a couple
of moons ago doing nothing at the edge
of the board and being the one piece
that needs to get active and alirez has
managed to do that the one thing I know
about King's Indian is that if white
manages to get this blockade on e4 or
Knight on e4 you basically kill Black's
dark Squad Bishop for the rest of the
game and you've got this dominating
Knight which can be an attacker but an
equally good Defender and that's a
massive piece which gives white a
long-term Advantage so even though
Wesley is not up a pawn positionally
strategically he's still got to be
better because of that Knight on e4 yeah
I do bet here though that his accuracy
levels have dropped so I might need to
check that uh it yeah it just feels to
me like it's Wesley kind of as we know
and love him but uh also the Wesley that
we sometimes say oh you could be world
champion you could be so much better if
you were slightly more aggressive I mean
keeping the Queens on the board just
looks so nice so beautiful especially
because White's King was so much safer
than the black king and that's another
thing we've talked about when you're
attacking when you'll decide with the
initiative keep the Queens on but
trading Queens off yes white still has a
kind of visual Advantage aesthetically
still looks really nice but now we're
slightly closer to safety for black
potentially and uh yeah look at those
that kind of assortment of knights
blacks Knights doing some great work
there
I mean the night's definitely improved
from where it was it's come all the way
over from A6 right onto F4 so kind of
fantastic Journey there I was hoping it
was going to go to E1 last week that
just seemed quite fun probably a lot of
rubbish but it seemed interesting and um
if black can get his Rook over uh on the
next move I mean uh he he's trying to
find coordination with the pieces uh so
it's not it's not terrible anymore by
any means it's certainly not terrible I
agree with you there and you guys were
talking about nights so much I was
expecting the pun nightmare nighttime
and the King steps forward I agree with
you though Tanya I think white
definitely has the advantage and I'm
just gonna actually say it's because of
the G4 Pawn I mean the Knight on e4 is
doing a fantastic job at just keeping
this E5 Pawn under locking key
butter G for porn it's it's loose and
it's gonna start pushing yeah
all right this is going to be quite an
end game battle and Wesley's got a
minute and a half on the clock so not
that much time left we might be seeing a
very fascinating time scramble develop
in this one let's head over to the
Magnus Fabby game has Fabi managed to
create any chances I do see some threats
against white skin right now yeah I
think Fabiano's done a fantastic job of
keeping this game alive and we talk
about the bishop pair as long as pawns
remain on both sides as long as there's
action on both flanks as long as Rooks
remain uh this bishop part has great
potential certainly
Superior hair to White Knight and Bishop
combo and Black's pawns will start
rolling White's King slightly vulnerable
should be a draw with the best play just
because there aren't too many pieces
left on the board but it's definitely
Magnus here fighting for his life this
is a dream type of position for black
yeah you also said earlier David which I
I've never really thought about but I
love these little bits of advice you can
get where if you have the Bishops the
more pieces you get off the board the
stronger they become and this must be a
case where there's not many pieces left
it's just the Bishops of one rookie so
they're controlling a lot of squares
there and Bishops work really well with
Rooks Queens work really well with
knights but Bishops and Rooks coordinate
uh fantastically well so it's uh it's uh
there's some chances here definitely
yeah I mean and I love uh fabi's last
move because uh he's Advanced his Pawn
but the idea is actually to move the
bishop to G4 and trap the white Rook
that is why Magnus is like no not gonna
let that happen and he moves it to the
C4 square but Wesley's Bishop sorry not
Wesley um fabi's Bishops they are
rocking they're coming towards the King
David I feel like he's gonna win this
one Fabiano just look at the clock time
as well Magnus is finding only moves at
this point to even survive that white
king is living a Charmed Life it's going
to start getting checked by the black
Dart squared Bishop as well soon it's
kind of being caught in a cage and
emitting that almost and the Bishops are
closing in this is a great game and if
he wins this he's got white in the next
game as well so wow Simon King F3 is
there some E4 tag this should be four I
like yeah I mean that that's a very nice
really nice move I mean I don't know if
the white king can run away but this
also surrounding the white King has many
threatened making one is threatened
Bishop to E2 would be a Checkmate now
how does Magnus guard against that
that's nice you've got to come back with
your knight is that the only way to do
it
Rook would kick you to the corner and
Magnus is running but surely this is
going to end in disaster
the bishop can check and then the black
g-pawn could start pushing I think this
is just going to be made within a few
moves it's a checkmating that 14 seconds
as well Fabby should finish this off now
again game four is what it looks like
the Bishops the bonds the black Rook all
coordinating beautifully we don't get to
see this often Magnus Carlson about to
get checkmated in an end game by a pawn
potentially yeah that porn could just
come for us and that would be a really
nice Checkmate you can also move them
the Rick is coming
incoming Bishop G4 was a big threat okay
this has been stopped I think Fabiana
missed this okay but he's still going
for checkmate this is cage Beautiful
People you have to give them you have to
reside up the night get the night up
yeah oh that was that's fantastic
fantastic place I think he's done it he
has he's won he's come back I don't
think any of us expected that and he
played he played a brilliant game there
to take Magnus Carlson down with the
black pieces incredible
he wins the Indian game check meeting
magnus's King there and leaves Magnus
meanwhile just shuts off his screen I
don't think even he can believe it that
with the white pieces he got outplayed
in an end game what a fantastic
performance there will be a game four
but Fabi still has to win one more to
force a tie Break Meanwhile this action
is still on
uh wow A lot has happened are we going
to see another repetition here yeah I
think we've jumped in just before the
result is confirmed suddenly the white
Knights are a bit stretched clinging
onto each other blacks pieces Super
Active the black Rook especially and I
think it's time for Wesley so to just
pull the handbrake here and just say
okay I'm gonna repeat moves keep
harassing that black Rook with the white
king before it's too late otherwise I
think you even lose control here as
white potentially and uh Wesley under 20
seconds as well it would be the
pragmatic thing to do and third time
we've seen that position it is a draw a
time we've seen that position third time
we're seeing this result in this matchup
with three draws the level the score is
level we will have a fourth game I'm
still thinking about how Fabi managed to
make a comeback in that one in this one
Wesley did have some real chances in the
middle game but alireza manages to keep
everything level and with the king's
Indian defense it lives on and that one
ended in a draw
David Fabi survives goes into game four
how did he manage to do that it's all
about the power of the Bishops in that
game Fabiano just uh surviving the
middle game taking it down to an end
game and taking down Magnus Carlson look
at how powerful these Bishops are they
control the whole board this bishop just
Mighty on the dark squares this this
bishop as well complementing it
perfectly just controlling everything
and this was the star move H4 closing a
cage around the white king and Magnus
here with no time on his clock did Panic
and blunder he needed to start running
away towards the corner an ugly move and
but a necessary move instead look at
what happened the king started advancing
but suddenly this check forced the white
king into a box on the corner and just a
few moves later after a Trader Bishops
this was the killer blow Pawn to G5 and
the only way to prevent porn town down
to G4 Checkmate is to give up the Knight
Magnus resigned about to be checkmated
water game and what an end game that by
Fabiano Karana you'll be I'm thinking
about what you said the way to beat
Magnus is to Checkmate him
oh well turns out I can predict the
future that was very prophetic let's
take a look at our score line with
another game coming up in both matches
it looked like it would be a three-game
match one more time for Magnus Carlsen
but it wasn't to be as Fabby with some
fantastic end gameplay keeps the match
going meanwhile Wesley and Ali Raza uh
continue with their draws Fighting Chess
but the score is level the final rapid
game is about to start we will be back
with all the action from the Julius bear
generation Cup in just a few moments
[Music]
so now Magnus and myself are going to be
taking on the air things challenge we're
going to play chess but with a Twist all
of the pieces are air things devices we
might be able to rely on pattern
recognition in the first few moves but
we will definitely lose our way
somewhere along the lines we also have a
big crowd here so I'm feeling the
pressure let's go okay I'll stop
oh no he's too calm I don't like it
uh
[Music]
did not expect that one it's not a very
good move ah it's the Mind Games he's
teasing me already does this actually
work
you tell me
I'm guessing I know you're guessing just
sometimes your guesses are right that's
the problem
I've studied this before Magnus
yeah but I mean I can't back down in
this game
that's Brave okay if that was a check so
I'm hiding in the corner
[Music]
he's coming back another check
oh my God I need like two hours for this
position
[Music]
oh I just saw a nice way to lose the
game okay he spotted my trap one thing
is like to play just this way but to
watch this must be
we're so sorry
ah
[Music]
what is my
oh I'm losing damn it
oh my god oh
[Music]
foreign
if you say so
I think what helped some pieces were
exchanged early the position was very
open I think that helped a lot like if
we played a closer game it would have
been a lot harder
yeah
[Music]
alireza faruga needs no introduction
this Superstar burst onto the scene as a
teenager becoming world number two at 18
years old
however since then progress has been
somewhat measured
he's been inconsistent and his love for
chess has at times been questioned
on the board though farouza is dynamite
he's aggressive he's Dynamic and there's
a Fear Factor about farrugia's play none
of the top players in the world can ever
relax when farrugia is sat opposite them
I have experienced the power of alares
many times myself
one of the most heartbreaking games of
my career came in the grand Swiss in
2021 when ferrugia beat me and went on
to qualify for the candidates
in this position I thought I was doing
okay with black however farugia is an
attacking Maestro and he shocked Me by
playing Knight takes Pawn sacrificing a
knight and he had calculated everything
perfectly the idea is that when the
Knight is recaptured suddenly this white
light squared Bishop is opened up to
capture the Black Knight and black has
too many things hanging this bishop is
suddenly attacked in the center the
black king is open and for example after
a capture of Bishops in the center white
can calmly recapture because the Black
Knight is undefended if you give alireza
farusha a tactical shot he will find it
and he will punish you as I found out
for myself
ah alireza feruja is up against Wesley
so he is trying to get his spot into the
season final he hasn't won an event yet
in the Champions Chester but he's had a
fantastic start taking down another back
up to satrov in the quarterfinals and
today three games have ended in a draw
going into the fourth game and these are
some of the big performances he's the
youngest player to ever cross
2800 in 2022 he was the Grand Chester
Champion but we have been seeing alireza
rarely in the Chess World now or at
least not as much as we'd like to
because he is pursuing a career in
fashion and it'll be interesting to see
how he's able to balance these two right
now he's got to balance his match
against Wesley what are the chances of
this one going into an Armageddon well
just judging by how level all the games
have been so far just judging by the
kind of high quality they've been I'd
say armageddon's very likely uh it feels
like they're canceling each other out
right now now and it might just take on
getting to separate them yeah it
certainly looks like that but we have to
remind ourselves the stakes are pretty
high for Wesley because it's not just a
place in the semi-finals if he wins this
then he is gonna secure himself a spot
in Toronto yeah this yeah really
important game is going on I mean uh
there's not much between Wesley and
faroogia at the moment and can Fabiano
come back as well
um I I'm gonna say Magnus losing two in
a row that that that's really rare as
possible I mean but I I'm just amazed
how Fabiano actually uh just outplayed
him you know you outplayed Magnus in the
ending and that that was really that was
really impressive to to do that and a
beautiful Checkmate pattern so you are
not sure dance and because you did say
the only way to win is to check many
exactly even Magnus cannot survive a
Checkmate that was incredible and that
also watching his King get trapped
just making magic out of nowhere in that
position with such few pawns that was
super impressive stuff I'm gonna be
honest I thought that was going to be
matching three for Magnus
yeah I wasn't so sure actually uh when
you know when we tuned in and we saw
that the bishop had come to E3 and you
know that Fabi got the bishop pair
that's when I thought actually I think
Fabi is gonna win this
and he did uh which means that they will
be playing a game for Magnus Carlton
needs only a draw to wrap up the match
or perhaps we will have an Armageddon in
that one as well Fabi needs to win in
that case and we've got some big wins
coming in from division two as well this
has been the Winner's quarter-finals
scores for the day as Jana Pam Nashi
takes down Vladimir farashiev in three
one quite a crushing Victory there Dr
I'm in Boston with a win over Salam
Manley and artemia takes down Laura
fresena Levon aronian for whom four
points are so critical to make it to
Toronto is well on his path as he
qualifies for the winner semi-finals
taking down Alexi Serrano two and a half
to one and a half all the semi-finals
matchups will be coming on on chess
dojo's channel in division two tomorrow
that is some action that you don't want
to miss uh David who do you think will
be able to take division two this time
we saw an incredible list players
fighting it out oh it's so tough there's
so many names that I want to see there
in Toronto that's the the problem I'm
gonna say Levon aronian is uh my pick
right now just because he did defeat
Serana who we all know is supremely
strong Serana the piranha European
champion and uh yeah if he can continue
to continue continue that form level
neronian he'll be hard to stop
razor sharp serrana piranha there but
Levon aronian did reign supreme in that
one he will be playing against Art
tamiyev Lavon versus Artemis in the
semi-finals is there a favorite uh Simon
I am yes I'm just trying to work out who
it is you probably have to go aronium
right I mean because he is the more
experienced player but our temir is a
fantastic player and we've seen him in
previous tours uh do so well here he's
beaten Magnus on a number of occasions
so that's going to be a really really uh
tough match and I want to call that we
did see our tummy ever earlier in the
Champions Chester and he had quite a
fantastic performance taking down Magnus
Carlsen as well but love on our onion
there is big big motivation for him but
right now Magnus Carlsen he's got to be
feeling motivated after that bit of a
shock in game three losing to this man
Fabiano caruana he makes his comeback he
keeps his chances alive a big game for
coming up Fabi has to win in on demand
to take it to tie breaks he does start
with the white pieces as well Ivanka and
we've got the English opening we do have
the English opening and Magnus answering
in a very combative Way by pushing his
Kingston two squares forward and now it
becomes like a colors reversed mussolimo
opening
it's like a sicilian and the difference
here is that white has an extra move so
you do have the opportunity to jump into
the center chasing that black bishop and
this little dance between the Bushman
Knights often goes on for a few more
turns it's interesting that Magnus
turned away from his previous black
opening where he was basically winning
after six seven moves as black but of
course Fabiano would have come with an
improvement so Magnus trying to keep the
surprises and uh yeah early days here
the first time I I lost to a certain
David Howe was uh after Knight D5 as
well with the white pieces I think it
was the Isle of Man you were about three
years old foreign
but I think it was a similar variation
uh Bishop B4 and uh yeah it's uh props
my Bishop back to a different square but
uh very similar yeah Bishop B7 and uh
but this is this is this is quite a
unique position right I mean this is not
Mainline Theory I mean at this level the
the players know it so well and uh we
see now with Fabiano getting the two
Bishops again so all he has to do is
what he did last game easy get to an
ending use the two Bishops Checkmate
play off do the same again there
um and go through to the next round yeah
yeah
Nostradamus no no it's not gonna happen
no um
the crystal ball is a little bit cloudy
so I can't tell but you know you guys
seem to remember all your games well
David does I mean he did correct me then
foreign
it was quite an early round it was a
morning round because I remember that
you might not have um
the night before anyway yeah back to
this game and uh this one is complicated
this is actually still a known position
um at least it's occurred in a few level
kind of decent level games the
difference here
between a sicilian is that white has
these very far Advanced doubled pawns on
the C file normally we would see one
Pawn maybe slightly further back and uh
White also that means okay firstly the
pawns are weak but that means let's talk
again white start Squad Bishop is going
to be a very important piece white
starts where Bishop is going to land on
B2 very shortly on the long diagonal and
it's going to exert extreme pressure
across the board so even if white
sacrifices a pawn which is quite topical
quite typical here
it looks pretty promising strategic
trade-off here by Fabiano caruana
destroying his spawn structure getting a
double bond but it is for the bishop
bear and the dark Squad Bishop which
cannot be challenged for the rest of the
game it's going to be a fun fight
meanwhile alireza furuja is ready to get
go against Wesley so and he starts with
the King spawn opening what are the
chances of getting a Berlin this time
Berlin or Petrov I think those two most
solid of openings oh hang on a second
the racing through this is the moment of
truth
seen so many berlins like give us
something else please the love of gods
no more berlins
I'm surprised though Wesley I would have
thought he's uh yeah really happy with
the drawers black but instead he chooses
a more fighting approach interesting
and maybe even hinting at a marshall
yeah or the martial though that's that's
the New Berlin it's the Berlin of the
2020s the Marshall
uh it used to be a Gambit used to be a
very attacking line but these days known
for its Jewish Tendencies there's not
many gambits I was thinking about this
the other day there's literally not many
gambits left that you can actually play
uh the only two I could sort of think of
is the like Queen's Gambit or the the
Marshall Gambit that a sound that top
players play there's not really any
other gambits that the top players play
regularly is there elephants
that's another one the king's Gambit
yeah but no one plays
dodgy what's happened with the Evans
okay anyway that says there's a
discussion for after the show I mean
achimata um the famous YouTuber loves it
plays it but I don't think I've seen
anyone you know over 2600 played for
years unfortunately won a very uh
important game at the world rapid Team
Championship with the Kings we won't
mention that one oh sorry okay it was
against team and we were so close to uh
doing something
and winning
anyway this is no Gambit
but you're right David here there are no
Pawn sacrifices no Gambit it is a slow
strategic fight H3 on the board so
taking away the chief of square how are
we expecting this one to develop yeah
it's all about what uh set up Wesley so
chooses here it's not the Marshall
Gambit because Black's Deport didn't
break open the center in one go uh often
that comes at the cost of a pawn but
opening the position when Black's pieces
are ready uh makes a lot of sense
instead this will take a slower turn
farrugia as well he's not going for a
main line either he's trying to avoid
any opening debate uh where preparation
might play a role he's just saying okay
I'm gonna play really slowly this
Central tension will happen eventually
maybe black will break first White will
break first in the center but uh first
it's a bit of maneuvering who can put
their pieces on good squares and this
has been made topical by players like
Jordan van Forrest and Magnus Carls and
Fabiano they've all been playing like
this recently as white
and yeah it's just very slow start to
this game and I'm still thinking about
the gambits and I wonder if it's uh if
it's a generational thing when you know
the computers were not as strong and in
the previous generation it was more easy
for players to be aggressive play for
the initiative sacrifice sort of that
romantic chess error but now with every
each of these strong players being so
good at defensive resources that gambits
have kind of just become a little more
redundant now they're very rare at top
level I mean even like you know like say
20 years ago you had the Moscow Gambit
which is still play but that was really
I mean and won a very famous game I
think in the world championships maybe
to help him become world champion
possibly in in the Moscow Gambit
um but yeah there's not as not as many
gambits around they're dying poor things
it's really sad they're getting extinct
we need to start some welfare group for
them bring back the gambits at 2700
level yeah I reckon we need more proper
gambits and I don't mean the Queen's
game is not even a proper game
I mean but dodgy gambits you know oh the
sad day they do work at top level abduce
a tour of wiped aronian off the board in
20 moves with a really dodgy Gambit with
white uh just yeah just in the last
Champions chess Tour event I think the
preparation you can do I mean I I think
there's still scope and some some
players like to say uh naughty Beck did
this uh Jordan fan Forest is a great one
as well it's finding really old ideas
that people have forgotten and sort of
reanalyzing them with the latest
computers which you have to do and even
if they're not 100 sound bringing them
back to life somehow and I think there's
there's still possibilities you can do
that but you can only you can only use
it once you know you can't that's the
problem the old days you could use these
gambits like you know dozens of times
but if you if you use it once your next
opponents can prepare for it and you
have to throw you know you have to not
use it again so that's that's the
problem with these kind of dubious
gambits nowadays you have more
maneuvering chests like this and this is
why positional maneuvering chess is so
important to understand and uh the
action will will happen a lot later
generally in in the top matches nowadays
um so yeah I mean pretty standard
position here I'd say really I mean
maneuvering maneuvering chests and
checkmates because if you have to beat
Magnus Carlson you've got to know your
checkmates Fabi managed to do it and I
believe we've got some updates coming in
from the Fabi versus Magnus matchup we
will come back to this as you said David
it is a strategic battle it's going to
be a long one uh let's jump over uh and
check out the Fabi game wow I don't know
if it's a Gambit or not but it's
definitely a crazy position crazy
position and uh Fabiano is gambling uh
he's not gambited any pawns yet but he's
chosen a really kind of risky strategy
that's an impressive mug I've got to say
from uh Carolina a second ago I hope we
see that again but uh yeah the play has
evolved significantly and I think we
need to jump in just to get to grips
with what is going on in this position
this is the current position we'll
discuss in a moment uh we left it around
here uh when Magnus Carlson had just
castled and I'm not sure about Fabiano
playing on the queen side I'm not a huge
fan of this approach I think he should
have been playing on the other flank and
after a few trades we saw Magnus gain a
lot of space in this Center and wow
Chaos on the board so I'm going to catch
up with the current position after the
move F3 I think if Fabiano just needed a
draw he were a very safe position he
would have traded off Bishops but he
needs to attack of course he's trying to
open up the G file for his rook and
Magnus has jumped in boom Knight to E4
wow
great minds great minds Tanya
you gotta love 94. oh it's such a nice
movie the one piece is hanging and then
you make the other one hanging as well
yeah put yourself in a self-walking
yourself it's uh yeah but uh that's a
Gambit for you Simon that's a peace
Gambit I like it much much better than a
pawn gabit see the these world champions
they don't do things by half you know I
don't need to Gambit a pawn I have a
piece you know I don't I don't think he
can take you I don't know can you yeah
we should mention you cannot take the
Knight of course because the White Queen
would fall to the black bishop and uh
taking the other one would also be
catastrophic at least in terms of the
match situation because after a check
the white King has to step forward only
legal move and uh I was going to say at
the very least you can take this Pawn I
think this would force a draw because
the king cannot step forward there would
be a devastating night Fork a royal Fork
here winning the White Queen and if you
step back of course black can just
repeat the moves and Magnus would
progress to the next round so Fabiano
could not accept that Gambit and what
does Magnus have up his sleeve after the
pawn steps forward to H4 taking away
this infiltration Square from The Black
Queen uh guarded now by the white Rook
Magnus still has this uh Fork on his
hands does he have to step back now with
his Bishop Queen F6 is possible maybe is
it as well
that's very nice Queen F6 um I don't
know if it's any good but I mean just
just trying to put some pressure on and
I love these chat mate ideas you know
this is uh yeah I I think it's fair
something like that something yeah I
wasn't quite sure but uh anyhow we do
have to kind of like approach this very
complicated position quite
systematically so there's like queen
move that David's indicated Bishop
Retreats there's also the Knight jump
forward and attack The Rook that's
another possibility and then once you've
kind of outlined all the moves that you
have available you then gotta rank them
that is the way unfortunately and then
you choose you always start with the one
that you like the most
which one do you like the most Ivanka
well the rules kind of say that you
should introduce a new piece into it
into the attack so I would be looking at
first attacking yeah playing the queen
to F6
yeah let's uh give Magnus Carlson that
dilemma three very tempting
opportunities here valuation Bar says
it's in Black's favor that's not
surprising because white is undeveloped
but uh still very complicated could go
either way maybe you can just go Bishop
page five as well yeah just just try to
keep the tension that seems like a
Magnus move right you know you can just
keep the tension keep the pressure in
the position but there's there's a lot
of uh you can go wrong here can't you I
mean very very easily with both colors
and I I it's very messy and this is
interesting stuff really exciting yeah a
critical position and that explains why
Magnus is taking his time right now
three tempting options as you pointed
out and Fabi he's just taken so many big
decisions on the board that King on E1
is probably going to be in the center of
the board for the rest of the game you
don't have safety on the king side I
don't know if you'll ever see a queen
side castling here which means it's sort
of an another all-in kind of a setup by
Fabi here he's he has to try to again go
for an attack go for magnus's King to
try and get anything if you let Magnus
consolidate white could be lost in the
next couple of moves right you know with
that King in the center and if Magnus is
able to just introduce more pieces to
the attack I agree with you I don't
think fabi's King is long for the world
but on the plus side I do remember the
words of Alexander grishek who found
himself in this type of situation he
said well a bad opening King bad middle
Game King but you know the longer the
game drew a drawer draw out it became a
really good English Game King so uh Fabi
does have long-term possibilities to
look forward to if he can survive
and he needs to do that he doesn't only
need to survive he needs to win uh this
game and we see a decision on the board
Magnus steps back from the fork uh quite
I think this is the most human approach
you just want to make sure that your
pieces don't remain hanging the pin is
still on there's pressure on F3 your
idea of Knight G3 your uh Simon your
idea of Queen F6 always in there Bishop
H5 just felt like the movie really want
to make here
it's all about timing as well if white
gets a few moves if white could somehow
release the pressure kick away the black
knight from the center Fabian is happy
if Magnus gets time to develop his Queen
side the other Black Knight coming out
the black queen Coming Out Black's gonna
have a raging attack so uh these next
few moves might be where it's decided
definitely feels like one of those types
of positions no boring maneuvering here
no uh no kind of small uh strategic
finesses it's just pure brute force and
uh Fabiano he needs to find an accurate
move here otherwise I fear for his life
in this game
yeah I mean whose King is weakest and it
certainly looks like White's King right
I mean uh The Rook on H1 has to hold on
to the pawn uh okay so he's broken the
pin there uh with this with this bishop
move and now now Magnus has the decision
to make with the knight uh White is
threatening to take that Knight now so
uh do do you dive in I mean diving in
for a very normal uh reaction to play
here uh in the position
and
saying I don't think there's many other
options maybe you just dive in right
yeah
Rook to H3 on the board as well hitting
that Knight and uh not many squares to
go to you have to either Retreat or take
this bishop he does remove the bishop
here maybe haunted by uh memories of the
previous game and now for Magnus what to
do next
is it time to start developing this
piece this piece lots of options
to yeah develop the knights
is hang on a second just do it with time
maybe I can actually develop the queen
first and then the night yeah
yeah we can hit this rook in the corner
actually I was gonna say be careful
because Fork double attack oh this could
be disastrous potentially but okay he
doesn't set up that trap all about the
cheap tricks in this position but uh
Knight to C6 as well very sensible move
might later jump into this nice Outpost
might later jump towards the center
to me it feels like Black's position
just
really harmonious yeah and also I just
kind of there's a pattern that is just
like screaming out to me the king and
the queen they're on the same line so if
you get rid of the night the White
Knight on B5 then the Knight can
actually jump forward to the D4 Square
so A6 is imminent
yeah big threats maybe black can even
start using the F Pawn if you need a
another lever to try and open up wise
position
um all these ideas are Black's ideas I
mean the black king is actually very
safe
um it might I mean I was thinking the
black king could be a problem in this
game with with the dark Square Bishop of
white swinging around on that diagonal
but there's never going to be any
threats on G7 because you can't really
ever move your Rook to attack that point
so I can't see any way at all white can
create threats against Black's King but
we've just noted a number of ways that
Magnus can create threats against whites
King and whites King is very precarious
there right in just that little small
Pawn protection in front of it so
definitely a better position for Magnus
but it is messy and when you need to win
Messi is good yeah I love how you're
suggesting pushing the black F4 and it's
not the Dutch defense Simon well I mean
I you know bad bad habits die hard to
hard to get rid of them afraid David
I I just want to throw out the board
Open up The Rook regret it and want to
move it backwards a couple moves later
it makes a lot of sense here going for
the white king which has now parked
itself on F2 I mean that's a really
flimsy cover for the white King right
now it feels like that isn't going to
hold up forever the black Knight's gonna
start coming in the black queen black
Rooks potentially as well
like this slightly low on the clock it
definitely feels like it's not uh he's
not as confident as he was a bit earlier
in the day but still a very good
position for black
so far he just needs to survive stay in
this as long as possible long term all
to play for but short term Black's favor
I guess there's Rook to G1 I like his
last move so at least he can now start
applying it's applying a bit of pressure
and if he can get his Rook to G1 and his
dark Square Bishop back to B2 well all
of a sudden because I've played F5 by
that point I'm in a lot of trouble so
it's like
um so no you're you're quite quick
I do feel that I you know that black has
to be super quick here because if you
let white play some happy moves the
bishop will line up on the long diagonal
and then the Rook so there you go The
Rook has come another happy
but I've never thought about it like
happy happy because they suggest
themselves right no I mean I always call
Happy Muse the ones that suggest
themselves that play themselves you know
you can almost you don't even have to
calculate you just okay The Rook belongs
on an open Line it wants to go and book
out the black king
and then the next happy move if you if
white is allowed is the bishop to
retreat itself to B2 so then it's on a
long diagonal
yeah I mean evaluation part is really
really liking magnus's position but I
think again in practice this is this is
a bit
um it's not as easy as the evaluation
bar is indicating I mean why white has
his own ideas
um as you say that Bishop dropping back
you're already creating a big fret that
Rook can come and attack Black's Bishop
Black's Bishop is a little bit loose in
squares I mean it's not it's not
completely straightforward I I for
Magnus at all
totally agree if I was playing this
position I would think okay maybe I'm
slightly better as black maximum but I
mean it's just complicated I would never
dream that Black's Advantage is so
significant uh like the engine points
out right now but uh here it comes out
I wasn't quite sure about fabi's last
move retreating the night I know it was
under attack but the bishop on A3 is
just stuck there and it has no future I
felt that he had to kind of go on the
counter offensive
with potential tactics or perhaps
putting pressure on G7 and right now
with the bishop on A3 stuck the only
Square I see for that Bishop is C11
right that's not a happy move that's a
very sad move isn't it uh that's really
cool that Rook B8 move I mean I'm
thinking about great moves in this game
and Rook B8 from Magnus is just not
something I would have thought about but
it's really just taking the sting out of
White's plate because it's all it was
all based around White's bishop and that
Bishop as you say is a very sad piece
now because it hasn't got to that
diagonal so a really really nice
containing move and the last move stops
White's Rook activating so rather than
trying to crush white Magnus is I'm not
going to let you play any moves Fabiano
I'm not letting you play any of the
moves that you likes playing white
White's actually running out of moves
even though the evaluation bar is maybe
liking it a bit more now can the Knight
come round is that is that why the
evaluation bar is like in white maybe
White's Night comes into the center and
then comes to harass the bishop via f4
on the next move I mean that that would
be a very sensible continuation so still
actually still a mess
moved by Magnus 86 does that surprise
you a little bit it felt a bit slow yeah
I'm surprised that Magnus chose it uh I
mean it's the type of move that I would
play and then regret it for not being
Dynamic energetic enough uh of course
the Simon says it kind of prevents this
Rook to G5 move uh trying to kick this
bishop but yeah very very slow and uh
let's catch up with the current position
after white tonight uses the center the
Black Knight jumps in as well maybe some
hints of a check
um but yeah some calculation to be done
the White Knight can drop back to F4
hitting this bishop it's fine we've got
modes David Knight F4 Bishop G6 and
Magnus played 95 at Breakneck speed so
he was anticipating Knight D5 yeah but
it's just a pure mess right now uh we
see wow Fabiano lock up the center this
is really committal he's trying to
render this bishop passive he's going to
maybe try and kick it in the next move
try to line up on the g-file uh but yeah
now you've given up control over all of
the dark squares uh in the center and
also some threats along the third rank
yeah I mean you have to calculate
something taken well Knight takes F3 in
in some positions now because uh that
would allow the black queen to come into
H4 don't think it works but um you know
you have to keep an eye on this kind of
idea
certainly computer doesn't hate it no no
it's not not the worst move on the board
um
yeah they play this is it's just a
really weird position this is not your
standard position it's extremely complex
this remember that white must win Fabi
must win with white to take it to the
playoffs and um he you know in the last
game he managed to get another dynamic
position he did the same actually in
defeating
um young player who I've forgotten
Dennis uh he also took a bad position
but a complicated position to win that
one uh and uh even again evaluation bar
doesn't like it but I think there's a
lot of play left here and this is going
to be very very exciting look at
magnus's time you pointed us out as well
three and a half minutes you know he's
he's he's he's also strugg to make sense
of this bizarre structure
but I still like black in this position
and one of the reasons is that Knight on
E5 after this last move by white that
Knight can't be kicked away for a while
wondering if there's a way for Magnus to
get the queen involved in everything
that we're seeing Queen F6 would be a
happy move that I would like to make but
that does invite white to jump back with
that Knight on that Central Square
hitting that Queen so I don't really
think that it actually makes any
progress by the end of it
yeah I I also was thinking about how to
introduce new pieces into the attack and
so I was looking at unusually for me
moves that give up material so I was
looking at me was like F5
fives to see whether
the funky yeah but the computer doesn't
it doesn't like it but okay and you
might be preparing it because he falls
back with the bishop to eight seven so
gets out of the range of the Knight so
F5 is definitely on his radar trying to
blow open the FL towards the white king
makes a lot of sense and uh it's not
clear what Fabian is going to do okay he
quickly plays the move D3 Black's King
gets out of uh the island of the white
rook and this move is definitely being
prepared uh first maybe he'll guard
against the White Knight jumping in but
still very very complicated uh this
position not clear how Fabiana is going
to improve either you'd love to put your
Rook on the G file but every time this
happens The Black Queen will swooping
and uh yeah just Magnus playing slow
steady build up moves I think he's just
trying to speed up now uh on the clock
and just telling Fabi okay I'm going to
play this move I'm kind of declaring
that right now uh you have to be ready
for it
or predictions anyone
well I mean it's a mess right I mean I I
think it's really hard to predict uh
predict what will happen here I mean
black black seems to be in a preferable
position but
you know
I can't predict what's on the clock no
we're two and a half minutes really
anything can happen despite black having
an advantage uh in this position and
everything under control active pieces
but that's that's not enough amount of
time to feel safe and uh it's the kind
of position where the price of an error
is pretty high as well so anything can
happen all three results possible
and the green has been introduced into
the attack again also taking care of the
E6 weakness we are going to see F5 and
then it all just blows up
White's root canal also move to the G
file uh that's that's one of the
disadvantages at some point and here we
come F5 it's coming to life here uh
all pieces are attacking now for pretty
much both sides right
even The Rook on B3 is Super Active it's
doing a great job of keeping that Knight
on F4 forced to defend and connected
with that pawn on D3 so it just feels
like when Magnus has played at five all
his pieces are ready for this yeah all
of the black piece is definitely ready
it's just that white Bishop which could
be improved I guess White's Rook on H3
is going to slide across but that needs
to be improved urgently
yeah I love that uh that message uh from
twitch there it is the Wild Wild West
now Magnus has lit the touch paper and
uh Fabian is saying okay I'm gonna meet
fire with fire White Queen slid across
that was threatening Checkmate in one uh
hitting the G7 Square forcing Magnus
into the retreating and okay will that
momentum change retreating normally
isn't a good sign but uh okay maybe he's
just gonna ring his Rook across Fabiano
trebled up with his pieces now he's
creating some Frets here oh wow but
Magnus wow I mean Magnus played this
very quickly not afraid of Rook takes
porn and Rook takes pawn it nearly oh I
mean that that very scary move but
Magnus is prepared Knight takes Pawn
check there and uh David I mean it's
getting even more wild wild Westy now
and I'm thinking Will Smith when I say
that but this is crazy Simon the three
pieces together uh for example if the
Black Knight takes now this would be a
losing blunder because suddenly look at
this dormant Bishop which was asleep for
so long suddenly along this uh longest
possible diagonal delivers the killer
blow and uh black would have to lose his
Queen just to eliminate this bishop this
is totally crazy if I'll be honest
thinking about it
and it's so easy to forget about that
Bishop David Anthony pointed out Bishop
to B2 is a Checkmate in that position I
didn't even know that it could come into
the attacks so you've got to watch out
here with the black uh things are
changing yeah they're changing and we do
see Fabiano recapture that pawn in the
middle and still white still has the
threat of Rook takes pawn and Bishop B2
as well at the right moment you've got
to watch out that the Rook on f8 is
attacking that Knight on F4 but once the
bishop lands on this diagonal it can be
super dangerous for black king and
there's five more pieces are gonna be
thrown towards that poor G7 Pawn you
know if Magnus defends it then there's
going to be the Knight coming to H5 and
I think Bishop B2 is a great move as
well I mean you've got Bishop takes H6
ideas and as well and the Magnus one and
a half minutes to defend against an
all-in Fabiano and uh Fabiano's
attacking hardcore here so he's going
for a counter-attack so he's aiming to
take the pawn with check if Magnus Dives
in and uh this is this is trying to at
least tie down some of Fabiano's pieces
here with that Queen can Fabi do the
impossible can he make a big comeback
from being 2-0 he's already won one game
he needs to win this one to force an
Armageddon meanwhile big updates coming
in on the alireza board alireza ferusa
on the brink of a win and this would
mean match over
what's going on here he's got two minor
pieces for a rook yeah it's like two
volcanoes erupted at the same time
ferrugia now is threatening a nasty
checkmating attack he's just slid his
Queen across one square threatening to
jump into the G6 square and I think we
have to jump in here Wesley so in huge
trouble only with two and a half minutes
left on the clock and just the last
couple of moves this one has really
sprung to life here Wesley is level
material he decided to take this Pawn
maybe living to regret this this has
opened up the beautiful light squared
Bishop towards the king and maybe this
is the one he missed Bishop takes pawn
and you cannot recapture Bishop takes
Knight now would lure the black queen
into the center walking into a family
Fork hitting the king queen and Rook
this would be devastating of course
black in the end dropping the Knight
back but this killer blow potentially
Queen to B1 threatening to slide in for
example Bishop takes Bishop now would be
devastating Queen to G6 this Pawn is
pinned and this will end in Checkmate
instead he had to push his Pawn forward
and after a trade of Bishops on f8 I'm
expecting
wow next move simply ferrush is going to
come in with this queen and the Knight
coming to F5 we know what that Knight is
capable of once it lands on F5 a lot of
nasty things
yeah I mean it's it's I mean White's
pieces are are flowing brilliantly here
and the the real strength uh in uh for
Ali raiser's game is when he when he is
attacking he spots these opportunities
uh uh really really well lucky like like
Gary Kasparov he always reminds me of
Gary Kasparov from the energetic play uh
that Gary used to put on his opponents
and here yep the queen coming over and
the Knight coming in it looks really
really strong and this could be could be
the game that puts a little razor
through to the next round yeah
actually really bad news for Wesley not
only does he lose this and get
eliminated to okay Eliminator gets
pushed down to the lower bracket but it
doesn't secure that spot in the Toronto
final yeah let's remind everyone if
Wesley wins this game he's already
through to the season and final but
losing it he would still have a chance
he needs to finish in top four in the
Julius bear generation cup to make it to
Toronto but uh this one will hurt it
definitely will hurt and there we can
see the White Knight landing on the
beautiful F5 Square now the queen at
night are circling around the black king
and while Magnus Carlson has just
blundered uh in the other game this one
looks like it's over for Rouge it's
about to jump in with his Queen and
deliver a Checkmate I think we have to
jump Magnus has just missed this
beautiful move look at Fabiano Flex
there stretching he's a piece up he has
an extra Knight and it's all about the
dark squares White's Bishop is actually
lurking we'll go through an action
replay in a moment but simply a piece up
here for uh Fabiano he's gonna win he's
gonna win two games in a row against the
the brilliant Magnus castle and take it
to uh Armageddon oh my God incredible it
followed that was impossible to do when
it was 2-0 you win one you win the
second one and that Rook was on pre but
couldn't have been taken because of that
dark Squad Bishop that we've been
pointing out and maybe we'll have a look
at it at another time David but Fabi
he's taking it to an Armageddon yeah
Fabiano he's doing the business here he
counter-attacked that white Bishop
finally springing to life a little
question here to answer Waits rookers
attacked on H6 or is it and the White
Knight on E6 as well slightly loose but
uh I think you can defend that you can
kind of solve that in a few ways now
right now
at the very least you can take that
black Bishop with your Rook but okay
Fabiano can he close this game out now
under one minute because you don't want
to give the material back right if you
have an alternative to keep that X your
piece you want to hang on to it so is
there a way that I can maybe sidestep
with the King creating that threat of
Bishop F6 it's worked for him before
I'll try it again I agree with you
oh he's is he giving the piece away no
he's counting on Rook takes Knight and
then the two Rooks will line up on the H
lines but look at the bar has changed a
lot I mean the problem here is that um I
I think the white king is is quite
exposed right so uh you know the the
black Rook on C2 can also do a number of
checks and force it to go to a very bad
Square so uh Rook takes Knight here
might just be playable in this position
yeah
um this is what that was a crazy move I
mean sidestepping the king like you
mentioned Tanya seemed so sensible don't
retreat unless you have to they're both
very short of time here you see that
Rook checking first of all forcing the
king to a bad Square yeah and don't
forget that all the white remaining
pawns are dropping so at the very least
even if black loses his Bishop uh
White's pawns there just lined up in a
row like Skittles there just you're
gonna wipe them out all in one go and uh
here we go it's uh elimination time if
you're just left with two Rooks and a
bishop against the two black Rooks with
no pawns left
won't be many winning chances no that's
right and uh yeah that was a big Miss of
Fabiano who did so well to get back in
the game he was a piece up he was
attacking he had a great position and he
just retreated he just played this
passive move at the wrong time there
going backwards rather than forwards
that was a massive moment and maybe in
just a few David you can show us what
exactly was the way forward for Fabi
there yeah I think we just have to jump
in and uh just a quick uh slow motion
replay of what happened here actually
Magnus Carlson was doing quite well he
should have given a check he needed to
keep his Rook on B2 oh sorry on B7 to
prevent the white Bishop using the
square he brought his Rook across
missing this beautiful Blow from Fabiano
allowing the white Bishop now to deliver
a killer blow but it was just a few
turns later uh Fabiano still had the
same idea he did not need to move this
Rook as he pointed out Tanya just moving
the king would have won the game because
this would have been a devastating
Checkmate he would have kept his Knight
on the board kept a winning attack
instead retreating that Rook did allow
the Knight to be eliminated and let's
catch up with the current position all
of white spawns are gone this one should
now be a draw black has three pawns for
the bishop level material and as long as
Black's King doesn't get checkmated this
is going to be a draw
still some chances maybe if you can
coordinate the white Brooks and the
Bishops to the bishop to to attack the
king I mean you have to you have to try
to create some chances against uh
Black's King here I mean it's not
completely dead as of yet and the time
situation that that's going to be a key
factor
's laughed out there we see Magnus given
a check it's been intercepted well look
at this I mean it's still corn has
disappeared from the board still seems
really really unclear to me this uh that
Bishop you know is still a bishop and
meanwhile there is an update farugia has
indeed closed out that game against
Wesley so we left it with a decisive
Advantage for him and he was about to
deliver Checkmate he had an extra Bishop
as well so Wesley resigns and is pushed
down to the other bracket
could we even see rooken rook and Bishop
versus Rook uh potentially in this one
uh if the pawns get removed and a pair
of Rooks come off which is a draw but
not an easy drawing you see here white
is definitely going to push this one on
right I mean he's got a bishop for a
pawn it's not clear to me
if I didn't know with the evaluation bar
that this is actually a draw I wouldn't
notice yeah and uh actually at the World
Cup there was that fast there was one
fascinating end game of this exact
position basically but without Black's
pawn and that should be a draw as well
but harder work with all the Rooks on
the board uh Magnus here he needs to
trade off one set of Rooks if he wants
to secure safety uh with all the Rooks
on the board the black king will never
be entirely safe Fabiano can play this
one forever I think we're gonna see a
150 move game here Fabiano has to push
this to the very end to The Bitter End
while Magnus tries to defend and trade
off Rooks yeah a Magnus just sitting and
waiting uh in this position there's not
much else he can do and Fabiano's got to
try and create some chances I mean like
his one idea here is go Bishop D4 and
try to win magnus's last Pawn uh that
would open up the black king uh to more
checks on the Rooks so that scene is a
very sensible idea yeah
because the king is not well placed
in an unsearing Rook ambition versus
Rook end game
it's always tricky I mean I rook and
Bishop versus Rook I mean Magnus knows
how to draw that but
you know I've seen so many top players
lose that ending uh but they're not
Magnus so that is the difference right
fabi's best chance in this end game is
to keep all the pieces on the board not
trade off either of the Rooks and to try
and win that jeep on so that you can try
and give another Checkmate to Magnus
Carlsen but giving one Checkmate in a
day I think it's uh it's kind of hard to
give to checkmates to Magnus here Magnus
continues to play a dominant countries
to play confidently but both players now
under 30 seconds is clock going to be a
bit of a factor especially Magnus he's
touching the 15 second mark
yeah I feel like Fabiano has to hustle
on the clock here uh if Magnus is able
to build up time build up increment get
closer to the one minute mark
especially that in-game Bishop versus
Rook where he knows the defensive
techniques I think he would hold that in
his sleep so you need to kind of push
him down on the clock as low as possible
and then maybe go for that end game uh
it's not going to be easy I could have
watched out for the 50 move rule of
course as well Magnus he's found a safe
haven for his King the Black Brook is
going to protect along the sixth rank as
well Fabiano's struggling to make
progress here and when was
the game let's get an update on that to
keep an eye on the 50 move rule
approaching that Fabi will have to take
a decision to go for that jeep on
because Magnus isn't pushing that pawn
anytime soon the last capture was moved
60 so we are about to reach the 30 move
Mark Fabiano needs to either capture a
piece or Force the black pawn to push in
the next 20 moves
well at some point he'll probably have
to exchange a pair of Rooks off and just
try to win uh rook and Bishop versus
Rook if he can get to it uh even even
though it's not clear he's going to win
that last Pawn ever
um I mean as there's probably a good
chance he will but how else does he make
progress say he's got a the only the
only other PC he can use is really his
King here and uh he can't really get
that anywhere great in the position
that's gonna gonna help uh pressurize
fabulous King Magnus ever been forced to
defend a Ricky King versus Rick and
Bishop because it's David
I mean I I I don't know it's a good
question actually because I would
imagine he's probably more used to being
on the other side right that's right
it's one of you on the other side if I
remember correctly I think I do recall
him defending one at least
um there's also a game between Maxine
Russian degrav and Magnus Carlson where
vashi the garage just didn't even try to
beat Magnus despite the extra Bishop in
that end game because he was confident
Magnus would draw it but uh either way
Fabiano he's running out of time he's
got 14 moves now to win that black porn
or to trade off a set of Rooks he has to
take uh his fate into his own hands and
do something otherwise his chances will
disappear just due to that 50 move rule
he's not making any progress whatsoever
here David would you be confident
drawing the ending rook and Bishop
versus rook and this is what we're
thinking might happen if Fabiano decides
to swap a pair of Rooks off because he's
running out of time the 50 move rule is
encroaching on them where it'll be
automatically decided to draw but you if
you'd be confident David or it's
classical I'd be pretty confident 10
seconds on my clock I don't think I'd be
confident in any position let alone that
difficult end game almost reaching the
50 move Mark is that 60 right so another
five moves to go five moves
difficult to do stuff here seven seconds
he get Rooks off the board oh so he's
trying to swap he's trying to offer some
kind of trade okay if I would be five
yeah like this is clever he won't
exchange here he'll just keep his on the
board the rugby five doesn't work you
can just take it as well so I mean uh
and okay so like I said
be careful the black king is in the
wrong place the white king is in the
wrong place as well two more miles to go
two more moves
oh Bishop takes G7 Bishop takes Pawn now
yeah well no unfortunately there's some
Rook checks
oh and here we go is it gonna be a draw
he should have taken the Rook
it Bobby did not realize it oh wow and
it automatically stops 50 move rule has
been reached and with that he had the
opportunity to keep going with the trade
on that last move
and Magnus Carlsen has got to be feeling
the relief after that with two big wins
at the start it looked like it was going
to be easy but Fabi Strikes Back in game
three and so close in game four yes so
close but uh in the end it was just a
big mistake from Fabiana caruana at a
critical moment but wow what a fight
what a fight David what was the critical
moment when things could have turned
around oh wow the critical moment was so
long ago I can barely remember I just
want to show uh that when we Mutual
blunders earlier but I just want to show
where Fabiano could have at least
prolonged the game and could have kept
his chances alive in this match and it
was here just one move before the 50
move rule kicked into effect and the
game was declared drawn automatically he
could have forced that prolific end game
that famous end game Rook takes G7 here
check would have forced the black Rook
to recapture and here we would have seen
Magnus having to show his endgame
technique this is a draw with rook and
Bishop versus the soul black Rook but it
would not have been easy we would have
seen 50 more moves of torture and decent
chances for Fabiano so he tried hard in
the end not quite close enough
for what a performance even coming back
in that game three a brilliant game by
Fabi but it is Magnus Carlsen who
continues in the Winner's bracket and he
will be playing against the Ali alireza
firuja in the winners final and this was
our score line with Magnus taking on
Fabian then winning with two and a half
to one and a half alireza fuja winning
that final game against Westy so uh and
taking his match and we are being joined
by Magnus Carlsen after his win against
Fabi hackness congratulations and what a
match this was
can you hear us Magnus thank you
um
I really ran out of energy towards the
end
um the last two two games were pretty
pretty Dreadful but I I got the win so
yeah
something
uh it was uh it was a great match Magnus
in the first two games you were making
it look really easy and we were super
impressed convincing stuff what happened
in game three
well what I just said
you ran out of energy
yeah I mean
um
to be fair he played he played a very
good game uh I think I was better from
the opening uh but that was kind of by
Design since he had to win and then uh
after that he played a lot better than I
did
um and then the fourth games
was bad as well but it's okay
um
yeah as I said you know
I just run out of energy and
the games were um four unfortunately was
there ever a moment that you thought
that this would go into an Armageddon
I didn't really care
and uh Magnus there was an opportunity
just before the 50 move rule kicked in
uh for Fabiano to go into the infamous
rook and Bishop versus Rook end game how
confident would you have been of drawing
that one
pretty confidence
just checking
and I did miss presentation I only saw
it after I met them
all right uh Magnus uh we know it's been
uh it's been a long day and you are
tired but just one last question you
will be playing alireza faruja in the
Winner's final and looking ahead at that
match uh uh give us your thoughts uh how
you're going to approach it
I'll probably have to play better than I
did today
[Music]
it's gonna be interesting too
to face in my I haven't faced him a lot
in in these matches over there the last
couple of years
um
in fact I cannot remember
that I kind of remember even one match
that I had to replace the last couple
years
magazine famously said that if
World Championship you were you know
you'd consider playing against him so is
it always fun for you to play uh is it
is it a match up that you look forward
to
yeah for sure
um he's um both very strong and
uncompromising players
the games are always um always good
we look forward to that one Magnus get
some rest and all the best for tomorrow
thank you
Magnus Carlsen saying that he could feel
the fatigue and the lack of energy in
those last two games Fabiano caruana
coming super close to taking it to the
Armageddon and Magnus will be fighting
against feruja in the Winner's final and
this was the matchup that we just saw
Fabiano caruana has been knocked down to
the elimination bracket a pretty high
accuracy rate there uh David yeah for
both players uh Magnus we're used to
that from him and Fabiano I think maybe
that accuracy was affected by the uh
second game where he was already
struggling out of the opening but in
general very high quality match and
close in the end just came down to a few
moves uh that decided it it does look
very tired though
yeah I know the feeling you know it's
been a long day of Chess there's been
some great games going on and uh you
know it's exciting to commentate on but
it's tough yeah I mean you're
calculating the whole time you're trying
to work stuff out he's just come from
the World Cup where he won so you know
he here he's going to be tired
yeah well and uh the other winners
bracket finalist is joining us alireza
after his win against Wesley uh alireza
congratulations
thank you
I'm wrapping that up in that fourth game
three games that ended with a draw what
happened there because it felt like an
Abrupt end what happened in game four
yeah um I think Wesley likes with energy
at the end he blundered of course with
Bishop H7 he blundered the
um two piece for a rook so I had the
advantage from early on and then I had
to find few more accurate moves and then
I had a very good position so
um I think he just lacked energy after
all the three games because it was very
sharp the three games so
makes sense
yeah it was the first three games ended
in a draw but they were big fights and
tough battles and your opening of choice
for today with the black pieces seemed
to be the king's Indian defense is that
an opening that you enjoy playing
alireza
yeah um
it's it's a good opening everything is
still but nobody plays it anymore but
um especially against Wesley I think
it's a good idea for instance I played
him once in classical and he took on E5
he exchanged the queen against me so I
sat in Rapid for sure I have chance
against him in King's Indian so
um it's not his style so much but of
course it's a not the best opening to
play with black so
that's very interesting that it was an
opening approach more because of uh you
playing against Wesley and you thinking
that that would be a good opening Choice
against Wesley and looking ahead you're
playing against Magnus in the winners
final uh tomorrow uh we had him on
earlier and he's looking forward to that
match uh what about you what are your
thoughts on facing Magnus in a matchup
after quite some time
honestly I'm just happy that I'm I will
get more broadcast time because my
parents are watching you guys and you
guys never show me so now at least
you even show me and they could watch it
so this is a good news at least
a big hello to your parents uh from our
side alireza
say to your parents and uh Larissa I'm
curious um you decided not to play the
World Cup uh can we ask why and uh were
you watching the event
yeah for sure I was watching even the
reason I didn't play was just because I
didn't see myself play one month
everyday chess so it was just too much
for reacting to compete so
um for me going to one place and stay
there for one month to play it's a bit
weird so I decided just to
skip that turn on because of this
chasing
well we missed you seeing uh at the
World Cup but we're so happy to have you
back with us in the Champions Chester
and alireza how important is it uh for
you to try to get that spot into Toronto
and how motivated are you for that
yeah
um it's I think it will be a great
tournament in Toronto so I will try my
best and so of course it's a good
motivation for me to qualify for it so
um I will try my best it's uh it's a
thing that I like to qualify so
yeah we wish you all the best it's all
it's awesome to see you on the board and
good luck for tomorrow
thank you
with a big win against world number
eight Wesley so and he will be taking on
Magnus Carlson tomorrow and a very high
accuracy rate there as well for both
players slightly more for alireza yeah
wow putting Magnus Carlsen and Fabiana
to shame 96 is incredibly high and uh
yeah it kind of reflects what we said
earlier in the day just really really
close match here uh neither player
making significant mistakes in the end
it was Wesley who tired and uh allowed
alireza to pounce in that final game but
uh yeah if you can keep this up alorisa
he's got great chances against Magnus
tomorrow better make sure we show his
game tomorrow as well we've got a bit of
a telling off there so uh sorry about
that he does play very exciting chess as
well so we've gotta we've got to show
that match we will be showing that match
as he takes on Magnus Carlton in the
winners final we will also have a lot of
big matchups before that in the losers
bracket let's take a look at some of the
other big high accuracy rates from
today's matchups as another back up to
satro of Knocked Out Pavel Eleanor from
the Julius bear generation cup with a
96.6 accuracy Ivanka yeah that is an
impressive score and of course he was
also really impressive as well you know
the way that he just dispatched early on
off I mean it just means that he's back
in form and yesterday was just an off
day
and the other player who was super
impressive Dennis lazowik he lost the
first game to Armin Tabata by then wins
the second one and goes on to win a
thrilling Armageddon and look at that
accuracy by the 16 year old at 92
percent of what a performance there
today by him Simon
yeah very very impressive and um looks
like it could be leading Apple in that
picture as well you know because uh but
yeah I mean he's just a really good
player for his agent just a really
mature player
we're gonna have big fights all across
tomorrow as we go into day three of the
Julius bear generation cup let's take a
look at our
brackets
for the day's action that is coming up
uh I'm in top have been knocked out of
the event Wesley so knocked down by
alireza farouza will play against Dennis
lazowick A Clash of generations there
and Fabiano caruana knocked down by
Magnus Carlsen takes on another back up
to satro later in the winners final we
will have to pick Marcus Carson against
the alireza furuja what are you most
excited about for tomorrow I think it's
going to be the big final but well the
winners final between Magnus Carlsen and
iraza furuja I mean alireza has played
so dynamically so in such a sharp smart
way and I can't wait to see how Magnus
will create for that
yeah I'm I'm the same I mean you can't
really pick another match there can you
it has to be that match I mean Magnus
wanted that match for the World
Championships he's going to get it
tomorrow and uh they're both such
exciting players when they play against
each other they play so many games
online and uh yeah I think we're all
looking forward to that one yeah that's
the main course but I'm also excited
about the appetizers and uh especially
the clash between caruana and Abdul
sotorov it's a repeat of one of the
finals we saw earlier uh in the season
in the chess kick carp and there
abdusator of Triumph so uh yeah Fabiano
he played really really well today after
he's up to this game as well it's gonna
be a tight Clash of that one a bit of a
grudge match that one for Fabiano
caruana and as David says big appetizers
and then a big big main course with
Magnus Carlsen taking on alireza I'm
also very excited to reveal our winner
of the trivia question that we had uh
let's bring up our trivia question for
the day it was a tough one who is the
youngest player to qualify for the
candidates and when it's also a bit of a
trick question let's reveal the answers
first
Bobby Fisher that's correct well I went
1968.
and you also have Bobby Fischer Bobby
Fisher yeah
I've known 1963 yeah okay probably most
of you are wrong it was in 1958. 58 I
was only 15 years old
I meant 58. that's actually five if you
look very if you look very closely that
says five
[Applause]
and there is our today's winner a huge
congratulations to Isaac I'm sorry if
I'm butchering that name but uh we all
congratulate you here from the studio
and the answer is Bobby Fischer in the
1958 qualification to the candidate it
was a trick question because Magnus
Carlsen also did qualify in 2007 he was
younger than Bobby Fisher but he never
ended up playing other candidates then
but he will be back tomorrow for a match
against alireza a player that he was
willing to play the world championship
title for and that's one match you don't
want to miss we will be back with all
the action we'll see you then
well
oh turning a blunder on the board from
Fabiano
it automatically stops Festival rule has
been reached
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you